. VERY OKAY GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE WELCOME OUR SOMETHING
THREE HEARING ON CLIMATE CRISIS
RESOURCES ENERGY AND
TRANSPORTATION TODAY IT'S ALL
ABOUT TRANSPORTATION PROPOSALS.
WE'RE IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN
AND THE PANELISTS ON THE AGENDA
WILL BE APPEARING REMOTELY USING
ONLINE TECHNOLOGY. WE WILL BE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THIS HEARING BOTH IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE
THE PHONE NUMBER. TO CONNECT TO
IS ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD ALSO BE ON YOUR SCREEN IF
YOU'RE WATCHING OVER THE
INTERNET. THE PHONE NUMBER IS
TOLL FREE. 877-692-8957 THAT'S
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE YOU'LL NEED
TO USE IS ONE THREE ONE. FIVE
ONE TWO SEVEN AGAIN THAT'S FOR
ONE THREE ONE FIVE ONE TWO
SEVEN. IF YOU ENCOUNTER ANY
PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE AT
NINE ONE SIX THREE ONE NINE. TWO
ZERO NINE NINE THAT'S.
916-319-2099 A STAFF MEMBER WILL
BE AVAILABLE TO ASSIST YOU. WE
ENCOURAGE THE PUBLIC TO PROVIDE
WRITTEN TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
HEARING AND- YOU CAN EVEN DO
THAT DURING THE HEARING PLEASE
SEND YOUR WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO.
BUDGET SUB THREE AT A. S. M. DOT
CA DOT GOV AGAIN THAT EMAIL
ADDRESSES. BUDGET SUB THREE B.
U. D. G. E. T. S. U. B. THREE
NUMERAL THREE. AT ASM DOT CA DOT
GOV. I THINK WE HAVE ENOUGH
PEOPLE HERE TO TAKE A ROLL CALL
THAT. MAY BE THE FIRST TIME EVER
. LET'S DO IT BLOOM. HERE
SENATE. HERE FRIEDMAN. YOUR ONE.
PATTERSON RIVAS YEAH THERE.
GREAT SO WE HAVE A QUORUM AND-
THAT MEANS WE CAN BEGIN WITH THE
VOTE ONLY CALENDAR THERE ARE TWO
ITEMS ON THE VOTE ONLY CALENDAR
PHOTOS THE ONLY ISSUE ONE AND
TWO. DO WE HAVE A MOTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND MAY WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE
BLOOM HI SENATE. EVEN AT ONE HAD
. RIVAS SMITH. GREAT THANK YOU.
WILL MOVE ON TO ITEMS TO BE
HEARD AND ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUSINESS
PLAN WE HAVE FIVE THREE
INDIVIDUALS ON OUR PANEL TODAY
HELEN KIRSTEN THE PRINCIPLE
FISCAL AND POLICY ANALYST WITH
THE L. A. O. LOUIS THOMPSON THE
CHAIR OF CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL PEER REVIEW GROUP. AND THE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY MISTER BRIAN KELLY
WILL BEGIN WITH MS KIRSTEN.
MORNING HEARING MEMBERS MY NAME
IS HELEN CRISTINA THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR INVITING
ME I'M THIS MORNING WE PREPARE
TO HAND OUT TO ACCOMPANY OUR
REMARKS YOU SHOULD HAVE A COPY
AND NOW IT'S ALSO AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE. AND FOR THAT FROM
HOW LONG HOME IT'S ALSO ABOUT
AVAILABLE ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE- I MEAN I THINK THE
BEGINNING OF A HAND OUT- AND-
TIME I KNOW WE HAVE A VERY FULL
AGENDA ALSO WHICH IS A REALLY
SHORT SUMMARY OF THE MAJOR
FEATURES AT THE BUSINESS PLAN-
TO DROP BUSINESS PLAN. NELSON
RECENTLY ISSUES FACING THE
LEGISLATURE THAT CONSIDERS THIS
TRACK PLAN AND THE PROP ONE A.
APPROPRIATION THAT'S BEFORE THE
LEGISLATURE- AND FINALLY A
HIGHLY DECISIONS FACING THE
LEGISLATURE. ARMS IF YOU WANT TO
FOLLOW ALONG I'LL BEGIN ON PAGE
SIX WITH JUST VERY BRIEF
DISCUSSION SOME OF THE MAJOR
FEATURES OF THE PLAN. OVERALL I
WE NOTE THAT THE DRAFT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUSINESS PLAN IS
REALLY VERY SIMILAR TO THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN THAT
THE LEGISLATURE SAW LAST YEAR
I'M FOR EXAMPLE THE PROJECT
DELIVERY PLAN IS ALMOST
IDENTICAL TO THE PLAN AND THAT
WAS. THE TWENTY TWENTY PLAN I
THE DRAFT PLAN CONTINUES THE
AUTHORITIES APPROACH THAT WAS
FIRST PRESENTED AND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN I'M REALLY FOCUSING THE
STATE'S EFFORTS ON CONSTRUCTION
OF A SEGMENT BETWEEN MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD THIS INCLUDES
CONSTRUCTION OF THE ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILE SEGMENT BETWEEN
MADERA AND CHAPTER THAT'S
CURRENTLY UNDER CONSTRUCTION. AS
WELL AS EXTENSIONS TO MERCED AND
BAKERSFIELD. AND THE THIRTY
PROPOSES TO LAUNCH INTERNET
SERVICE ON THIS- STATEMENT
HOPEFULLY BY THE END OF THE
DECADE. ALSO TO PLAN TO MAKE
PROGRESS TOWARDS THE REST OF
PHASE ONE AND IN THE NEAR TERM
THAT MEANS COMPLETING
ENVIRONMENTAL WORK FOR PHASE ONE
AND THEN A DANCING DESIGN ONCE
THE STATEMENTS ARE
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEARED. I'M
STILL IN PAGE EIGHT WE HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THE MAJOR FEATURES
RELATED TO SCHEDULE AGAIN NOT
MANY CHANGES HERE AND YOU'LL
NOTICE THAT THERE ARE A FEW
CHANGES TO SOMETHING NEAR TERM
ACTIVITIES MEADOWS HAVE BEEN
DELAYED A LITTLE BIT SUCH AS THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS CONTRACT
COMPLETION ADVOCATE OF THAT
RIGHT OF WAY ACQUISITIONS. AND
COMPLETION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEWS FOR PHASE ONE THAT I
MENTIONED- HOWEVER. THE PLAN
DOESN'T COMPREHENSIVELY UPDATE
SCHEDULES AND IT DOESN'T WORK.
FIFTY FOR BECAUSE ACTIVITY
BEYOND THAT CENTRAL VALLEY
SEGMENT. SO THE PLAN INVASION
AGAIN IN TERMS. WILL BE-
PERSPECTIVE. IN TWENTY TWO NINE.
VALUE VALUE WILL BECOME. BY
THIRTY ONE AND FACE ONE BY TWO
THIRTY THREE AND THAT IT SEEMS
THAT THE PRIDE- WILL HAVE FULL.
I'M IF YOU TURN THE PAGE WE HAVE
A THREE YEAR THE- THAT REALLY
HAS. PROBABLY THE BIGGEST THE TO
TWENTY TO DROP- RELATIVE TO THE
TWENTY PLAN- WHICH IS REALLY TO
COST PROJECT. AND EVEN HAD THE
BEEN FULLY UPDATED BUT YOU
NOTICE THAT THERE ARE FEW KEY.
ON THAT. I'M SO OVER YOU'LL
NOTICE THE DRAFT PLAN ESTIMATES
THAT BUT- THE BASE COST TO FACE
ONE- WILL GO OUT BY ABOUT. FOUR
PER THREE BILLION RELATIVE TO
THE THAT WE'RE- IN. TWO TWENTY
PLAN I. SO IN. THEY ALL THERE
NOW AFTER. AT BETWEEN EIGHTY SIX
POINT SEVEN BILL EIGHTY EIGHT
POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS. AND
THAT'S REALLY IF YOU'RE BY THREE
CHANGES SEE HERE THEM MOST BY
TWO OF THE IN THE SOUTHERN. AREA
AND THOSE ARE STATEMENTS THAT
WERE RECENTLY ENVIRONMENTALLY
CLEARED AND SAYS. WHAT HE'S
PROPOSING ADDITIONAL AT THERE
YOU CAN SEE- BAKERSFIELD TIMBER
SAID AFTER TO INCREASE BY TWO.
SEVEN BILLION OR ABOUT 17% AND
BURBANK TO LA- BY ONE POINT SIX
BILLION OR HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
PERCENT. THEY'RE ALSO VERY MINOR
CHANGES- TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SEGMENT COST ESTIMATE BUT- THOSE
ARE REALLY. VERY MINOR- AND.
AROUND SEVENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS. I MEAN YOU KNOW IT'S
OTHER SIGMA HAVEN'T BEEN. TO IN
TERMS COST. I'M SO IT YOU TURN
PAGE. ELEVEN WE HAVEN'T THING
HERE. AND THIS ONE REALLY
HIGHLIGHT THE PROJECTED FUNDING
FOR THE PROJECT AS WELL AS- THE
CUSTOMER SAID TO BAKERSFIELD. ON
THAT PROJECT CONTINUES TED TO
IDENTIFY A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
SOURCES. OF FINDING AN ESTIMATE
THAT THOSE RESOURCES WILL BRING
BETWEEN ABOUT TWENTY ONE AND
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON WHAT CAP AND TRADE
GOT- AND HOW MUCH WE'RE IN TERMS
OF REVENUE FUNCTION REVENUES IT
PRODUCES- THIS IS A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER THAN WAS ASSUMED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN.
THAT'S LARGELY BECAUSE OF THIS
PLAN ISSUED- BASICALLY TAKES
INTO ACCOUNT THAT WE'VE HAD
SOME- MORE ROBUST ON A RECENT
CAP AND TRADE AUCTIONS. AND
PROJECT THAT THOSE HIGHER
REVENUES COULD INCREASE IT HAD A
SCENARIO WHERE THOSE- THOSE
CONTINUE TO TWENTY THIRTY. I'M
THIRTY THREE. THAT THIS MONEY
WILL BE RUN FIFTY TECH. THE COST
THE WRIST TO BAKER. THANK I'M
KNOW THAT THAT DOESN'T FUNDING
SOURCES FOR THE REMAIN OF ONE.
I'M AND IF YOU TURN TO PAGE
THIRTEEN THAT WE IDENTIFY FOUR
KEY ISSUES FOR LEGISLATIVE
CONSIDERATION- SO FIRST WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S BEEN A RECENT
AGREEMENT- BUT THE AUTHORITY HAS
ENTERED INTO. A REALLY
COMPLICATED LEGISLATIVE DECISION
MAKING SO SPECIFICALLY IN JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE AUTHORITY
ENTERED INTO A REVISED AGREEMENT
WITH THE FEDERAL WORRY GOT GOT
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT EXCUSE ME AS
PART OF THE SETTLEMENT- A
SIMPLIFICATION RELATED TO THE FY
TEN FEDERAL GRANTS. AND UNLIKE
PRIOR AGREEMENTS THAT THE THAT
WE HAD ENTERED INTO THIS ONE
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIES
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT AS A TASK THAT
WILL BE COMPLETED BUT THE GRANT
FUNDS. SO BASICALLY THAT
CONNECTS THE TWO ELECTRIFYING
THE CENTRAL VALLEY SEGMENT
UNLESS IT'S ABLE TO RENEGOTIATE
THE AGREEMENT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. ARE POTENTIALLY PUT
THOSE FUNDS AT RISK. I'M WE DO
KNOW IN A LIKE. ONE HUNDRED NINE
MILES. I'M PROUD WOULDN'T BE
WOULD MAKE A LOT OF SENSE IS
PROBABLY IMPRACTICAL TO RUN AN
ELECTRIFIED SERVICE ON- AND I
THINK MADE BETWEEN. AND CHAPTER
I'M SO SHOULD THE AUTHORITY
ELECTRIFY THE CENTRAL VALLEY
SEGMENT WE THINK IT MIGHT. MIGHT
MAKE SENSE TO EXTEND THAT TO
MORE LOGICAL CONNECTION POINT
SUCH AS MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD-
AND CERTAINLY THE UTILITY OF
THAT STATEMENT WOULD DEPEND A
LOT ON HOW WELL. WE'RE SAID TO
BAKERSFIELD ARC- THIS
CONNECTIONS ARE MADE TO OTHER
SERVICES- ARTIST. MAJOR ISSUE
FOR A- LEGISLATIVE CONSIDERATION
WE I DON'T. THAT EXACTLY TO US
THERE'S THEY'LL BE CIVIC FUNDING
TO COMPLETE PERCENT. STILL
SEGMENT. PROBABLY THIS IS
BECAUSE COST COULD INCREASE AND
I KNOW THAT THEY CAN BE IS VERY
WELL AWARE THAT THERE'S BEEN A
HIS ACROSS INCREASES ON ON THIS
PART. AND CERTAINLY LARGE AND
COMPLEX PROJECTS LIKE- THERE'S
INHERENT RISK THAT COSTS WILL
INCREASE ALSO BECAUSE REALLY
THERE WASN'T- THERE HAVE BEEN A
LOT OF UPDATES LAST IN TERMS THE
CONSTANT AT THE COST OF MERCED
TO BAKER'S. I'M CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW IT THOSE WERE UPDATED WE
THINK THAT THEY THEY COULD WELL
BE HIGHER ON AND THERE COUPLE
REASONS WE THINK- WE THINK THIS
COULD BE HIGHER IF THEY IF THEY
WERE FULLY UPDATED- ONE OF THEM
IS THAT- THEREARE YOUR STANDING
IS THAT THERE ARE SOME CLAIMS
THAT ARE BEING MADE BY THE
CONTRACTORS ARE CURRENTLY DOING
WORK ON THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I
AND SOME OF THOSE KINDS COULD
POTENTIALLY BE SAID. AND SO ONCE
THOSE COSTS ARE FULLY. INTO THAT
THE COST ESTIMATE- YOU KNOW ONCE
THEY'RE STARTED. BY THICK OR ANY
KIND OF. REACHES SETTLEMENT AND
THERE'S A BROUGHT IN- THAT COULD
CERTAINLY INCREASE COSTS OF THAT
SEGMENT- AND THEREFORE THE
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD. OF ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY ONE MILES ON
THANK. ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD
NOTE THAT EVEN JUST IN THE LAST
YEAR STATE- REALLY THIS IS BEEN
A UP ABOVE. EVEN THAN- DYNAMIC
BUT THERE BEEN THINK BECAUSE
INCREASES RELATED TO
CONSTRUCTION- COST ESCALATION
AND CERTAINLY WE THINK THAT
COULD IT. COULD AFFECT THE COST
OF THE PROJECT. YOU TO RELATE TO
Y. EIGHT IT'S UNCLEAR IF THEY'LL
BE SUFFICIENT FOR RESEARCH TO
BAKER'S. IS THAT SOME OF THE
FUNDING THAT'S PROJECTED MAY NOT
MATERIALIZE. AND WE GOT THAT AS
I MENTIONED BEFORE THE THERE'S
RENOWNED COULD SCENARIO THAT
ISSUE. THAT SORT OF A HIGHER AND
HIGHER REVENUE FROM CAP AND
TRADE THAT WE'VE EXPERIENCED
RECENTLY WILL CONTINUE TO TWENTY
THIRTY AND WE THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY THEY
BASICALLY USE OUR OFFICES
PROJECTION THROUGH TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE EXPENSE. THE
TWENTY THIRTY I THINK THERE'S A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY- RELATED TO
WHAT HAPPENED TRIANGLE DO
PARTICULARLY ARE OUT INTO THE
FUTURE. AND SO IT'S CERTAINLY
POSSIBLE THAT THAT- ESPECIALLY
THAT HIGHER REVENUE SCENARIO- AT
ME NOT TO REALIZE. I WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S NO BY PLAN. WORST
TO BAKER- THE OCCURRING READ
ABOUT THE OF YOU SOME OTHER
FUNDING INCLUDING OF THE SOME
FROM THE FOR TRANSFERRED PACKAGE
WHICH I THEY CAN WILL BE BACK-
EXTENDING CAP AND TRADE TWENTY
FIFTH SICK. SINGAPORE THAT THE
THREE OF TYPICALLY GOT THE 25%
I'M MORE THINKING FEDERAL FOR
YOUTH THREE THE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL WOULD
PROVIDE THEM. GRANT POTS THAT
THE THREE COULD POTENTIALLY
COMPETE FOR. HOWEVER THESE
FUNDING SOURCES- REALLY ARE
SUBJECT TO SIGNIFICANT
UNCERTAINTIES SO IT'S UNCLEAR-
REALLY HOW MUCH THEY'LL THEY'LL
BRING IN. I FOR WE IDENTIFIED
THAT THE AT THE- PRETTY ACTION
THANK CONSTRAIN SOME. SOME
ALTERNATIVES TO THE FUTURE.
THREE WE I DID THREE. ACTIONS
THAT KIND OF TERM MATCH. ONE IS
THAT THE PLANTS AWARD A TRACKING
SYSTEMS. AND THIS WOULD BE FOR
ELECTRIFIED AND NON ELECTRIFIED
TRACKING SYSTEMS LATER THIS YEAR
LATER IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO- AND
SO THAT WILL FURTHER COMMIT THE
STATE TO ELECTRIFICATION AND
REALLY TAKING THAT APPROACH.
SECOND THE AUTHORITIES PLANNING
ADDITIONAL ACT- BEYOND TO BAKER
THINK ADVANCE DESIGN AND THEN
WHAT'S A DANCE IS. THE IT'LL
START TO BE ABLE TO DO THINGS
LIKE- ACQUIRE PERSON AND THOSE
KINDS OF STEPS WILL AGAIN I
KINDA- THIS THE THIS STATE
MORNING. TOWARD COMPLETING-
OTHER PORTIONS THAT. ONE AND
THEN THIRD- WE KNOW THAT THE
AUTHORITY AND- TO SEEK SOME
FEDERAL. I THINK A MENTION
INCLUDING FROM A THE FEDERAL.
BILL AND THERE COULD BE SOME. OF
GRANTED- AND THE LEGISLATURE
SURE THAT WHATEVER PROVISIONS
INCLUDED THIS GRANT AGREEMENT
IT'S COMFORTABLE WITH THEM IN A
LINE WITH LEGISLATIVE. I DON'T
WANT PAGE SEVEN. WE HIGHLIGHT
SOME KEY DECISIONS THAT WE
REALLY THINK THE LEGISLATURE'S
KIND OF WANT TO THINK ABOUT-
THIS YEAR. WE THINK A
FUNDAMENTAL CHOICE REALLY FACING
THE LEGISLATURE IS ITS LEVEL OF
COMMITMENT TO FULLY FUNDING THE
PROJECT. AND THAT'S NOT JUST
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD IS REALLY
FUTURE PHASES AS WELL. DEPENDING
ON THAT SCOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COMMITTED TO FINDING
WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE WILL
WANT TO TAKE DIFFERENT ACTIONS
BOTH REGARDING ITS FINDINGS
RESIDENTS AS WELL AS THE
STATUTORY DIRECTION THAT
PROVIDE- WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
TO LEGISLATURE MAKE ITS CHOICES.
YOU CAN. REACH GOING TO CONTINUE
GOING TO YOU KNOW TAKE SOME
STEPS. THAT WILL PROBABLY. YOU
KNOW ADVANCE PLAN COMPLETE- WORK
AND I LIKE TO PAY WITH A BIGGER
SAY AND- MAKE PROGRESS. TOWARDS
THE- AND THOSE ARE ARE BECAUSE
CENTERS THAT. I'M OF THE
LEGISLATURE COMFORTABLE WE THE
AUTHORITY APPROACH AND IT'S TO
FULLY FUND NOT DISBURSING FIELD
BUT ALSO ALL THE PHASE ONE WE IT
MAKES SENSE TO APPROACH THE PROP
ONE A. AS ITS PROPOSED AND
REQUEST BY THE GUY- WE NEVER
THAT THERE'S SOME RISK THAT
WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE IT JUST
FUNDING TO COMPLY OR SAID TO.
FEEL. BUT THERE ARE HIGHER COST
OR SOME OF THE THAT CAN THINK
THAT. AND ADDITIONAL WE THINK
THAT THEY- I HIGHLY HAD THIS
WOULD HAVE TO COME.
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE COMPLETE
PHASE ONE. UNLIKELY FROM THE
GENERAL. I AND IF THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD LIKE TO
PRESERVE BUT THE BILL TO PUSH
OTHER. APPROACHES AND THEN THE
ONE THAT. WERE INVITED TO. WE
WERE THAT MAKE BUDGET. THAT PER
. ITS NATURAL. POINTS AND IT'S
FIFTY CONTROL THE PROJECT HE HAD
THIS PROJECT DOESN'T HAVE A OF
NOT THIS IS A POINT IN FIFTH
CONTROL WITH THE COULD YOU.
APPROPRIATION AND THIS IS TO THE
LAST. THE LAST MAJOR POOR PROP
ONE A. IT ALREADY PROBABLY WON'T
HAVE TO COME. FOR APPROPRIATION
. FOR QUITE SOME TIME AND IT MAY
NOT BE ABLE OF ACTUALLY. POINT
SO- LEGISLATURE ME WHEN I
PRESERVE THOSE AND ALSO PROVIDE-
FROM STATUTORY CHANGES. THAT-
THAT HELP PRESERVE ITS FOR. SO
WITH HER TO THE THIS IS POINTS.
I A COUPLE OF. THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER. ONE OF THEM IS STILL.
I ON OR ALL OF THE REQUESTED
PROPER EIGHT. AND BEEN THERE FOR
WOULD HAVE TO COME BACK TO ASK
FUNDING- PERMITTING BANDS.
FOURTEEN WE IDENTIFY ABOUT. OF
MODIFYING TO CONTINUE ITS
APPROPRIATION PROJECT HAS SO
IT'S BEEN RECEIVING. TWENTY CAP
AND TRADE REVENUE- AND THOSE ARE
VERY FLEXIBLE MAKING USE THEM
FOR A OF DIFFERENT. 'M THE
LEGISLATURE COULD MY TO THAT FOR
EXAMPLE. CAP AND TRADE ON ANY
BASIS- MEAN A DESIGNS IN THE
CASH MONEY TO THE- AND AGAIN THE
THREE WOULD HAVE TO COME BACK
FOR. A REQUEST THAT WOULD GIVE
LEGISLATURE NATURAL TO. IT'S
CHECK A WITH THE PRIDE. AND MAKE
SURE IT'S ON TRACK. I WOULD BE
TO STAFF. CHIU TO PRESERVE
CHOICES IDENTIFIED. OF ON. COULD
CAN SAY FOR. IT COULD END UP
BUDGET TRAILER LANGUAGE THAT
LIMITS OR PREVENTS THE AUTHORITY
EXPENDING FUNDS BEYOND WHATEVER
SCOPE LEGISLATURE COMFORTABLE
FINDING- EXCEPT AS REQUIRED BY
EXISTING FEDERAL GRANT AGREEMENT
SO YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FOR PHASE ONE TO
THAT'S REQUIRED BY THE FEDERAL
GRANT AGREEMENT. BUT BEYOND THAT
THE LEGISLATURE COULD LIMIT. THE
PRETTY. I THIS WOULD BE. BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET. HAVE A
TRAITS VERY FLEXIBLE THREE SPEND
. ON OUTSIDE THE- VALLEY AND-
BETWEEN THEIR- ABOUT IT COULD
THE LEGISLATURE NOT COMMITTED
TO. MAKE TICKETS COMPLETING WORK
BEYOND THAT YOU CAN PROTECT
RESULT IN STRANDED- IF THE
LEGISLATURE ULTIMATELY DOES.
FIND THE FEATURES. OR EXACT.
POTENTIAL PEOPLE CUTTING DOWN-
FROM CENTER. IF FUNDING THAT I'M
IS CURRENTLY. FOR THAT PERCENT
BIG. THING IS YOU. OTHER PARTS.
I MET- AND ANOTHER OPTION THAT
WE- IT'LL JUST. COULD
ARBITRARILY IT WOULD LET OR PER
. GETS FROM. THIS SUCH AS GROUP
GRANT. TO WORK. NINE IS WHATEVER
THE- COMPRA. WITH SPENDING THAT
WOULD BE. IN STATURE- AND WE
THINK THIS COULD BE IMPORTANT
GIVEN THAT AGAIN YOU'VE ALREADY
HAS A HISTORY OF ENTERING INTO
SOME GREAT AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE
CONSTRAINED LEGISLATIVE CHOICES-
SO THIS WOULD HELP PRESERVE
HELP. THEM PREVENT THAT FROM
HAPPENING IN THE FUTURE. AND
THOSE ARE MY REMARKS AND HAPPY
TO TAKE QUESTIONS WHICH- THE
CORPORATE. THE YOU BEFORE WE
MOVE ON MISTER TOM- I MEAN- TAKE
A MOMENT TO TRIED CEMEX. HERE
THIS MORNING BE. OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL ALWAYS- GEN- A LOT OF
QUEST. AND CALM. AND I'M SURE
THAT'LL BE THE CASE TODAY WE ARE
A LITTLE BIT CONSTRAINED BY THE
CLOCK TODAY AND THAT- MANY OF US
HAVE A- MEETING THAT WE HAVE TO
ATTEND THAT- AT NOON. AND SO-
I'M GOING TO- ASKED THAT WE TRY
TO HOLD THE DISCUSSION ON HIGH
SPEED RAIL- TO AN HOUR AND- AND
TEN MINUTES AND CONCLUDED BY-
ELEVEN AM WE DO HAVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY WITH THE AGENDA IN
THAT- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE- AT ADDRESS ISSUES ONE
THROUGH FIVE AT A MINIMUM BUT
THE REMAINING ITEMS WE CAN-
MOVED TO OUR MEETING BECAUSE
IT'LL HAPPEN ON MARCH THIRTIETH.
MORE ON MARCH THIRTIETH- SO WILL
EXERCISE SOME DISCRETION THERE
IF NECESSARY BUT- JUST GETTING
THROUGH THESE ITEMS- ONE THROUGH
FIVE AND PUBLIC COMMENT WHICH IS
ALWAYS AS ROBUST AS OUR OWN
DISCUSSION- IS ON HIGH SPEED
RAIL- WILL PROBABLY TAKE A SAYS-
WELL- AT CLOSE IF NOT TO UP TO
WERE A LITTLE BIT PASSED THE
NOON HOUR- THAT SAID I WANT TO
WELCOME- CHAIR BOTH CHAIR TANG
AND VICE CHAIR OF THE BUDGET-
FONG- TO OUR HEARING AND TO.
INVITE NOW MISTER THOMPSON. TO
GIVE HIS COMMENTS. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LUKE
THOMPSON I'M THE CHAIRMAN OF THE
PEER REVIEW GROUP. THAT REPORTS
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THE UP
STATUS AND REPORTS OF THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT. BYE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
APPEAR HERE TODAY- I HAVE TO SAY
IT'S ALWAYS DIFFICULT TO APPEAR
AFTER OF HELEN KIRSTEN BECAUSE
SHE USUALLY SAYS EVERYTHING I
WOULD LIKE TO SAY IN MORE DETAIL
AND BETTER. SO IN THE INTERESTS
OF TIME I'M GOING TO- TO HIT THE
HIGH POINTS IN A MAXIMIZE
DISCUSSION TIME. YOUR REVIEW
GROUP WILL BE SUBMITTING A
LETTER TO THE LEGISLATURE WITH
COMMENTS ON THE DRAFT TWENTY
TWENTY TWO PLAN SO WHAT I HAVE
TO SAY TODAY ITS PRELIMINARY.
OVERALL THE TWENTY TWO DRAFT
PLAN DOESN'T BRING MUCH NEW
INFORMATION TO THE TABLE. IT
CONTAINS A CENTRALLY MOST OF THE
NUMBERS AND THE FACTS AND THE
THRUST OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN. THERE ARE SOME
POSITIVE ELEMENTS THAT ARE NEW
AND THEY'RE USEFUL TO RECOGNIZE
FIRST. THERE IS A REAL
POSSIBILITY FOR NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING. THOUGH THE AMOUNTS AND
THE DEGREE OF CALIFORNIANS
PARTICIPATION ARE NOT YET
DEFINED. WE CAN ONLY SPECULATE
ABOUT THE POSSIBILITY FOR OTHER
FUNDING AND FOR EXAMPLE TO BUILD
BACK BETTER BE A WHOLE. LOT IF
ANY BUT IN ANY CASE NONE OF THIS
WILL REFORM TO RESOLVE THE
STATE'S FUNDING PROBLEMS OF THE
PROJECT. THE REASON RUPE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE NEGATIVE
IMPACT OF COVERED ON THE PROJECT
AND THAT IMPACT HAS BEEN
SIGNIFICANT AND WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT. THE
ENVIRONMENTAL CLEARANCES ARE
MOVING AHEAD THERE IS A BETTER
AND MORE POSITIVE RECOGNITION OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF CONNECTIVITY
AND IMPACTS ON LOCAL DEVELOPMENT
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL. THIS IS
IMPORTANT TO THE STATE'S
TRANSPORT NETWORK AND IT
HIGHLIGHTS THE ROLE OF
SUPPORTING AGENCIES NOT JUST THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY IN
THIS IS A POINT WE HAVE TRIED TO
TOUCH ON BEFORE THAT THERE IS
MORE TO THIS THAN JUST SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY'S ROLE. THEN THE
OTHER HAS BEEN INTRODUCING
BETTER MANAGEMENT. INCLUDING
ENTERPRISE RISK MANAGEMENT AND
STAGE PROJECT DEVELOPMENT THESE
TOOLS HAVE BEEN LONG NEEDED THEY
ARE TIMELY AND THEY SHOULD HAVE
AN IMPACT ON MANAGING COST
CONTROLS. BUT AND THIS IS
IMPORTANT. THERE IS A WIDE RANGE
OF UNCERTAINTY ABOUT COST AND
SCHEDULES THAT REMAINS IN FACT
IT PROBABLY HAS EVEN INCREASED
BECAUSE OF A NUMBER OF FACTORS.
FIRST THE CONSTANTS GADGIL
EXPERIENCE SO FAR IS NOT
ENCOURAGING. THE AVERAGE COST
INCREASE ON THE CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT ONE TWO THREE AND FOUR
IS EIGHTY SIX POINT SEVEN
PERCENT. AND THE AVERAGE GRADUAL
INCREASES A 118% REAL ESTATE
PARCELS ARE STILL ONLY 90% THE
CARD THE RIVER ROAD PARTIALS OR
73% REQUIRED IN THE TIER ONE
UTILITY PARCELS ARE ONLY 65%
REQUIRED. THIS IS AFTER SIXTY
NINE YEARS OF CONTRACT AWARDS.
THIS EXPERIENCE DOES NOT INCLUDE
CLAIMS THAT MAY HAVE BEEN FILED
BUT NOT YET RESOLVED AS HELEN
MENTIONED AND IT DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR FUTURE CLAIMS THAT
HAVE NOT YET BEEN FILED BUT MAKE
WILL BE. THE PROJECT BUDGETS
WERE OUT OF DATE. DASHBOARDS
THAT WORD MEANT TO PROVIDE A
BROAD INDICATION OF THE PROJECT
STATUS OVER TIME HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE MAY OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. OF THE TWO PROJECT
NOTES THAT WERE UPDATED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO GRANT BUSINESS
PLAN AS HELEN MENTIONED. BOB
BAKER FEEL PALMDALE UP BY
PERCENT 17% OF BURBANK TO LOS
ANGELES UNION STATION WAS UP BY
A 116% THE NEXT THOROUGH UPDATE
OF COST IS NOT DUE UNTIL THE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE PROJECT- DAY
REPORTS OF THAT'LL BE SOMETHING
MORE THAN A YEAR FROM NOW. THERE
IS AS YET NO EXPERIENCE WITH
MAJOR PROJECT COMPONENTS THAT
REPRESENT MORE THAN HALF OF THE
COST OF THE PROJECT THAT MEANS
TIMELINE ELECTRIFICATION
SIGNALLING AND ROLLING STOCK. IN
THIS REGARD IT'S USEFUL TO NOTE
THAT CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT IS ABOUT 25% OVER
BUDGET. IN THE BART VTA
EXPERIENCE WITH THESE TYPES OF
COMPONENTS HAS NOT BEEN
ENCOURAGING. IN ADDITION AND MAY
BE OVER WRITING THAT'S THE
AFTERMATH OF CODED AND POSSIBLY
OF THE UKRAINE DISCREET WE DON'T
KNOW THIS YET. MAY PRESAGE AND
AFTER A PERIOD OF UNUSUALLY
RAPID COST ESCALATION THAT COULD
TAKE TIME TO WORK THROUGH THE
SYSTEM AND COULD LEAD TO FURTHER
COST INCREASES. OVERALL AS I
SAID THE UNCERTAINTY THAT AND
THIS PROJECT RIGHT NOW IS VERY
SIGNIFICANT AND IT MAY BE
INCREASING. END YOUR LOWER PRIOR
ISSUES AND CRITICAL ISSUES THAT
REMAIN UNADDRESSED AND
UNRESOLVED THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD BE AWARE. PRIMARY
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT HAS NOT
IMPROVED RELATIVE TO THE
CHALLENGES AND THE EXTREME.
RIDER SECOND THE FUNDING AS WE
HAVE SAID MANY TIMES IS
INADEQUATE AND IT'S UNSTABLE AND
THAT MAKES MANAGED OF THE
PROJECT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE. THIRD EVEN WITH
NEW FEDERAL FUNDING THE STATE
CANNOT GET OUTSIDE THE CENTRAL
VALLEY THE PROJECT CAN'T GET
OUTSIDE OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY
WITHOUT ADDED STATE FUNDING FROM
SOURCES THAT HAVE NOT YET BEEN
IDENTIFIED. SO IN SUMMARY WHEN
WE LOOK AT ALL THIS TOGETHER WE
CAN SAY THAT WE'VE COME A LONG
WAY THAT THERE IS FURTHER
PROGRESS IN THIS REPORT BUT WE
STILL HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO
BEFORE WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THE
PROJECT HAD IT IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THAT'S FLOWING UNDER
CONTROL. THANK YOU AND FORCE IF
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I'LL BE
HAPPY TO DEAL WITH. THANK YOU
MISTER THOMPSON- I ALWAYS
APPRECIATE GETTING A REPORTS
THERE ARE- A UNIFORMLY
ELIMINATING CAN WILL PROCEED
NOW. TO OUR- HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER BRIAN KELLY. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS ARE
BRIAN KELLY THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED
RAIL FORTY. I APPRECIATE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT THE
AUTHORITY'S DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BUSINESS PLAN. I'M JOINED
HERE TODAY BY MY COLLEAGUES. ARE
OUR CHIEF FINANCIAL OFFICER
BRIAN ENNIS. THE RELEASE OF THE
BUSINESS PLAN ON FEBRUARY EIGHT
STARTS A SIXTY DAY REVIEW PERIOD
DURING THIS TIME OUR BOARD WILL
REVIEW MANAGEMENT SUMMARY AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TAKE PUBLIC
INPUT. AND HEAR FROM POLICY
MAKERS AND CRAFT THE FINAL
TWENTY TWO BUSINESS PLAN. TO BE
ADOPTED AND SUBMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE BY MAY FIRST OF
TWENTY. BECAUSE OUR TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN WAS
ADOPTED AND PRESENTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE. JUST TEN MONTHS AGO
MOSTLY DUE. TO THE SCHEDULE
CHANGES- OF. SOLUTION WITH THE
COVERT PANDEMIC. WE VIEW THE
STRAP IS A BRIDGE DOCUMENT THAT
ADDRESSES THREE THINGS
PRIMARILY. PROVIDES UPDATES ON
MEANINGFUL PROGRESS IT OUTLINES
NEW OPPORTUNITIES TO DEVELOP A
FEDERAL STATE FUNDING PROGRAM.
UPDATE SOME OF THE AUTHORITIES
PROJECT FORECAST INCLUDING COST
UPDATES AND PREVIEWS THE
UPCOMING TWENTY TWENTY THREE
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT. YOUR
STORY HAS BEEN MAKING PROGRESS
IN THREE KEY AREAS AS LUKE
THOMPSON ALLUDED TO. THESE ARE
IN THE AREAS OF CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITIES RIGHT OF WAY
ACQUISITIONS ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW. SINCE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
DESIGN IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS
EXPERIENCE FROM THE READER
CENTER NEARLY A 100% 71% OF THE
STRUCTURES ARE IN CONSTRUCTION
WORK COMPLETED NOW. 72% OF THE
MILES OF GUIDEWAY ARE COMPLETED
OR IN PROGRESS. RIGHT AWAY TEAM
IS DELIVERED MORE THAN TWO TWO
THOUSAND FIFTY PARCELS TO
CONTRACTORS WHICH IS 90% OF THE
TOTAL NEED. A HIGH POINT IN THE
HISTORY OF THE PROP PROGRAM.
REPRESENTS THIS REPRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS IN THE AREA
THAT IS TRADITIONALLY PLAYED THE
PROJECT. ENVIRONMENTALLY THE
AUTHORITY IS CLEARED NEARLY
THREE HUNDRED MILES. OUT OF THE-
OF THE PROGRAM IS WORKING TO
CLEAR FOUR HUNDRED THIRTIES OF
THE ORDER THIRTY MILES OF THE
FIVE HUNDRED MILE. AS ONE SYSTEM
BY JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
ACHIEVING THESE MILESTONES IS AN
ESSENTIAL STEP FORTY STRATEGY
DANCE THE ENTIRE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM AND SECURE NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES GOING
FORWARD. THERE ARE FEW UPDATES
TO THE PROGRAM THAT REFLECTED IN
THE DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY TWO
BUSINESS PLAN. SPECIFICALLY THE
AUTHORITY IS PROVIDED UPDATED
CAPITAL COST ESTIMATES. IS UP
STATES ARE THESE UPDATES AREN'T
OUTCOME OF THE AUTHORITIES
EXTENSIVE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK AND
STAKEHOLDER OUTREACH REFLECTING
EFFORTS TO MITIGATE IMPACTS. AND
WORK WITH LOCAL COMMUNITIES ARE
PROJECT CHOICE. BE CLEAR THAT
THERE IS NOT A PROJECT UPDATE
INCREASE BETWEEN BAKERSFIELD AND
MERCED. PUBLICLY BAKER SHOW IN
PALMDALE WHICH IS THE EXTENSION
THAT WE DEPARTMENT CLEARED IN
TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WE JUST CLEARED THE
BURBANK TO LOS ANGELES SEGMENT.
GOING THROUGH THAT MANY GETTING
UP SOME OF THE IMPACTS OF THE
PROJECT BECAUSE COMMUNITIES WITH
IDENTIFIED. ACOSTA FEATURE THAT
AND WE CONCLUDED THOSE IN THIS
PLAN. THE THIRTY SPORT HAS THE
AN UPDATE ITS PROBE TO ITS
FORMAL PROGRAM BASELINE BUDGET
UNTIL THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATES OR DETERMINES HOW
THEY WANT TO DO WITH A FOUR
POINT TWO. BILLION VOTER
APPROVED. OPPOSITION ONE A
QUESTION OF APPROPRIATIONS WE'VE
DELAYED THAT FOR TWO FOR REALLY
FOR REASONS. ONE IS THE PENDING
DISCUSSIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE.
MAY AFFECT BOTH PROJECT SCOPE
AND RESOURCES AVAILABLE FOR THE
PROJECT AND WE NEED TO HAVE
THOSE RESULTS BEFORE WE- MOVE ON
WITH A FORMAL PROGRAM A BUDGET
SECOND WE ARE TRACKING SYSTEMS
BIDS ARE DUE IN JULY. THIRD OUR
FINAL SETTLEMENT OF- CONTRACTOR
COMMERCIAL ISSUES WILL RESULT A
LITTLE BIT LATR THIS SPRING.
AND FOURTH ARE THERE WE
RIDERSHIP AND REVENUE UPDATES
BECAUSE THERE'S A NEW RIDERSHIP
MODEL THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY. ARE WORKING WITH OUR-
TRAIN OPERATOR HAS ONE WILL BE
THE PUTTING THAT. USE DROPPED IT
RIDERSHIP AND REVENUE. FOR THE
TWENTY THREE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT. SO I DO I POD THERE AND
SAY THE ARE THE FOUR MAIN RE.
YOU HAVE NOT UPDATED PROGRAM.
BUDGET A LOT OF THAT HAS TO DO
WITH WE ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF
WHAT USUALLY IT YEAR CYCLE
BETWEEN BUSINESS PLANS. AND NOW
WE ARE IN A TEN MONTH PERIOD
SINCE OUR LAST BUSINESS PLAN- SO
WE ARE. UNDERTAKING OF VARIOUS.
YOU KNOW PUT THINGS WE DO THE
JOB IN OUR COSTS BUT THERE'S A
LOT OF UNANSWERED QESTIONS THAT
NEED TO BE ANSWERED. ONE THING I
JUST WANT TO SAY ABOUT THE L. A.
O. PRESENTATION THAT I THINK
DESERVES. UP SOME RESPONSE
PROCESS THAT I WANT TO BE CLEAR.
THE IS NOT RUNNING FORWARD AHEAD
OF THE LEGISLATURE. ON WHAT
WE'RE DOING. WE ARE TASKED WITH
PROVIDING THE LEGISLATURE WITH
OUR PROPOSAL. FOR HOW WE WOULD
MOVE FORWARD IN A CONSTRAINED
BUDGETS. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BUSINESS PLAN DOES HOWEVER. WE
HAVE TO WAIT. ARE TRACKING
SYSTEMS CONTRACT. AND WE HAVE T
WAIT AND ARE NOT EVEN
SCHEDULING. TRAIN PICTURE AT
THIS POINT UNTIL WE HAVE. ALL
BY. WHAT KIND OF TRACKS TO GET
AWAY. WHAT KIND OF TRAINS WERE
GOING TO OPERATE. AND SO WE ARE
NOT. RUNNING AHEAD OF THE
LEGISLATURE WE ARE- THINK NOW IS
THE TIME WITH THIS BUDGET
CONVERSATION. TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. ASSAULT THE
QUESTIONS. THAT REMAIN ABOUT
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO NEXT. AND
THEN WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW TO
MOVE YEAH. AND THAT WE THINK WE
GET THE SIX. FOR NOW. BUT REALLY
THE OF. AS I GOT MORE. SORRY THE
AUTHORITIES ALL IDENTIFIED IN
THIS BUSINESS PLAN. MANY FEDERAL
SEVERAL MULTIPLE PARTS OF
FUNDING AT FROM THE REASON
PASSED BY PART BIPARTISAN
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS ROAD
REPRESENT A REPLY LOVE OF
INVESTOR ENTRANCE. IN THAT HAVE
NOTS FOR DECADES I THINK THE
TOLD FIVE YEAR AS BOB FUNDING IN
THAT THERE WAS SOME HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE BILLION DOLLARS AND
WE'VE IDENTIFIED ABOUT SIX POTS
VALUED AT SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS THAT WE- WE HAVE IN THE
PAST WE DO NEED TO COMPETE FOR
FUNDING. THIS A TREMENDOUS I FOR
THE STATE TO DEVELOP A FEDERAL
STATE FUNDING PROGRAM THAT WILL
ENABLE US TO ACHIEVESEVERAL
THINGS AT THE SAME TIME. ONE
DELIVER AN ELECTRIFIED TO TRACK
INITIAL OPERATING SEGMENT
CONNECTING MERCED PRESIDENT
BAKERSFIELD ISSUE AS POSSIBLE.
STATEWIDE TO ADVANCE ENGINEERING
AND DESIGN WORK IS EVERY
PROJECTS SECTION IS
ENVIRONMENTALLY CLEAR. THAT IS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE THAT WILL
ENABLE US TO VALLEY CONFIGURE
THE PROJECTS STATEWIDE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO LA AND ANAHEIM BUT
MADE WAS TO REFINE COSTS. GET
ALL THE GEO TECHNICAL WORK DONE
MAP RIGHT AWAY IDENTIFIED
LECTURED LECTUED UTILITIES TO
BE MOVED AND YOU'LL GET PREPARED
TO DO ALL THE NECESSARY PRE
CONSTRUCTION WORK BEFORE WE GET
INTO CONSTRUCTION. THOSE STEPS
WERE MISSING IN THE ORIGINAL
CONTRACTS THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE THAT
MISTAKE GOING FORWARD. SO WE
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE-
THAT'S- THE OTHER OPPORTUNITIES
ARE TO DEVELOP- THE OTHER A-
WITH THE FUNNY IS TO IT. IN
JERICHO IN THE AREA SUCH AS THE
CALTRAIN PROJECT OF THE LOS
ANGELES BASIN SUCH AT THE LINK
U. S. R. PROJECT OR PERHAPS
EARLY GRADE SEPARATIONS THAT CAN
BE DONE DOWN THERE. DEVELOP A
SINGLE STATION IN DOWNTOWN
MERCED SO THAT INSTEAD OF. YOU
KNOW A TRAIN OPERATORS GOING TO
TWO SEPARATE STATIONS THEY'RE
GOING TO WANT. AND ALSO THE
OPPORTUNITY ESPECIALLY AS
CONGRESS CONTEMPLATES THE
FINALITY OF THE BILL BACK BETTER
BILL. CRAFTED PETS WALKER
TRANSPORTING STRATEGY TO EXPAND
EXTEND HIGH SPEED RAIL FROM
CENTRALLY BUDGET. IS POSSIBLE.
YEAH BUT ABOVE ALSO I AND CON
THAT ARE BY. THIS PRESENTS AN-
TO CLOSE THE DIVIDE. AND AGREE
ON INVESTMENTS THAT ALLOW
STATEWIDE HIGH SPEED RAIL THE
REPORT ALONG HIGH PRIORITY
REGIONAL PROJECTS. FINALLY THE
AUTHORITY ANTICIPATES COMING
BACK NEXT YEAR WITH THIS PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT THE PROVIDE MORE
CLARITY ON SOME OF THE KEY
ISSUES. THAT WE ARE STILL
WORKING THROUGH AND NEED
DIRECTION AND GUIDANCE ON. WHAT
THE LEGISLATURE. SPECIFICALLY
OUTLINING A FUNDING STRATEGY
THAT WILL BE INFORMED BY
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET DECISIONS.
AND POTENTIALLY FEDERAL ACTION
ON ADDITIONAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES LIKE A BILL BACK
BETTER BILL. ALSO EXPECTED WILL
BE AN UPDATED PROGRAM BASELINE
BUDGET SCHEDULE INFORMED BY
FUNDING COMMERCIAL AGREEMENTS
TRACKING SYSTEMS BEDS. AND
STATION DESIGNS WERE MERCED
BIGGEST ON. WITH FEDERAL STATE-
OFFENDING THAT IS AT A LEVEL
THAT WE HAVE NOT SEEN BEFORE.
AND WHAT WE'RE HOPEFUL OF IS
THAT WE CAN ADVANCE A PROGRAM
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO THIS
BUDGET CYCLE. TO ALLOW US TO
ADVANCE OUR PROGRAM AS WE HAVE
PROPOSED SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN.
AND TO ALSO MAKE IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS IN STATEWIDE
REGIONAL PROJECTS AROUND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND- MISTER
CHAIRMAN THAT IS A QUICK
THUMBNAIL SUMMARY WHAT'S IN
BUSINESS PLAN WITH THAT I'M-
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OF A MISTER CALLIE- WILL PROCEED
NOW WITH- I HAVE QUESTIONS- I'LL
KICK IT OFF- FOLLOWED BY. A
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN TANG AND FONG
AND THEN THE OLD LET ME KNOW- AS
YOU WANT TO ADD YOUR QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS PLEASE AGAIN WITH
THE GOAL TOWARDS THE CONCLUDING
THIS PART OF OUR HEARING AT
ELEVEN AM- SO- A MISTER KELLY. I
THINK- VERY SIMILAR TO LAST YEAR
WE'RE FINDING OURSELVES AT A
CROSSROAD ABOUT HOW TO MOVE THE
PROJECT FORWARD IN A RESPONSIBLE
MANNER IN THE L. A. L. IS OUT
THE CENTRAL QUESTION. TO THE
CONVERSATION AND THAT IS WHAT
LEVEL OF COMMITMENT TO THE
LEGISLATURE WANT TO MAKE. TO
FULLY FUND THE PROJECT NOT JUST
THE- HUNDRED NINETEEN MILES BUT
THE FUTURE SEGMENTS AS WELL. BUT
TO GET TO THAT ANSWER- WE NEED
QUESTIONS ANSWERED. THAT WERE
ASKED LAST YEAR BUT- AT LEAST A
TO MY KNOWLEDGE REMAIN
UNANSWERED WITH THE DRAFT TWENTY
TWO BUSINESS PLAN. THE DRAFT
BUSINESS PLAN DIFFERS A BASELINE
OF THE PROGRAM BUDGET UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY THREE HOWEVER WE
KNOW THAT INFLATION DELAYS AND
THE CURRENT COST OF MATERIALS.
MUST IMPACT THE TOTAL COST OF
THE PROJECT. CAN THE AUTHORITY
EXPLAINED WHY THESE WERE NOT
EVALUATED AS PART OF THE- TWENTY
TWO BUSINESS PLAN. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE ANSWER IS MOSTLY
BECAUSE THEY WERE THEY WERE
EVALUATED IN THE PLAN THAT WE
RELEASED JUST TEN MONTHS AGO.
AND WE HAVE NOT MADE. OF UPDATES
TO THOSE AT THIS POINT WITH
RESPECT TO THE INFLATION THAT'S
A PART OF THE- CONSUMER. PRICE
INDEX FOR THE OTHER ELEMNTS. WE
CONDUCT A REVIEW OF OUR PROPOSED
CONSTRUCTION ESCALATION RATES IN
THE BUSINESS PLAN. AND COMPARE
THAT TO THE US ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS ESCALATION MANUAL
WHICH IS CALLED THE CIVIL WORKS
CONSTRUCTION COST INDEX SYSTEM.
RESULTS INDICATE THAT THE TWENTY
TWO ESCALATION RATES ARE WITHIN
THE RANGES AS COMPARED TO THE
LONG TERM- LET'S WORK WILL
PERFORMANCE OF THE INDEX. AND SO
WE'RE NOT MAKING AN ADJUSTMENT
AT THIS TIME WE NOTE. THAT THE
INFLATION BLIP HERE IS AT THIS
TIME. UP A POINT IN TIME- EVENT
. OUR PROJECTIONS IN OUR
ESCALATION RATES COVER MULTIPLE
YEARS. AGO FOR. A LONGER PERIOD
OF TIME THAT THAT WILL CONTINUE
TO MONITOR AND WATCH. A THAT IT
WILL MAKE ANY ADJUSTMENTS WE
NEED TO MAKE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME BUT AT THIS POINT BSED ON
THE METRIC WE USE. WE DIDN'T WE
DIDN'T MAKE THAT THAT'S- AND
THEN WITH RESPECT TO THE
ADOPTION OF OUR FORMAL BUDGET
WHICH IS INTERNALLY HERE AT THE
OR- WE DID OUR BOARD DID
APPROVED AUTHORIZED EXPENDITURE
THAT WAS CONSISTENT WITH THE
BUDGET THAT WE IDENTIFIED IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN. IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND THAT TOOK INTO ACCOUNT.
CHANGES THAT WE IDENTIFIED IN
THAT PLAN. THAT WE'RE COST
ESTIMATES BASED ON OUR INCREASES
IN THIS VALLEY MOSTLY TIED TO.
OUR SCOPE STILL GETTING IN THAT
A CONTRACT FROM. DECISIONS WELL
BEFORE I ARRIVED HERE- HOWEVER
WE ARE FINALIZING THAT WORK NOW-
BUT THE ACTIONS THAT WE TOOK. IN
THE BUDGET ADJUSTMENTS WE MADE A
WE ESTIMATE WILL BE SUFFICIENT.
TO COVER WHAT WHAT WE HAVE WHAT
WE NOW KNOW WAS ARE NO COST
ESTIMATES IN THAT REGARD. SO AS
WE GO FORWARD AND WE WORK
THROUGH- CONTINUES COPIOUS USE
ON THIS PROGRAM WE WILL UPDATE
AGAIN. AND WE WILL DO. AS SOON
AS WE COMPLETE SOME OF OUR
COMMERCIAL. THAT EXHAUSTION. AS
I UNDERSTAND THAT THE- OF.
NUMBERS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ARE BASED ON. TWENTY
NINETEEN- INFORMATION IS THAT
CORRECT. THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUSINESS PLAN ESTIMATES ARE
BASED ON THE YOU KNOW THOSE ARE
ESTIMATES THAT THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE JUST BEFORE WE RELEASE THE
PLAN AND THE PLAN WAS RELEASED
IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ADOPTED IN APRIL OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WE UP TO UPDATE THEM
AS BEST WE CAN ALL THE WAY UNTIL
THE RELEASE OF THE FINAL PLAN-
AND SO THAT IS THOSE EXCLUDED
ARE ESTIMATES FOR WHERE WE
IDENTIFIED. ACOSTA MIGHT MOVE IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN THAT PLAN
WE IDENTIFIED ABOUT ONE POINT
THREE BILLION IN COSTS THAT
WOULD GO UP WITH THE CENTRAL
VALLEY BASED ON- COMMERCIAL
DISPUTES AND CHANGE ORDERS THAT
WE- WERE NOT. INCLUDED IN THE
PRIOR A PROGRAM THAT WE DON'T
NEED TO BE INCLUDED AND SO WE
ADJUSTED THE BUDGET AT THAT TIME
WE HAVE NOT IDENTIFIED NEW OR
ADDITIONAL ONES AT THIS POIT-
TO ADD TO THAT BUDGET. AND SO
ARE TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS PLAN
BUDGET WHICH REALLY ARE BOARD
DID NOT INCORPORATE UNTIL
DECEMBER OF TWENTY ONE JUST TWO
MONTHS AGO INCORPORATES OUR
ESTIMATE OF COSTS FOR THAT
SECTOR AND THE WOULD THAT
INCLUDE THE COST FOR CHANGE.
ORDERS- THAT WERE. YEAH YOU WITH
WE WILL AWARE OF WE ESTIMATED IN
THAT PROGRAM WHAT WE CALLED ARE
KNOWN AND UNKNOWN COSTS AND WE
DID THAT BY. CUTTING DOWN COSTS
IN THE SPECIFIC BUDGETS OF EACH
OF OUR CONSTRUCTION PACKAGES.
AND THAT WE INCLUDED A
CONTINGENCY INCREASE FOR EACH OF
THOSE PROTOCOLS ARE UNDER
BECAUSE WE ARE IN COMMERCIAL
DISPUTE OR COMMERCIAL SETTLEMENT
ISSUES WHICH YOU CONTRACTORS
NOW. AND AS THOSE RESOLVE IF
THERE'S ANY ADJUSTMENTS WE NEED
TO MAKE WILL INDICATE THAT TO
THE LEGISLATURE. AND WILL
INDICATE THAT TO MY BOARD PUBLIC
WITH. ADS BUT AT THIS POINT BUT
WE HAVE NOT MOVED OFF THE
ESTIMATES THAT WE PUT IN THE
TWENTY TWENTY. THIS IS. THANK
YOU AB. A FOR THE- IS-
CHRISTINE. OF WHAT ARE THE
OPTIONS FOR LEGISLATIVE FOR
OVERSIGHT ON THE PROJECT CAN
YOU- REVIEW THOSE AGAIN FOR US
AND ALSO- INCLUDING REMARKS WHAT
HAPPENS IF THE LEGISLATURE DOES
NOTHING. SURE THANK YOU AND JUST
NINE ON MR KELLY'S POINT I
BELIEVE IT WHAT I BELIEVE THAT
EVEN THE TWENTY TWENTY BUSINESS
PLAN DIDN'T FULLY AT THE ALL THE
COST FOR THE WHOLE OF THESE ONES
THAT SOME OF THAT SO THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF BECAUSE THEY REALLY
HAVEN'T BEEN FULLY UPDATED SINCE
TWENTY NINETEEN SO I THINK THAT-
THAT THAT'S- THAT THAT IS STILL
AT AN IMPORTANT POINT. AND THEY
TRY TO MAKE THAT CLARIFICATION-
BUT YES I AM THANK YOU SO MUCH
ON YOUR ON YOUR POINT ABOUT-
WE'RE SORRY I THINK IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT POINT WE PROVIDE YOU
KNOW AS I MENTIONED IN MY
COMMENTS- I THINK WHAT IS.
REALLY IMPORTANT THINGS TO THINK
ABOUT IS- YOU KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE HAVING A LITTLE BIT
MORE CONTROL AND OVERSIGHT OF
THIS PROJECT AND PART OF THAT IS
THESE NATURAL DECISION POINTS
THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
BECAUSE- I'M PART OF YOU KNOW
THIS THIS PROJECT- AGAIN BECAUSE
THEY CONTINUE TO CORPORATION
BECAUSE THEY GET THESE BIG. YOU
KNOW BUCKET THE PROP ONE A. AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA BASICALLY BE
DEMOCRATS TWENTY NOW- AND THAT
BECAUSE HE WAS A PREPARATION
JUST KIND OF COMES IN ON THE
NATURAL THE LEGISLATURE ISN'T-
IT REQUIRED- YOUR DOES IT
DOESN'T HAVE YOU KNOW THAT HAVE
TO MAKE IT APPROPRIATIONS AND
ANNUAL BASIS- AND ALSO BECAUSE
THE AUTHORITY. IS REALLY
GOVERNED BY A BOARD AND THE
BOARD CAN MAKE A LOT OF CHOICES
THAT ARE AND IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
GO TO THE LEGISLATIVE IT IF WE
DON'T HAVE TO GO TO LEGISLATURE
FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU WANT YOU KNOW
WHAT DINNER TO GRANT AGREEMENT
WANTS TO INTERFERE WANTS TO MAKE
OTHER CHOICES TO BEFORE THE
PROJECT- SO THIS PROJECT THIS
PROJECT CAN REALLY KIND OF- GO
ALONG ON ITS OWN WITHOUT. A LOT
OF LEGISLATIVE CONTROL AND LET
THE LEGISLATIVE LATE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD EXERT ITSELF I'M THIRTY
THINK ONE WAY TO DO THAT IS TO
BE NATIONAL DECISION POINT THE
BUDGET PROCESS AGAIN I'M MAKING
YOU KNOW MAKING SOME
OPPORTUNITIES WITH ALLEGED WHERE
THAT ALREADY HAS TO COME BACK TO
THE LEGISLATURE TO ASK FOR
FUNDING. AND GET THE LEGISLATURE
OPPORTUNITY THAT YOU HAVE THE
AUTHORITY COME MAKE THANK YOU
KNOW COSTS GO UP NEXT YEAR WE
SEE THAT YOU HAVE BEEN IN THE
PROJECT UPDATE REPORT
LEGISLATURE CAN REVIEW THOSE
COSTS CAN. ASK THOSE QUESTIONS
AND MAKE THOSE DECISIONS SO WE
THINK THAT- ONE OPTION.
CERTAINLY ALSO PROVIDING MORE
STATUTORY DIRECTION RIGHT NOW
THE CABIN. FUNDS THEY MENTION
ARE RE. FIVE YOU KNOW THEY'RE
THEY'RE REALLY JUST KIND GIVE
INTO THE AUTHORITY FOR THE PER.
THOSE COULD BE USED YOU KNOW. I
ON THE ALIGNMENT FOR- AND- THAT
COULD BE A- AT THE- CONSISTENT
LEGISLATIVE. BUT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS. MORE DIRECTION ABOUT HOW IT
WANTS THOSE FUNDS TO BE USED OR
THE TYPES OF AGREEMENTS THEY
WANT THE AUTHORITY TO ENTER
INTO- WE THINK IT'S PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATE FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO- YOU KNOW TO. PROVIDE THAT
STATUTORY DIRECTION THAT WOULD
FURTHER- FOR DIRECTING IT TOWARD
THE END AND REALLY MAKE SURE
IT'S CLEARLY. TO THE AUTHORITY-
MISTER WHAT THE LEGISLATURE'S-
YOU ARE. PREFERRED APPROACH IT
IS- THERE'S SOMETHING THAT WE
HAVEN'T WE HAVEN'T TALKED ABOUT
RECENTLY- AS AN OFFICE BUT- I
KNOW OUR OFFICE BROUGHT UP.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO FOR EXAMPLE
AND BACK WAY BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN IT FEELS LIKE A
ALMOST A DIFFERENT WORLD A LOT
OF THE PRAHLAD OF THE ISSUES
FACING THE PROJECT. ARE STILL
SOME OF THE SAME ISSUES- THAT WE
WERE TACKLING YOUR TEN YEARS AGO
. WORK FOR EXAMPLE WE TALKED
SOME ABOUT THE CHALLENGES WITH
THIS GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE FROM
THE LEGISLATURE. PERSPECTIVE
ABOUT THE BOARD HAVING A LOT OF.
SORT OF ACT. YEAH A LOT OF
MATURITY AND- AND SOMETIMES IT
BEING HARD FOR THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE OVERSIGHT TO THAT PROCESS.
TO TALK ABOUT SOMETHING THAT
REPORT ABOUT SOME DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW
YOU'RE MODIFYING THE BOARD- SO
THERE ARE A LOT OF CHOICES YOU%
COULD ALSO HAVE SOME SORT OF
SEPARATE COMMITTEE FOR EXAMPLE I
KNOW IT'S BEEN TALKED ABOUT- BY
FOLKS YOU KNOW THAT BUT LOOK AT
CHANGE ORDERS OR SOME KIND OF
OUTSIDE GROUP THAT LOOKS. THAT
LOOKS AT THE AUTHORITY- OR THAT
COULD DO YOU I'VE EVER VICE COST
ESTIMATE FOR EXAMPLE THAT'S AND
THAT'S ONE THING THAT- YOU RIGHT
NOW THAT THE AUTHORITY IS. IT
DOES IT DOES YOU KNOW. CONTACT
WITH ITS OWN CONTRACTORS TO DO-
RIDERSHIP AND COST ESTIMATES
BUT- YOU KNOW ANOTHER OPTION AS
WELL. YOU KNOW. SHOULD THIRD
PARTY B. B- HE INVOLVED IN SOME
OF THOSE. THAT THEY'RE A WHOLE.
OF OCT. THAT I KNOW- HAVE BEEN
THE- OVER OVER THE YEARS- WITH
THIS PROJECT- THEY'RE PROBABLY.
YOU KNOW A NUMBER IN THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER.
AGAIN YOU KNOW IT'S PART OF OUR
REMARKS TODAY WE REALLY FOCUSED
ON A FEW- A FEW RELATED TO THIS
DECISION POINTS AND PROVIDING
THAT STATUTORY DIRECTION BUT-
BUT THERE ARE OTHERS AS WELL
THAT COULD BE CONSIDERED IF THE
LEGISLATURE- IS INTERESTED IN.
AND FURTHER PURSUING ANY OF
THOSE- THOSE POSSIBILITIES.
THANKS VERY MUCH MS FRIEDMAN.
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO THANK
ALL THREE OF YOU FOR BEING HERE
AND- SPENDING TIME WITH US THIS
MORNING- YOU KNOW I. STILL BUY
INTO THE DREAM OF HIGH SPEED
RAIL IN CALIFORNIA. I STILL
THINK THAT THIS IS A GREAT
VISION FOR- FOR TRANSPORTATION
IN THE FUTURE AND SOMETHING THAT
COULD BE HUGELY BENEFICIAL TO
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IS A GROSS.
AS WELL. BUT I ALSO REMAIN
CONCERNED- ABOUT THE PROJECT-
GIVEN. ALL OF THE- ISSUES THAT
IT HAS WITH FUNDING AND IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S FAULT- BUT THE
PROJECT IS UNDERFUNDED FOR WHAT
IT NEEDS TO BE COMPLETED. HOW
MUCH IS UNCLEAR YOU KNOW WE HEAR
DIFFERENT NUMBERS FROM DIFFERENT
GROUPS- WE HEARD TODAY FROM
MISTER THOMPSON CONCERNED ABOUT.
THE COST CONTINUING TO ESCALATE
BEYOND WHAT WE SEE IN THIS-
DRAFT A BUSINESS PLAN. AND WE
ARE IN AN UNKNOWN OF A POSITION
IN TERMS OF FEDERAL FUNDING AND
WHAT'S REALLY GOING TO BE ABLE
TO BE ATTAINABLE. AND AT SOME
POINT. IN THE EGISLATURE OR THE
VOTERS ARE BOTH ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO ALLOCATE QUITE A BIT OF
MONEY TO FINISH THIS PROJECT.
AND MY- REASON FOR QUESTIONING
THE BUSINESS PLANET EVERY POINT
THAT WE CAN IS BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE RESPONSIBILITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE POINT WHICH IS OF THE
LEGISLATURE THE VOTERS ARE BOTH.
ARE ASKED TO GIVE ALLOCATE A LOT
OF TAXPAYER MONEY TO THIS
PROJECT. IT NEEDS TO BE IN THE
BEST SHAPE IT CAN BE IT NEEDS TO
BE SOMETHING THAT IS SHOWING THE
PROMISE OF WHAT HIGH SPEED RAIL
COULD MEAN FOR THESE REGIONS. I
REMAIN CONCERNED ABOUT. FOCUSING
ON BUYING TRAINS AND RUNNING
TRACK FOR A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MILES RUNNING THROUGH HIGH SPEED
ELECTRIFIED TRAIN FOR A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES WHICH IS NOT AN
ADEQUATE AMOUNT OF DISTANCE TO
SHOW THE PROMISE OF THE
TECHNOLOGY AND IN THIS CURRENT
BUSINESS PLAN AS FAR AS I CAN
SEE WE'RE NOT RUNNING IT INTO
OUR POPULATION CENTERS TO
DEVELOP THE KIND OF RIDERSHIP
THAT A SUCCESSFUL SYSTEM WOULD
DO. SO I. CONTINUE TO THINK THAT
WE SHOULD. LOOK AT ALTERNATIVES
AT LEAST HAVE. AT THE POINT AT
WHICH THE BOND MONEY IS
FINISHED. AND WE'RE GOING TO BE
COMING BACK TO LOOKING FOR
ANOTHER LARGE. POT OF MONEY.
THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING THAT HAS
AS MUCH UTILITY. FOR ACTUAL
WRITERS AS POSSIBLE. IF THERE
ARE PEOPLE RIDING THE SYSTEM
THAT'S WHAT'S GOING TO CONVINCE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA TO
CONTINUE TO INVEST IN IT. IF IT
IS A TRAIN THAT'S FAST RUNNING
BACK AND FORTH. WITHOUT A LOT OF
WRITERS I THINK THAT A LOT OF
THE PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN NAY
SAYERS AND MAYBE EVEN THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN SUPPORT BY HAVE SECOND
THOUGHTS ABOUT THE PROJECT. WE
DON'T HAVE A LOT OF ABILITY IN
THIS LEGISLATURE TO IMPACT THIS
PROJECT EXCEPT WHEN IT COMES TO
US FOR FUNDING THAT'S OUR ONLY
OPPORTUNITY IS THE ALEJO'S JUST
SAID. WE NEED TO USE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE SURE THAT AS
WE MOVE FORWARD WE DO IT. WITH
THE BEST POSSIBLE BUT PLAN THAT
WE CAN. SO WHEN I WHEN I ASK
QUESTIONS IT'S NOT AN ATTACK ON
ANYONE IN PARTICULAR I THINK
THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY. HAS BEEN GIVEN A
DIFFICULT TASK. OF A PROJECT
THAT IN SOME WAYS IS
UNDERFUNDED. AND HAS A LOT OF
EXPECTATIONS. AND OF COURSE
THEY'RE COMMITTED TO TRYING TO
GET AS MUCH BUILT AS THEY CAN
WITHIN THEIR ORIGINAL MANDATE-
BUT IT'S ALSO VERY DIFFICULT FOR
US TO MAKE DECISIONS WHEN WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW HOW MUCH MONEY
WE EVEN HAVE WHEN WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S COMING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THIS PROJECT EVEN TO FINISH
MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD IT'S
ACTUALLY GOING TO COST. THERE
ARE STILL SEGMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PURCHASED WERE HEARING. A
DIFFERENT ANALYSIS FOR MISTER
THOMPSON FROM THE INDEPENDENT
PEER REVIEW GROUP ABOUT COST THE
MORE HEARING THAT WE'RE SEEING
REFLECTED IN THE BUSINESS PLAN-
I WANTED TO ASK. ALL THREE. AND
I'M SORRY BUT AT TEN THIRTY I
ACTUALLY HAVE TO LEAVE FOR A FEW
MINUTES- AMONG THE URBAN
SCHEDULE PREVIOUSLY AND I'LL
COME BACK AND I'VE ASKED MY
STAFF TO BOOK MARKING TAPE
EVERYTHING SO I CAN HEAR ALL THE
ANSWERS. BUT I THINK MAYBE IF I
CAN ASK A FEW QUESTIONS. AND
THAT WAY IF I NEED TO LEAVE
THEIR OF THEIR ASSETS. I WANTED
TO KNOW YOU KNOW WE'VE HEARD
SOME DIFFERENT- SUGGESTIONS
ABOUT SPENDING MONEY. IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE ON CALTRAIN
OR ON- YOU KNOW LACE ISN'T IN
LOS ANGELES. AND YET WE HEAR
THAT WE MAY NOT HAVE THE FUNDING
AVAILABLE WITHIN WHAT WE HAVE.
TO FINISH MERCED TO BAKERSFIELD
SO I WANTED TO ASK ALL THREE.
ABOUT THE OPTION OF NOT SPENDING
ANY MONEY OUTSIDE OF THE MERCED
BAKERSFIELD- PROJECT AREA INTO
AND- UNTIL WE'VE COMPLETED THAT.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE WISDOM
OF ACTUALLY ENTERING INTO
TRACKING SYSTEM CONTRACTS AND
ESSENTIALLY BUYING TRAINS.
BEFORE WE'VE HAD THE MONEY TO
CONNECT OUR SYSTEM TO ANY
POPULATION CENTER. AND WHY THE
RUSH TO DO THAT. INSTEAD OF
PUTTING ALL THE MONEY THAT WE
CAN'T INTO DOING A TWO TRACK
SYSTEM WE STILL HAVE A ONE TRACK
SYSTEM IN THIS BUSINESS PLAN BY
THE WAY. ONE TRACK WITH TRAINS
HAVING TO PULL OVER TO PASS EACH
OTHER. SUBOPTIMAL FOR SURE- AND-
I ALSO WANTED TO ASK MR KELLY
ABOUT THAT CONNECTION. TO A
STRAIN OR TO OTHER ANOTHER TRAIN
SYSTEM. I'M STILL VERY UNCLEAR
ON THIS BUSINESS PLAN ABOUT
WHERE THIS TRAIN WHERE THE
STATION IS GOING TO BE. AND WHO
PAYS FOR CONNECTION. AS FAR AS I
CAN SEE IF THE TRAIN STOPS IN
MERCED AT A STATION THAT'S TO BE
BUILT BUT THERE'S NO CONNECTION
TO ANY OTHER TRAIN SYSTEM. AND
HOW LONG IT'S SUPPOSED TO
OPERATE. FROM OUTSIDE OF
BAKERSFIELD NOT EVEN INTO
DOWNTOWN BAKERSFIELD BUT OUTSIDE
OF BAKERSFIELD. TO A STATION
NUMBER SAID WITH NO CONNECTION
TO ANYTHING ELSE. AND WHAT ARE
THEIR RIDERSHIP NUMBERS THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO PRESENT AS
REFLECTED THAT REALITY. BECAUSE
THEN WE'RE WAITING TO TRY TO
FIND MORE FUNDING TO CONNECT
THIS TRYING TO SOMETHING. AND I
BELIEVE THAT TO HAS WOULD HAVE
UTILITY THIS TRAIN HAS TO GO.
BEYOND MERCED. THEY WON WHEN IT
OPENS NOT DOWN THE LINE NOT IN
FIVE YEARS NOT IN TEN YEARS. SO
MY CONCERN ABOUT THE PROJECT HAS
BEEN THAT I BELIEVE THAT WE NEED
TO REALLY FOCUS MORE THAN
ANYTHING ON THAT CONNECTION SO
THAT WHATEVER IS RUNNING ON THIS
BEAUTIFUL NEW SECTION O TRACK
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY BRINGS
PEOPLE TO WHERE THEY'RE WORKING.
OVER THEY WANT TO GO. NOT TO GET
ON A BUS AND TRAVEL ANOTHER FEW
MILES TO ANOTHER TRAIN SYSTEM.
THAT MAYBE HAS SERVICE THAT
DOESN'T MATCH UP WITH THIS TRAIN
SERVICE BUT SOMETHING THAT.
REALLY HAS UTILITY. AND THAT ALL
OF OUR FUNDING SHOULD BE FOCUSED
ON COMPLETING THAT SECTION OF
TRACK WITH TWO TWO TRACKS. MY
LAST QUESTION WILL BE ABOUT THE
ELECTRIFICATION IN THE AND
THAT'S NOW SOMEHOW FOUND ITS WAY
INTO THIS FEDERAL APPROPRIATION
. IS AND THIS IS FOR ALEJO. OF
COURSE WE'RE NOT GOING TO RUN
HIGH SPEED RAIL WITHOUT BEING
ELECTRIFIED THAT'S OBVIOUS BUT
BUT MY QUESTION IS IF WE DO THE
PRELIMINARY WORK. TO ELECTRIFY
THE TRACK BUT NOT COMPLETE THAT
UNTIL WE'VE ACTUALLY BOUGHT OUR
TRAINS INCLUDED OUR SYSTEM. DOES
THAT SORT OF COUNT WITHIN THE
FEDERAL FUNDING IN OTHER WORDS.
CAN WE TO START THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT STILL RUN
SOMETHING IN TERM ON THAT TRACK-
INTO WE COMPLETE OUR SYSTEM OR
DOES IT HAVE TO BE FOR THE
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT YOU HAVE TO
DO. EVERYTHING EVEN IF YOU'RE
NOT ACTUALLY GOING TO RUN A
TRAIN OR CONNECT TO ANYTHING SO.
I'LL WAIT IN HERE AND I'M SORRY
IF I HAVE TO GO OUT AND COME
BACK BUT- AGAIN I REALLY
APPRECIATE AND I DEFINITELY WANT
TO HEAR FROM MR THOMPSON WHO IS
OUR INDEPENDENT- A SORT OF
ANALYST IN ALL OF THIS- I'D LIKE
TO HEAR IF HE HAS ANY- ANSWERS
TO ANY OF THESE AS WELL. THANK
YOU. HELLO ASK- THAT- ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS KEEP YOUR ANSWERS AS
CONCISE AS POSSIBLE BECAUSE WE
HAVE LOTS OF QUESTIONS TO US
THIS MORNING. MISTER CHAIRMAN
I'M SORRY WHO DID YOU WANT TO GO
FIRST. IF YOU MISTER TOM. MISTER
THOMPSON. THANK YOU FOR THOSE
QUESTIONS WHICH I WILL HAVE TO
SAY ARE NOT EASY- THEY REQUIRE A
LITTLE BIT OF THOUGHT FIRST I
THINK MY REACTION IS THAT WHAT
YOUR QUESTION DOES IS HIGHLIGHT
THE IMPORTANCE OF DIRECTION FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AS TO WHAT IT
WANTS. ARE YOU DO NOT IN THIS
CASE WANT TO DILUTE THE EFFORT
OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
IF THEY'RE GOING TO DO. A MERCED
THE BAKERSFIELD THERE ISN'T
REALLY ANY MONEY TO TALK ABOUT
SHIFTING OUT OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE
IT SHOULD REMAIN FOCUSED ON THE
OBJECTIVE OF MERCED THE
BAKERSFIELD. ALL WE ALL
CONNECTION AT MERCED THIS WAS AN
ISSUE THAT WAS ISCUSSED IN
DETAIL IN OUR LETTER LAST YEAR
AND IT REMAINS A MATTER OF GREAT
CONCERN. IT INVOLVES STATE
MINING AND STATE COMMITMENT TO
FINISHING YOUR CONNECTION SAID
AND LOCAL COMMITMENT FROM THE US
AND GENERAL KEANE JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY. BOOSTER PLAN OPERATE
THAT STATION OPERATE THE
CONNECTING SERVICES AND UNDER
THE PLANS OF THE AUTHORITY.
ACTUALLY OPERATE UNDER CONTRACT
HI SPEED TRAINS FROM MERCED THAT
BAKERSFIELD. AND THOSE ARE
ISSUES WHICH WE SAID THEN- NEED
DID A LOT FOR THE RETENTION OF
CLARIFICATION THAT HAS NOT YET
BEEN DONE SO IT'S A- DESERVES.
SOME AND ALL THAT ALL RIGHT SOME
ATTENTION ON THAT. I GUESS FINAL
ELECTRIFICATION A ROLE IN THIS
OFF TO A BRAND OR ALONE BUT- I
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE TERMS OF THE
OF THE FEDERAL. REQUIREMENT FOR
ELECTRIFICATION OF MERCED THE
BAKERSFIELD ART. AND I'M NOT
SURE WHAT OBJECTIVES THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WAS TRYING TO SOLICIT
SATISFIED BY REQUIRING
ELECTRIFICATION. AS AS PART OF
AN AGREEMENT- INDEED YOU COULD
OPERATE HI SPEED DIESEL TRAINS.
ON THE SEGMENT FOR SOME INTERIM
PERIOD OF TIME. AND THAT WOULD
HAVE HOW DO BECAUSE THEY TO
CONNECT DIRECTLY TO SACRAMENTO
IF YOU WANTED TO DO SO WITHOUT
REQUIRING ANY CHANGE IN OUR SET.
UP WITH THE SUIT WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
INSIST ON ALECTRA EDUCATION
BEFORE COMPLETION OF EVERYTHING
ELSE I DON'T KNOW. THAT WOULD BE
A MATTER FOR DISCUSSION WITH THE
BIDEN MINISTRATION BUT- MY
EXPERIENCE THUS FAR IS THAT
THEY'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO TRY
TO WORK WITH THE STATE FOR
ANYTHING. THAT THE STATE WANTS
TO DO. WHICH INCLUDES BACK TO
THE QUESTION WHAT THE ALLIANCE.
REALLY WANT THE SPEED RAIL OF
THE- TO DO. I DO WANT TO ADD ONE
OTHER THING- THAT THEY WE CAN
THE SIZE DATA IS THAT. TO PUT
ONE IS. LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
COULD INCLUDE A NUMBER OF THINGS
THAT FELL AND HAS MENTIONED- BUT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE.
BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE AS OF
NOW LOOKS AT THE PROJECT ONCE OR
TWICE A YEAR WITHOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE EXPERIENCED IN THE PROJECT
WITHOUT PEOPLE WHO'VE HAD YEARS
OF. CONTINUITY IN OVERSEEING
ISSUES OF THE PROJECT AND
WITHOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE FOCUSED
ON THE LARGEST PROJECT THE STATE
IS EVER UNDERTAKEN THAT DESERVES
SOME THOUGHT. WELL I GUESS THE
OTHER THOUGHT IS THAT. HELP
STABLE INADEQUATE FUNDING FROM
WHATEVER SOURCES THE LEGISLATURE
DESIGNATES WITHOUT STABLE AND
ADEQUATE FUNDING YOU'RE ASKING
BRIAN KELLY TO DO SOMETHING THAT
HE CAN'T DO. HE'S GOT TO HE HAS
TO JUGGLE TOO MANY THINGS AND HE
HAS TOO MANY THINGS THAT HE
DOESN'T KNOW THAT YOU CAN DEPEND
ON. SO AT SOME POINT PART OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S ACTION ON THIS
PROJECT HAS GOT TO BE TO
ESTABLISH A CLEAR SET OF
OBJECTIVES AND FUNDING THAT IS
ADEQUATE AND STABLE TO ACHIEVE
THOSE OBJECTIVES UNTIL YOU DO
THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE HAVING
THE SAME KIND OF ISSUES EVERY
YEAR. OF THAT AS HELEN SAID THAT
WE'VE OF THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS PROJECT
SINCE TWO THOUSAND NINE AND I
HANG OUT. THESE ISSUES HAVE COME
UP NEARLY EVERY YEAR AND I
REALLY NEED TO BE RESOLVED.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MAY I. OKAY SO
ON THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS- FIRST
WITH RESPECT TO THE SUGGESTION
THAT WE'RE SPENDING MONEY
ELSEWHERE OUTSIDE THE VALLEY OF
LUCK WHEN IT COMES TO THE BUDGET
THAT WE ESTIMATE WE HAVE BETWEEN
BOND DOLLARS. THE AVAILABLE
FEDERAL DOLLARS WE ALREADY HAVE
NOT NEW BUT THE AVAILABLE DATA
DOLLARS WE ALREADY HAVE AND THE
CAP AND TRADE MONEY THAT WE
ESTIMATE WE HAVE BETWEEN NOW AND
TWENTY THIRTY WE ARE NOT
PROPOSING TO SPEND THOSE DOLLARS
OUTSIDE OF THE VALLEY. WHAT WE
ARE OBSERVING IS THAT WE'RE AT A
TIME A MOMENT IN TIME WHERE NEW
FEDERAL DOLLARS HAVE COME IN AT
A LEVEL OF INVESTMENT HIGHER
THAN WE'VE SEEN IN DECADES. THE
GOVERNOR HAS ADDED A FOURTEEN
POINT NINE BILLION DOLLARS
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENT
PROGRAM. INTO THAT FEDERAL POT
RIGHT NOW. AND SO THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY THAT EXISTS HERE FOR
US TO PURSUE FEDERAL MONEY. TO
ELIMINATE THE CONSIDERATION OF
THE SINGLE TRACK BETWEEN MERCED
AND BAKERSFIELD AND DO A DOUBLE
TRACK. AND TO USE OTHER STATE OR
FEDERAL FUNDS TO ADVANCE WORK
AROUND THE STATE THAT SOME HAVE
ADVOCATED WE DO. I'M THROUGH
WITH THOSE DOLLARS TO ADVANCED
DESIGN WORK WHERE WE FINISH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL DOCUMENTS. WE ARE
WORKING ON THE ENVIRONMENTAL
DOCUMENTS STATEWIDE- FIVE
HUNDRED MILE SEGMENT. AT FOR
FIVE YEARS BEFORE I GOT HERE
THORNY HAD NOT CLEARED THE
RECORD OF DECISION. WE'VE NOW
DONE FOR IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
AND WILL DO TO MORE IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THAT'S SIX SEGMENTS
CLEAR ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY
MILES OF THE FIVE MILE SYSTEM WE
ARE. WE THINK IT IS WISE TO
ADVANCE THE COULD THE DESIGN
WORK IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT AND
WE WOULD HOPE THAT IN THE BUDGET
DISCUSSIONS THIS YEAR. THEY'LL
BE SOME MONEY IDENTIFIED FOR
THAT PURPOSE BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
ADVOCATED FOR BY SOME OF THE
LEGISLATURE AND WE SUPPORT THAT.
I DON'T HAVE IT WITHIN MY
CURRENT BUDGET TO DO IT BUT I DO
SUPPORT USING ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO ADVANCED DESIGN WORK
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. NO
QUESTION ABOUT. SECONDLY ON THE
WISDOM OF RUSHING FOR TRACKING
SYSTEMS CONTRACT. OR BUYING
TRAINS. FAR FROM RUSHING WE ARE
DELAY. WE ARE DELAYING THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS CONTRACT WE
HAVE DONE IT SEVERAL TIMES. AND
WE ARE NOT EVEN CONSIDERING
BUYING TRAINS IN THIS FISCAL
YEAR UNTIL. THIS CONVERSATION
WITH THE LEGISLATURE IS SUBTLE.
OUR HOPE IS THAT THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS THIS YEAR. WE
WILL COME OUT OF THIS WITH THE
CLARITY. ON HOW POLICY MAKERS
WANT TO MOVE FORWARD ON THIS
PROJECT. AND THEN WE WILL REACT
TO THAT. AND WE WILL DETERMINE
TOGETHER HOW WE MOVE FORWARD.
ARE WE WHAT WE ARE REQUIRED TO
DO UNDER THE LAW THIS BUSINESS
PLAN. IS TELL YOU HOW WE WOULD
MOVE FORWARD UNDER A CONSTRAINT
BUDGETS. AND ARE CONSTRAINED
BUDGET IS ABOUT TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE BILLION.
BETWEEN NOW AND TWENTY THIRD.
THAT'S CAP AND TRADE DOLLARS THE
REMAINING BOND FUNDS. AT THE
FEDERAL FUNDING WE ALREADY HAVE.
NOT NEW FEDERAL FOR. NEW FEDERAL
FUNDING WOULD BE IN ADDITION TO
THAT. SO WE ARE YOU INTEND TO
PURSUE NEW FEDERAL DOLLARS
BECAUSE THEY'RE THERE. BECAUSE
WE HAVE THE BEST WORKING
RELATIONSHIP WE'VE HAD WITH THE
US DEPARTMENT TRANSPORTATION AND
THE UP ALREADY IN THE HISTORY OF
THIS PROJECT. WE THINK NOW IS
THE TIME TO GO SETTLE ISSUES
LIKE ONE TRACK VERSUS TO TRACK.
THE OTHER THING I JUST MENTION
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO GET THE
TRACKING SYSTEMS CONTRACT BILL.
BECAUSE IT NEEDS TO BE DESIGNED
AND YOU NEED TO MOVE. TO
AUTOMATE CONSTRUCTION AS WE
COMPLETE THE CIVIL WORKS. THE C.
P. FOR CONTRACT WILL BE DONE. AT
THE VERY BEGINNING OF TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. AND SO. THE DESIGN
AND THE EARLY PROCUREMENT OF
MATERIALS WILL BE NECESSARY TO
AUTOMATICALLY EXECUTE TRACKING
SYSTEMS HOWEVER. IF WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT WE'RE BUILDING
ELECTRIFIED SYSTEM OR NOT. THEN
WE SHOULD WAIT. WE SHOULD WAIT
OUR VIEW IS FOR THE AMOUNT OF
MONEY WE'RE SPENDING IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. WE SHOULD HAVE
AN ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM. WE DID A ALL SIDE BY
SIDE ANALYSIS OF THIS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN WE REPEATED IT IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE SHARED IT WITH
THE LEGISLATURE WE CHATTED WITH
PEER REVIEW GROUPS. THE PEER
EVIEW GROUP THAT WE SHARED IT
WITH SAID IT WAS REASONABLE THAT
WE THINK THAT'S THE BEST
APPROACH FOR CONSTRAINED BUDGET.
THAT ALSO IS IN LINE WITH WHAT
PROP ONE A. **** TO DO. SO WE
WANT TO GET AN OPERATING SEGMENT
GOING ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED
TRAINS BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
BENEFIT FROM DOING THAT FROM
RIDERSHIP PERSPECTIVE IN THE
BALLOT. AT THE SAME TIME WE WANT
TO ADVANCE ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
EVERYWHERE ELSE SO WE CAN
PREPARE THE NEW SEGMENTS FOR
CONSTRUCTION. AND MAKE SURE WE
DO IT RIGHT UNLIKE THE BEGINNING
OF THIS PROJECT ON THE BALLOT.
WE WANT TO GET MORE RISK THE NO
EARLIER WE WANT TO IDENTIFY THE
DID THE WHAT EXPAND DESIGN
IDENTIFY THE RIGHT AWAY THAT'S
NEEDED. WE'RE NOT GOING TO
UNDERTAKE THAT WORK UNTIL WE'VE
MOVED THE WORK IN THE VALLEY
WE'VE GOT A PERCENT BAKERSFIELD
STRETCH OPERATIONAL OR GOING
WE'RE COMMITTED TO THAT AS A
STATE. AND THEN WE'LL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET HOW TO ADVANCE THE
WORK BE ON THE BALLOT AND YES IT
WILL TAKE ORE MONEY AND IT WILL
TAKE MORE TIME. BUT YOU KNOW I.
COME UP WITH A BUSINESS PLAN
EVERY YEAR. AND I CAN. THE I DO
HAVE FUND. FOR ANYTHING OUTSIDE
OF THE VALLEY RIGHT NOW. I DO
NOT HAVE DENTIFIED FUNDING AND
THAT'S WHAT LIEU THOMPSON IS
THAT SAYING FOR FIVE YEARS MAYBE
LONGER AND SO I'M GIVING YOU A
PLAN OF HOW WE CAN DO THIS
WITHIN OUR TRAIN BUDGET SEGMENT
BY SEGMENT ARAFAT IS USE THE
ASSETS WERE BUILDING NOW GET THE
ELECTRIFIED SYSTEM GOING THERE
THERE ARE RIDERSHIP BENEFITS
TRAVEL BENEFITS CONNECTIVITY
BENEFITS GREENHOUSE GAS
BENEFITS. WE LAID ALL THOSE OUT
IN TWENTY NINETEEN AGAIN IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE SUBJECTED TO
PEER REVIEW AND IT WAS A FIRM.
AND SO THAT IS OUR PROPOSAL
GOING FORWARD IF THE LEGISLATURE
POLICY MAKERS WANT TO DO
SOMETHING ELSE WE'LL DO
SOMETHING ELSE. BUT THAT THAT IS
WHAT WE ARE REQUIRED TO PUT IN A
PLAN HERE IS HOW WE WOULD
PROCEED I DO NOT HAVE MONEY YOU
HAVE TO GET TO THE BAY AREA OR
INTO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BUT BUT
WE CAN ADVANCE THOSE SECTIONS BY
GETTING ENVIRONMENTAL WORK DONE.
AND DOING ALL OF THE ADVANCED
DESIGN WORK SO WE KNOW MUCH MORE
BEFORE WE GET THERE AND THAT'S
WHAT OUR THAT'S OUR APPROACH
ENTAILS TWO OTHER POINTS JUST
AFTER MISTREATMENT. QUESTIONS I
MAKE A BRIEF PLACE. WHY ON THE
CONNECTION MERCED. LOOK TODAY
WHETHER OR NOT HIGH SPEED RAIL
IS OPERATING BETWEEN PERCENT OR
BAKERSFIELD. TODAY WITH THE
EXTENSION OF AS IN THE DOWNTOWN
PERCENT WHICH IS ALREADY FUNDED
BY THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT IS
HAPPENING. AND SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO MERCED AT THE END
OF THE DECADE. BOB THEY'RE GOING
TO A DIFFERENT STATION IN MERCED
SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM WOULD GO TO.
AND THE CITY OF MERCED AND MOST
TRANSIT ADVOCATES WOULD SAY WE
ARE TO BUILD A SINGLE STATION IN
MERCED. FOR ALL OPERATORS TO GO
TO SO WE HAVE BETTER TRANSIT
CONNECTIVITY. AS GOES TO THE BAY
AREA THE SAN JOAQUIN'S GO TO
SACRAMENTO AND OAKLAND. AND YET
THE IDEA IS FOR A SINGLE STATION
AND WERE SET. AS WE INDICATED
LAST YEAR AND THE YEAR BEFORE.
THAT STATION STILL HAS TO BE.
DESIGNED IT CLEARED AND FUNDED.
AND WE DON'T THINK THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL FORTY SHOULD FUND
THAT STATION BY ITSELF BECAUSE
THE BENEFITS INVOLVED. AS IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN SYSTEM WHICH NOW
GETS FUNDING FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO OPERATE. SO
ALTERNATELY A SINGLE STATION IN
MERCED IS THE RIGHT DECISIONWE
AGREE WITH THAT. AND WE THINK
THAT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
INCLUDING THE AUTHORITY TO DO
ALL THE WORK TO GET THAT SINGLE
STATION LOCATED FUNDED AND BELT.
AND IT'LL BENEFIT RIDERS GOING
TO OAKLAND. SACRAMENTO AND OTHER
POINTS IN THE BAY AREA. IT WILL
ALSO. IMPROVE CONNECTED IN THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL. AND LASTLY ON
THE ONLY. QUESTION IN THE
AGREEMENT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. UP EVEN THE ORIGINAL
OUR AGREEMENT AS A PRINCIPLE
MATTER SAID THE RESULT OF THESE
FUNDS LIKE TO FIGHT HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM ABOUT. AND SO WHAT
WE GET BACK WITH THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION. BUT PROPOSED TO
RESCIND FEDERAL DOLLARS THIS
PROJECT AT AND WE NEGOTIATED
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- HOW
TO GET THOSE DOLLARS BACK. THE
OBJECTIVE OF THE INVESTMENT WAS
STILL THE SAME THE LECTURE BY
HIGH SPEED RAIL SYSTEM IS
OPERATING ABOUT SO THE AGREEMENT
SAYS THAT. NOW IF CALIFORNIA AS
A STATE THE SIZE. WE'RE NOT
GONNA DO ELECTRIFIED IN THE
VALLEY THE START IT'S JUST A
MATTER OF LIKE TO DO ELECTRIFIED
EVERYWHERE ELSE BUT I DON'T HAVE
MONEY. FOR IT SO IF WE DON'T DO
ELECTRIFIED SYSTEM OPERATING IN
THE VALLEY NOW YOU HAVE TO GO
BACK TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AS A STATE AND FIGURE OUT IF
THAT'S OKAY. AND THEY'LL HAVE TO
THEY'LL HAVE TO MAKE A JUDGMENT
ABOUT THE- BUT- CAN. SINCE THE
BEGINNING OF THE ARE FUNDS.
THROUGH THE RECENT DOCUMENT IS
FOR LIKE TO FIVE HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYSTEM OPERATING CALIFORNIA WITH
THE FEDERAL MONEY THEY KEPT. WE
SEE GREAT BENEFITS TO THAT IN
THE VALLEY AS THE ORIGINAL AND
FIRST BUILDING BLOCK. WHICH WILL
EXTEND. FROM THERE BUT THAT'S
THAT'S WHY IT'S IN THE
AGREEMENT. THAT WE THINK IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS ALWAYS
BETTER. RIGHT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
RESPONSE. YOUR TURN WE- WOULD
YOU LIKE ME TO ADD ON AS WELL
AND MISTER CHAIR. IF YOU CAN DO
SO VERY BRIEFLY WERE RAPIDLY
RUNNING OUT THE CLOCK CARE. I
APOLOGIZE AND JUST A FEW CLICKS
. I'M WITH REGARD TO THE
SPENDING OUT ON OTHER PARTS
OUTSIDE OF MERCED TO
BAKERSFIELD- AS WAS MENTIONED BY
AND BY MISTER KELLY- THE
AUTHORITY WANTS TO DANCE DESIGN
OUTSIDE OF THAT OF THAT MERCED
TO BAKERSFIELD AND YOU KNOW
THAT'S A PROBABLY IMPORTANT
THING IF YOU'RE REALLY COMMITTED
TO DOING WORK OUTSIDE OF
REJECTED A CONCEALED THAT'S
CURRENTLY NOT BUDGETED AS WAS
MENTIONED IT'S ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THAT THEY
EXPECTED TO COST TO DO THAT
ADVANCED DESIGN. THAT'S NOT IN
THE BUDGET SO EITHER WE HAVE YET
FEDERAL FUNDS TO DO THAT AND
MAYBE THEY MATCH THIS THAT WITH
THEM STATE BENEFITS AND CLEAR
WHAT AND THIS WOULD BE SO- I
THINK IT IS IT IS A QUESTION I
MEAN IT'S THEORETICALLY EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT IN THE BUDGET
PLAN HE'S ALREADY COULD USE SOME
OF THE CAP AND TRADE FUNDS TO
MATCH FEDERAL FUNDS. ARE
POTENTIALLY YOU KNOW PERHAPS
OTHER STATES WHICH IS TO BE USED
FOR THAT BUT THAT'S NOT
CURRENTLY BUDGETED- AND SO TO
THE EXTENT FUNDS WERE USED FOR
THOSE ACTIVITIES THAT WOULD THAT
WORK YOU ARE CURRENTLY THIRD
DESIGNATED FOR MERCED
BAKERSFIELD THAT COULD INCREASE
THAT FUNDING GAP SO THAT WAS OUR
POINT THERE ON THE TRACKING
SYSTEMS WHAT HE'D WANT TO COMMIT
TO THAT BEFORE AND THE LINE
CONNECTED TO POPULATION CENTERS.
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT ONE I
THINK ONE IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION OUT WHEN YOU WANT
TO DO TRACKING SYSTEMS IF YOU
WANNA MAKE SURE YOU GOT ENOUGH
OF THE RIGHT AWAY AND THE CIVIL
WORKS IS REALLY FAR ENOUGH ALONG
THAT YOU DON'T START LOOKING
TRACK I MEAN I KNOW THE
ORIGINAL. RP THERE HAD LAYING
TRACK IN IN VERY SMALL SEGMENTS
LIKE LESS THAN TEN MILES-
BECAUSE WE DIDN'T THINK WE WERE
GONNA GET ALL OF THE WORK THAT
ENHANCE FACT THAT TO CHALLENGE
LIKE BACK BACK WE REALLY
PROBABLY DON'T WANT TO BE DOING
WE WANT TO WAIT MAKE SURE WE AT
LEAST HAVE THE CIVIL WORKS IN
GOOD SHAPE BEFORE STARTLING
TRACK THAT WE DON'T END UP IN A
SITUATION WHERE- YOU KNOW WHERE
WE HAVE TO LAY CLAIMS- AND
THAT'S BEEN PROBLEMATIC FOR THE
STATE IN THE PAST- SO I THINK
THAT'S AN IMPORTANT THING TO DO
YOU. TO THINK ABOUT ALSO TWO
TRACKS- ARE A VERY VALUABLE
AGAIN AS MR KELLY MENTIONED SO
I'M GETTING RESPECT TO PROBABLY
NEED FEDERAL FUNDING TO DO THAT
SO DO WE WANT TO RELEASE THE
CONTRACT AWARDED TRACKING.
SYSTEMS CONTRACT BEFORE WE NO IF
THAT FEDERAL. IS AND THERE INTO
THE- WHERE THE- WORDING THAT
COULD. LATER THIS YEAR TO CLEAR
THAT KNOW ABOUT. FUNDING THAT.
SO THAT I THINK I KNOW KEY FOR.
TO THINK. THEIR CERTAINLY- OF.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE NONE. OF KEY
THING ALSO I DO A PRE. CERTAINLY
THE AT THE WORD TO LAY THE TRACK
INSIST CONTRACT SOMEWHERE
ALREADY. BUT WOULD NOW- KNOW.
AGAIN THAT THAT. THAT THAT WE
TALK ABOUT THAT GRANT AGREEMENT.
EFFECTIVELY CONNECT THE STATE'S
ELECTRIFICATION SO ON ONE HAND
THROUGH DIFFERING THAT ACTION
BUT THEN. I'M YOU REALLY.
PREVIOUS GRANT AGREEMENTS REALLY
HADN'T THOUGHT ABOUT THE
ELECTRIFICATION. AND THIS GRANT
AGREEMENT HOW THAT WITH THE
TROOPS. IN MANY PLACES
THROUGHOUT THE AGREEMENT SO-
AGAIN IT'S UNCLEAR WHETHER WE
COULD KIND OF- YOU RENEGOTIATE
WITH THAT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. OR WHETHER WE DO YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT IT WOULD ACTUALLY
HAVE TO REDDING ELECTRIFIED
TRAINS. I HAVE TO LOOK AT IT THE
DETAILS AGAIN BUT- BUT IT REALLY
IS A CHANGE IT WAS VERY NOTABLE
BETWEEN THE PREVIOUS GRANT
AGREEMENT IN THIS ONE.
ELECTRIFICATION WITH ADAM YOU
KNOW NUMEROUS TIMES THROUGHOUT
THE DOCUMENT. AND THEN JUST
FINALLY- ON THE CONNECTION TO
MERCED I THINK IT'S CRITICAL.
THAT WE HAVE A GOOD CONNECTION
RESET AS WAS MENTIONED BEFORE
RIGHT NOW. THE PLAN IS. THAT THE
CURRENT STATIONS WOULD BE THIRTY
THREE OF THEM RIGHT ONE
CONSERVING THE SAN JOAQUIN. ONE
EIGHT TO COME INTO AND IT OR
HE'S TRYING TO COME INTO YET A
THIRD ONE. I'M SO I THINK
EVERYONE AGREED THAT THAT
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE WE NEED IT TO
BE ONE STATION. RIGHT NOW.
EXTENDING. OUR HIGH SPEED RAIL.
WE WILL HAVE TO EXTEND. TO GET
TO THAT PROPOSED A STATION AND
THEN THE SAME WORKING WITH TO
COME AND- THAT EXTENSION. I NOW
INCLUDED IN THE- SO ANOTHER THAT
WOULD PROBABLY ADD SOME THAT
CAUGHT. SO AGAIN THEY WANT YOU.
TO WORK THAT'S NOT MY CALL YEAH
THEY WANT TO DO YOU THEY WANT TO
EXTEND NORTH TO GET TO THE
STATION ASU'S PLANNING THAT'S
NOT IN THE BUDGET YET. THEY'RE
ALL THESE PIECES THEY WANTED YOU
DOUBLE TRACKS IT'S NOT REALLY
THAT THE- BUDGET BUT- AGAIN IT'S
NOT CLEAR BACK BEFORE. YOU HAVE
AN OPENING FOR THEIR A LOT OF
PIECES OUT THERE. IMPORTANT
PIECES OF THE PROJECT TO MAKE
THE PROJECT WORK REALLY WELL BUT
AGAIN AS MR KELLY MENTIONED. THE
AUTHORITY REALLY HAS VERY
CONSTRAINED FUNDING RIGHT AND
IT'S QUITE POSSIBLE THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WILL BE
NEEDED. TO REALLY MAKE THAT
STATION. B. AS GOOD A CONNECTION
AS POSSIBLE TO REALLY MAKE THAT.
DON'T YOU KNOW DOUBLE TRACKING
HAPPENED. TO DO THAT AGAINST THE
FINE WORK AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
TO DO OTHER WORK OUT TO PAY FOR
SUCH A BAKERSFIELD- SO I KNOW
THAT WAS VERY QUICK BUT
HOPEFULLY THAT WAS. THE
PREFERRED IT- BUT- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK. THANK YOU.
MISTER TECH. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF. IS THE- THANK YOU I
MEAN YOU'VE BEEN. THESE SPEED
RAIL HEARINGS. OUR ENTIRE TENURE
. YES HISTORY. THIS IS DOTTING I
BELIEVE THE LIKE YOUR TEN. HIGH
SPEED RAIL HEARING REALLY PER.
YOU IN YOUR LEAD- IN ON THIS
ISSUE. TRYING TO KEEP KEEP THE
OVERSIGHT ON TOP THE AGENCY-
JUST WANT TO START WITH MISTER
THOMPSON I REALLYAPPRECIATED
YOUR PEER REVIEW REPORT- IF I
CONTRAST. YOUR REPORT WITH MR
KELLY SUPPORT I WOULD THINK THAT
I'M TALKING. ABOUT TWO
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT PROJECTS.
SO- SOMEONE FROM. USER FRANCISCO
HIGH SPEED RAIL VERY IMPORTANT
TO US WHEN WE HAVE A STATION
THAT WE'VE ALREADY BUILT OUT
THAT'S WAITING FOR A TRAIN. I
FEEL VERY FORTUNATE THAT DURING
MY TENURE LEGISLATURE I'VE SEEN
THE- THE REBUILDING OF THE BAY
BRIDGE AS WELL AS OUR NEW
TRANSBAY TERMINAL SERVING THE
EAST BAY. OF WHICH THERE IS AN
EMPTY SHELL OF A TRAIN STATION
WAITING TO BE BUILT OUT FOR. A
HIGH SPEED RAIL AT SOME POINT.
SO GORGEOUS GOING TO- MR ARE.
MISTER THOMPSON FOR A SECOND
JUST. COULD COULD YOU- IF YOU DO
WOULD YOU HAD ADVISED US TO HAVE
SOME SORT OF ONGOING OVERSIGHT
WITH MORE EXPERTS TO MORE
EXPERTISE IT SEEMS LIKE. WE NEED
TO HAVE A PROBLEM MUCH DEEPER
DISCUSSION WITH MR KELLY THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND REALLY
FLESHING OUT WHAT THIS WHAT
REALISTICALLY. IT CAN BE DONE
WITH THE SORT OF FORTY AND I
THINK IT SEEMS TO HAPPEN
DISCUSSION SEEM TO HAPPEN
SPORADICALLY BUT NOT WITH THE
CONSISTENCY THAT'S NEEDED TO
REALLY FLESH OUT OF PLANS I WAS
HOPING TO GET YOUR ADVICE
BECAUSE HE SEEMED. YOUR REPORT
WAS EXTREMELY THOUGHTFUL BUT
ALSO- JUST READING BETWEEN THE
LINES SEEMED RATHER PESSIMISTIC
TO AT THAT THAT THAT THE SAME
POINT. ALL WE HAVE SAID SINCE HE
I SAW HER FIRST REPORTS ON THE
PROJECT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO DEVOTE MORE ATTENTION
AND MORE RESOURCES TO CONTINUING
OVERSIGHT OF THE PROJECT. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THERE IS NO
DEDICATED STAFF OF PEOPLE I
DON'T KNOW THAT IT REQUIRES A
LARGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE BUT A-
DEDICATED NUMBER OF PEOPLE. WITH
ACCESS TO ALL OF THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED WHO CAN ADVISE THE
LEGISLATURE YEAR AFTER YEAR ON
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE PROJECT
INSTEAD WHAT WE'VE HAD IS
HEARINGS ONCE A YEAR OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE MANY TIMES ON
THE DIFFERENT HEARINGS. AND NO
SENSE OF CONTINUITY OR HER DEATH
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO REVIEW OF
THIS IS A PROBLEM BECAUSE- BY
ANY MEASURE THIS IS THE LARGEST
PROJECT THE STATE HAS EVER
UNDERTAKEN AND THAT'S LIKELY TO
BE THE LARGEST PROJECT THE STATE
EVER UNDERTAKES. SO IT DESERVES
THE MORE REVIEW MORE ATTENTION
AND MORE UNDERSTANDING. ON THE
PART OF THE LEGISLATURE OF WHAT
THE PROPOSAL'S MEANING OF WHAT
THE SCOPE OF THE PROJECT IS AND
WHAT THE RISKS ARE IN A
REALISTIC WAY- THIS COULD BE
DONE EITHER AS WE DIDN'T WE
SUGGESTED POSSIBLY A SPECIALIZED
STAFF WITHIN THE L. A. O. BUT
THERE MAY BE MANY OTHER WITH.
COMP WHICH THIS ON AMTRAK FOR
EXAMPLE HAS AN INTERNAL
INSPECTOR GENERAL THAT REPORT TO
THE CONGRESS ON ON THE ISSUES
AND AMTRAK THAT THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL CONSIDERS TO BE
IMPORTANT FOR ON ISSUES THAT THE
CONGRESS HAS ASKED THE INSPECTOR
GENERAL TO ANALYZE FOR THEM.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
WAYS TO DO THIS THE MAIN
EMPHASIS IS ON IMPROVED AND
CONTINUING LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
OF THE PROJECT I BELIEVE IN THE
INTEREST OF CALIFORNIA IT'S
SOMETHING. YOU WOULD ONLY NEED
TO DEVELOP. NO NO THANK YOU MISS
THOMPSON I THINK THE IDEA OF THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL SO I THINK A
REALLY GOOD IDEA. WE HAVE ONE
FOR OUR CORRECTIONS SYSTEM AND I
WOULD SAY THAT ONE OFFICES WORK
IN THAT ONE AREA HAS REALLY-
BEEN ONE OF THE ONLY BRIGHT
SPOTS IN THAT SYSTEM I WOULD SAY
AND REALLY. HIGHLIGHTING AND
REALLY HELPING US PROVIDE THE
OVERSIGHT I MEAN AS AS YOU
ARTICULATED- I THINK YOU
ARTICULATED OUR ENTIRE CHALLENGE
AROUND OVERSIGHT NOT JUST IN
HIGH SPEED RAIL BUT OVER. EVERY
SINGLE- DIVISION AND DEPARTMENT
WITHIN STATE GOVERNMENT WHICH IS
QUITE LARGE QUITE COMPLEX IN
DOING- YOU KNOW VERY
SOPHISTICATED THINGS I THINK- I
THINK YOUR IDEAS ARE GREAT- WILL
BE TAKEN TO HEART WILL BE
TALKING- WITH OUR CHAIR HERE AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN-
FEEL. FRANKLY TO DO OUR PART I
JUST GO AND GO TO MISTER KELLY
ON. WITH TAX BEFORE THE VIEW
MISTER THOMPSON SO ON. BASED ON
WHAT YOU KNOW TODAY I MEAN HOW
CONFIDENT. ARE YOU ABOUT THE
COMPLETION EVEN OF THE SEGMENT
THAT IS FUNDED WHICH IS THE
MERCED TO. BAKERSFIELD SEGMENT-
BECAUSE- YOU'RE WITH YOUR
CLOSING STATEMENT IT DIDN'T IT
DIDN'T SOUND LIKE YOU HAD AS
MUCH CONFERENCES. I WOULD HOPE.
USE THAT QUESTION FOR PRIME CAL
IN CALIFORNIA I'M SORRY I WANTED
TO FINISH AT THE THEY'RE GONNA
MISTER KELLER FOR SECOND. ALL WE
SAID LAST YEAR IN OUR LETTER
THAT WE- THINK THAT COMPLETION
OF COMMERCE SAID THE BAKERSFIELD
PROPOSAL. WITHOUT ADDITIONAL ALL
FEDERAL MONEY IS GOING TO BE UP
WOULD REQUIRE THAT EVERY THING
GO RIGHT. OF EXPERIENCE WHICH WE
HAVE NOT HAD TO DATE. SO THERE
IS A RISK AND I WOULD NOT BE
CONFIDENT THAT WITH THE EXISTING
MONEY THAT BAKERSFIELD TO MERCED
CAN BE COMPLETED THAT WOULD
DESTROY FEDERAL MONEY OF COURSE
BROUGH CHANGE THAT. WHAT WE NEED
TO ADD AND I DID SAY TODAY AND
BRIAN ALSO AGREED. THAT GETTING
OUTSIDE THE CENTRAL VALLEY IT'S
GOING TO REQUIRE A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE OF NEW MONEY THAT HASN'T.
TRIED YET. THANK YOU I'D
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS OF
PUTTING- PUTTING A SOME BALL IN
OUR COURT WHICH IS A THAT WE
HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO AS A LEGISLATURE.
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT WORKING WITH
THE AUTHORITY IN THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE HOW TO HOW TO FIND AND
PAY FOR THIS- AND THAT THERE ARE
THERE ARE YOU AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THERE PROBABLY DOES NEED TO
BE A CLEARER. MESSAGE COMING OUT
OF THE LEGISLATURE IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE'D LIKE TO KNOW A NUMBER
OF US REPRESENT OUR OWN
DISTRICTS AND THEIR THOUGHTS IN
THIS AREA BUT I DON'T KNOW I
WOULD AGREE WITH YOU I KNOW THAT
THERE IF THERE IS ONE Q. SET OF.
LEGISLATIVE THOUGHT- SO DON'T GO
JUST MISTER KELLY JUST KIND OF
PIGGYBACKING ON. MISTER MISTER
THOMPSON'S POINT OF VIEW WOULD
YOU AGREE WITH THAT ASSESSMENT
THAT- IN ORDER TO FINISH THE
CURRENT PROJECT WE'RE GONNA NEED
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDING. WELL
AS WE ARE IN LET ME JUST CHECK A
COUPLE THINGS FIRST- ONE THING
THAT LIEU THOMPSON HAS BEEN SPOT
ON FROM FROM DAY ONE I CAN.
THINK WE CONCUR WITH. YOU ARE
OUR ONLY SOURCE OF ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THIS PROJECT RIGHT
NOW IS CAP AND TRADE FUNDING
INTO EVERYTHING ELSE IS ONE
TIME. BOND DOLLARS WHAT TIME
FEDERAL FUNDING. WHEN WE CAN GET
- BE ONGOING STABLE SOURCES CAP
AND TRADE AND CAP AND TRADE HAS
HAD MOMENTS OF VOLATILITY. AND
SO THE NUMBER ONE RISK THAT WE
IDENTIFIED IN THIS BUSINESS
PLAN. FOR ANYTHING THAT WE'RE
GOING TO DO IS A FUNDING RISK.
WHAT WE HAVE ADVOCATED IN FOUR
CONSECUTIVE BUSINESS. THAT THE
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM BE
EXTENDED TO THE COMPLETION DATES
AND THE A PROGRAMMATIC BATES OF
THE BENEFITS OF THAT PROGRAM TO
TWENTY FIFTY. OR WE ASKED HIM
REQUESTED THAT WE BE ABLE TO
FINANCE AGAINST THOSE PLANS
WOULD YOU BRING MONEY FORWARD SO
I DID YOU KNOW FUNDING
STABILIZATION IS A KEY PART OF
WHAT WHAT WHAT WE'RE ADVOCATING
FOR AND WHAT WE HAVE ADVOCATED
FOR. R. THE HARDEST PART OF MY
JOB AMONG MANY DIFFICULTIES. IS
TRYING TO DEFEND TO FOLKS. THAT
I SOMEHOW HAVE FUNDING TO DO IT
ALL. I DON'T. NOT QUITE CANDID
ABOUT THAT. I HAVE A WE HAVE
ESTIMATED A BUDGET WE HAVE TO
TWENTY THIRD. AND WE THINK THAT
WE HAVE ESTIMATED WHAT WE CAN DO
WITH THAT. AND WE THINK IT GETS
AN OPERATING RUN GOING TO THE
VALLEY THE KEY RISK IS A FUNDING
RISK. BECAUSE CAP AND TRADE HAS
BEEN VOTER. AND I WILL BE NEW
WILL MORE I WILL LIKELY NEED NEW
FEDERAL MONEY TO MAKE SURE I CAN
DO THAT AS A DOUBLE TRACK. AND
WHAT THAT IS NOT A NEW OR
SURPRISE. WE INDICATED THAT LAST
YEAR. AND SAID YOU KNOW BECAUSE
OF BUDGET CONSTRAINTS WE
CONSIDER A SINGLE TRACK BUT A
DOUBLE TRACK. WILL TAKE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING IN FEDERAL
FUNDS IS A GOOD PLACE TO GO. AND
SO OUR OPPONENTS OF THE QUESTION
BUT- BUT BUT FUNDAMENTALLY YEAH
HE'S RIGHT THE VOLATILITY OF ARE
FIGHTING TO. GET BIGGEST
CIGARETTES AND THE LIMITATIONS.
NO I APPRECIATE THAT AND I THINK
I THINK. THE CHURCH ADDRESS I
THINK YOU'RE THE ONE BY TAKE
AWAY WITH. MISTER THOMPSON I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH HIM IS- IT I
WOULD EVEN SAY THE- BEYOND THE
LEGISLATURE NOT BE ON THE SAME
PAGE THE ASSEMBLY THE SENATE ARE
ON THE SAME PAGE- AND- YOU KNOW.
YOU IN THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON
THE SAME PAGE WITH US AND- IF WE
WOULD LIKE THIS PROJECT TO GO
FORWARD I THINK WE DO NEED TO
TAKE MISTER THOMPSON'S DEVICE.
GET TOGETHER- TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE ON THE SAME PAGE THAT
DISCUSSION AND YOU AND I HAVE
TALKED ABOUT THAT DISCUSSION
EVEN GOING BACK TO LAST YEAR.
THE DISCUSSION HASN'T HAPPENED-
THERE THERE IS NO UNDERSTANDING
THERE IS NO AGREEMENT THERE USE.
THAT HASN'T EVEN BEEN A- OUTSIDE
OF THESE OVERSIGHT HEARINGS A-
DISCUSSION REALLY. ABOUT WHAT IS
THE YOU KNOW THE STATE'S LONG
TERM VISION AND I'VE MET WITH
PARTS OF THE STATE I MEAN.
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT LET
LEGISLATURE YOUR YOUR BODY YOUR
BOARD. MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS
WHAT WE'RE COMMITTED TO IT I
THINK YOUR- YOUR YOUR FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT GETTING. A
FUNDING COMMITMENT. AND THE
LEGISLATORS ON WILLING TO GIVE
YOU A FUNDING COMMITMENT BECAUSE
WE HAVEN'T SIGNED OFF ON A PLAN
. AND SO I THINK IT'S VERY
COMMON THIS IS A VERY LARGE
PROJECT MR THOMPSON'S RIGHT A
LOT OF MOVING PARTS LOT
UNCERTAINTY. THAT IS THE-
BIGGEST PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE AT
THIS. TIME SO I THINK IF YOU. IN
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WE WANT
THIS PROJECT BEFORE I THINK YOU
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO- SIT DOWN.
WITH OUR HOUSE THAT DOWN WITH
THE SENATE CAN REALLY HAMMER
THIS OUT I THINK WE HAVE TO DO
IT FRANKLY TOGETHER- EURO YOU
OTHERWISE YOU COULD I THINK YOUR
YOUR FAIR YOU'RE COMPLETELY FAIR
TO SAY HEY. I THINK A COMMITMENT
I'M GONNA DO WHAT I CAN
WHAT I GOT THAT'S ALL I CAN DO
AND I THINK AND I THINK THAT'S
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING TO SOME
EXTENT I THINK THAT'S A VERY
FAIR STATEMENT- WE ON THE OTHER
HAND CAN EXPECT ANY MORE ANY
LESS. AND LESS WE COMMIT A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF FUNDING BUT
AGAIN IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR US
TO COMMIT WITHOUT KNOWING WHAT
WE'RE COMMITTING TO DOUBT. FOR
ME PERSONALLY FOR MY DISTRICT
FOR MY CITY I THINK WE CONTINUE
TO BE- ARE. FULLY COMMITTED TO
THIS VISION OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
THIS CONNECTION FROM SAN
FRANCISCO TO LA I FOR ONE WOULD
LOVE NOTHING BETTER TO BE ABLE
TO. HOP ON A TRAIN IN DOWNTOWN
SAN FRANCISCO AND END UP IN IN
DOWNTOWN LA YOU KNOW A FEW HOURS
LATER- SO HAVING SAID THAT THAT
THE VISION IS SOMETHING THAT.
YOU KNOW I PERSONALLY REMAIN
COMMITTED TO I KNOW OUR OUR
REGION STANDS FAIRLY COMMITTED
TO THAT BUT- I FEEL LIKE I'M IN
THE MINORITY MY CAUCUS AND ALSO
I THINK I'M IN THE MINORITY IN
THE STATE AT THIS POINT- SO. I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF WORK TO
DO. I REALLY APPRECIATE OUR
CHAIRS LEADERSHIP AND REALLY
TRYING TO KEEP KEEP THE BALL
MOVING- ON THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
BUT I REALLY WOULD ENCOURAGE-
ALL OF US WHO WHO CARE ABOUT
THIS PROJECT AND WE ALL NEED TO
KIND OF SIT DOWN AND HAMMER OUT
A LOT OF THESE. DETAILS AND
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT HER DOCTOR
MISTER THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
TANK- AND I'LL HAVE MORE TO SAY
ON THAT- AS WE- CONCLUDES. OUR
HEARING TODAY I DO HAVE AN
UPDATE FOR YOU- I AND I
APOLOGIZE TO THOSE WHO. HERE TO-
PARTICIPATE IN OUR SPEAK ON
ITEMS THREE THROUGH TWELVE. BUT
WE ARE GOING TO PUSH ALL OF
THOSE AT A OFF TO A FEW MEETING
AND- RESTRICT OURSELVES AND GIVE
OURSELVES MORE TIME. ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE BUT WILL-
COMPLETE ITEMS ONE AND TWO-
ISSUES ONE AND TWO. ON- QUAN ON
THE AGENDA I'M THE WITH THAT OF
THE MOVE ON TO- VICE CHAIR FONG
. BUT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WANT TO COMMEND YOU- COMMAND-
THE CHAIR PLEDGING
TRANSPORTATION- ON THE ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS UP TO IN THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS EVE- OVER I'VE- I'VE
ACTUALLY SERVED- ON THE BACK ON
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE. ON
SEPT THREE AND ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- OF WATCHING THIS
PROJECT I KNOW HOW. MUCH OF
THOSE CONCERNS ARE- OUR OUR OUR
BED IN BUILDING SO- AS SOMEONE
WHO- IS AFFECTED BY THIS PROJECT
IN MY COMMUNITY BAKERSFIELD-
CERTAINLY- THIS IS. A BIG DEAL
AND- OVERSIGHT IS NECESSARY I
COMMEND THE CHAIRED THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE- ON HIS QUESTIONS WE
MAY COME TO A DIFFERENT
CONCLUSION. BUT I THINK MORE
OVERSIGHT IS COMPLETE NECESSARY
AND- I HUMBLY REQUEST MAYBE WE
HAVE AN ADDITIONAL- HEARING MAY
BE THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE-
ON THE ON GOING TO THE SPECIFICS
OF HIGH SPEED RAIL- BUT- I JUST
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AND MY
QUESTIONS ARE ARE DIRECTED TO
THE L. L. BUT- I FIND IT VERY
INTERESTING AND I WOULD
HIGHLIGHT THIS TO MEMBERS IS
THAT. WHAT SHE SAID IN HER
TESTIMONY WAS THAT HE- REPORTS
TEN YEARS AGO HIGHLIGHTED. THESE
ISSUES AND THEY HAVEN'T CHANGED.
AND I'VE SAID THIS IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND OTHER COMMITTEES
IN THE PAST THAT THE ONLY
PREDICTOR OF FUTURE BEHAVIOR IS
PAST BEHAVIOR AND SO WE EXPECT.
THE HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY TO
CHANGE SOMEHOW. WELL SOMETHING
SOME EXTERNAL FORCE HAS TO BE
PLACED ON IT. AND AND AS THE
CHAIRMAN SHOULD BE FOR- AND OUR
FREIGHT ALFREDO IT DIFFERENTLY.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME. THAT THE
HIGH THROUGHOUT THIRTY IS ASKING
FOR MORE MONEY. BUT THEN WE
DON'T LIKE WHAT THEY'VE BEEN
DOING WITH THE MONEY SO WHY
WOULD WE GIVE. THEM MORE MONEY
IF WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT'S
BEEN HAPPENING. I WILL LASTLY
SAVED IN MY COMMENTS. THAT WHEN
WE WENT HIGH SPEED RATHER ONE
THE CONCEPT OF HIGH SPEED RAIL
OR THIS PROJECT WAS FIRST PUT ON
THE BALLOT. THE ESTIMATE WAS
THAT THIS ENTIRE PROJECT WOULD
BE THIRTY THREE BILLION DOLLARS
. AND NOW WITH APPROACHING A
HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS- ON THE
ON THE HIGHER RANGE. SO SO MY
QUESTION TO THE ELIO IS. HOW
REALISTIC. IS THIS BUSINESS PLAN
I MEAN IN IN YOUR IN IN YOUR
CANDID ANALYSIS I'LL THE
SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY STATE
THAT. JUST FOUR- AN EXAMPLE. THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY
ASSUMES AN INFLATION RATE OF TWO
POINT 25% FOR COST MATERIALS THE
CURRENT RATE OF SEVEN POINT FIVE
PERCENT. AND YOU INDICATED IN
YOUR HAND OUT THAT THE INFLATION
FOR THE CONSTRUCTION SECTOR. WAS
13% TWENTY TWENTY ONE. SO TO THE
ELIO HOW REALISTIC IS THIS
BUSINESS PLAN. I THINK THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF RISK RIGHT THERE
AND WE TALK ABOUT THIS I THINK
ABOUT THIS BUT IT IS-
PRESENTATION A LITTLE BIT BY- I
THINK THERE'S A RISK ON THE ON
THE CONSTRUCTION COST SIDE AS
YOU AS YOU HIGHLIGHTED- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERTAINLY COST COULD BE
HIGHER I MEAN THIS IS REALLY
NOT. A TIME WHERE WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF AND INCREASES IN
CONSTRUCTION COSTS AND THERE'S
JUST A LOT OF RISK- IF IT'S
PROJECT THERE'S THE AGAIN FOR
THAT INITIAL CONSTRUCTION
SEGMENT THAT RESEARCH OR CENTRAL
VALLEY SEGMENT SOMETIMES
REFERRED TO THAT ONE HUNDRED
NINETEEN MILE SEGMENT- YEAH WE
DON'T REALLY KNOW WHAT THE FINAL
CONTRACTOR CLAIMS WILL BE
RESOLVED THAT AND THAT AMOUNT
COULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER WE
JUST DON'T KNOW RIGHT WE DON'T
HAVE INFORMATION. AND AT YET-
FROM THE AGORI WERE HOPING TO
GET SOME- WE'RE WE'RE THANK YOU-
WITH THEM AND- OUR OFFICE IS
MAJOR QUESTION- BUT AT THIS
POINT WE DON'T HAVE HAVE- ANY
INFORMATION REALLY ON WHAT THE
SCALE OF THOSE COSTS WILL BE
THEN THE EXTENSION TO MERCED
AND- BAKERSFIELD THOSE ARE
REALLY STILL THE VERY EARLY
PLANNING STAGES. NO THERE'S JUST
THERE'S RISK THERE TO YOU RIGHT
SO THERE'S GONNA COSTS AND THEN
ADDS MR KELLY MENTIONED THERE
CERTAINLY WAS GONNA ON THE
REVENUE SIDE TO YOU I MEAN
CAPITAL RESTORED CLEAN HANDS I'M
HAS GONE UP AND DOWN OVER YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT ALWAYS IT'S NOT
SUPER CONSISTENT SO WE HAD A
COUPLE REALLY ROBUST RAP-
AUCTIONS. BUT WHAT I CAN SEE THE
TWENTY THIRTY THERE'S JUST A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTIES SO I'M I WOULD
HAVE LIKE THAT I THINK IT'S JUST
IT'S TOUGH TO SAY- NO PROBLEM
YEAH BUT WE NEED TO GET A LOT OF
FEDERAL FUNDING MAYBE THAT WILL
HELP ADDRESS THE ISSUE I THINK
HISTORICALLY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAD IT FUNDED I.
WOULD SURMISE BY THE SAME THING
TWICE SO- YOU FIGURE OUT WHICH
PIECES WE CAN GET THEM TO FIND
THEY'VE ALREADY FUNDED- YOU KNOW
THE ONE NINETEEN ON THE TRACK
WELL WHAT THEY COULD TO GET THEM
HELP WITH EXTENSIONS WOULD WE
WOULD THAT WOULD BE SUCCESSFUL
IN GRANTS YOU KNOW. I'M GRATEFUL
SITUATION THERE'S NO MONEY
THAT'S DEDICATED FOR THIS
PROJECT IN THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BELL- MORE FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND INFRASTRUCTURE. BILL SO IT'S
COMPATIBLE SO IT'S JUST ME JUST
DON'T KNOW- AND- THERE'S A LOT
OF UNCERTAINTY OUT THERE AD
WELL THAT'S BECAUSE- COSTS. YOU
KNOW THAT THEIR- HIGH. OF
INFLATION INCREASE IN CONTINUE.
IF IT DOES I THINK THAT THAT
WOULD BE. CERTAINLY JOHN FOR THE
PRIDE BUT- BUT AGAIN IT'S JUST
HARD HARD TO THAT CRISP BALL.
WHAT I WOULD SAY IT'S NOT IF
THEY'LL BE INCREASE ITS MUCH IS
THE SO A WHAT IT MAKES. FOR THE
L. A. ELEMENT. DIFFERENT
CALCULATIONS BASED ON DIFFERENT
RANGES ASSUMING. DIFFERENT
INFLATION RATES- AND MAYBE THIS
IS A QUESTION FOR- FOR THE
THOMPSON AS WELL. BUT IT SEEMS
TO ME THAT. ALL THE BUSINESS
PLAN IS ONLY AS GOOD AS THE
ASSUMPTIONS IN IT. ANY OF THE
ASSUMPTIONS ARE WRONG THEN WE'RE
MAKING MASSIVE AMOUNTS OF
INVESTMENT- ON SOMETHING THAT IS
INCORRECT AND SO IF THERE'S A
TWO POINT 25% AND INFLATION RATE
ASSUME TO BY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY WOULD MAKE SENSE TO
DO- DIFFERENT RANGES ASSUMING 5%
7% OR SOMETHING HIGHER. I'M SO-
I'LL DEFER TO LIVE IN JUST A
MINUTE YEAH I MEAN I THINK I
THINK THAT I THINK IT'S HELPFUL
TO HAVE A RANGE RIGHT AND IT
ALREADY HAS INTRODUCED IN THE
LAST FEW BUSINESS PLANS THEY'VE
INTRODUCED THEM YOU KNOW
AFFECTIVE RANGES AND SO THERE IS
CURRENTLY A RANGE FOR EXAMPLE
FOR CENTIMETERS. BUT YOU'RE
RIGHT IT DOESN'T INCORPORATE
THAT SORT OF MAYBE EXACTLY THE
RANGE OF CONSTRUCTION COST
INFLATION SO I THINK THAT'S
CERTAINLY SOMETHING REASONABLE
TO THINK ABOUT- JUST RECOGNIZING
ESPECIALLY THAT THE I MEAN I
THINK FOR YEARS RIGHT WE WERE IN
THIS RELATIVELY LOW INFLATION
ENVIRONMENT AND MAYBE THIS WAS
JUST LESS OF A CONCERN. AND
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL WE WERE
SEEING YOU KNOW PRETTY MODEST-
INFLATION AND YOU KNOW OVER THE
LAST YEAR THERE'S BEEN A CHANGE
THAT DYNAMIC AND WE'VE SEEN MUCH
MORE PRONOUNCED INFLATION YEAH
MORE BROADLY AN ECONOMY AS WELL
AS- CERTAINLY THE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS SO- I THINK IT IS WORTH IT
SORT OF REVISITING THAT AND
THINKING ABOUT HOW THAT SHOULD
BE. IT SHOULD BE WORKED AND
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
AUTHORITY ON THAT AND WILL- I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU. HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO ADD
. I JUST WONDERED IF THE- THAT
THE WORD I KEPT YOU. WAS AND-
THAT IS WE DON'T KNOW THERE IS A
WIDE RANGE OF. OUTCOMES FROM
THE- COST ESTIMATES THAT WE HAVE
ARE M. S. I DON'T SEE THIS TO BE
CRITICAL OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY I SIMPLY SAY IT TO
MAKE IT CLEAR TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT WE DON'T KNOW
HOW THESE NUMBERS ARE GOING TO
TURN OUT AND WE CAN'T HELP THESE
NUMBERS TURNED OUT PART OF THAT.
IS THAT PAST EXPERIENCE DOESN'T
GIVE US RIGHT YET CONFIDENCE IN
FUTURE PERFORMANCE OF THAT WE
WILL BE NICE IF IT DID BUT IT
DOESN'T. LESSONS HAVE BEEN
LEARNED AT I THINK IMPROVEMENT
IS THERE BUT THE LESSONS HAVE
BEEN LEARNED HAVE BEEN EXPENSIVE
AND THEY'VE BEEN LEARNED THE
HARD WAY. BUT ALSO. WE DO KNOW A
LEADERSHIP DON'T WHO PROJECT
BUDGET ARE NOT UP DATE HELLO AS
WE DON'T WE HAVEN'T COURT. AS
MUCH OF BIG. WE MY HAVE. WE
DON'T HAVE THE EXPERIENCE WITH
STUFF THAT WE HAVEN'T DONE YET
LIKE ELECTRIFICATION OR
TUNNELING OR OR SIGNALING A
ROLLING STOCK IN THAT REPRESENTS
MORE THAN HALF OF THE COST OF
THE PROJECT. AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE FULL IMPACT OF COVER IT
IS GOING TO BE IN TERMS OF
INFLATION AND TERMS OF
PERFORMANCE. ALL IN I HAVE TO
TELL YOU THAT I WAS RUNNING THE
NORTHEAST CORNER. DURING THE
CARTER ADMINISTRATION WHEN WE
TRIED TO UPDATE. BUDGETS THE
WHAT INFLATION REALLY ONES WE
WERE TOLD BY IT WOULDN'T BE THAT
THAT CONFLICTS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S REVEAL TRUTHS
ABOUT WHAT INFLATION IS GOING TO
BE. SO YOU CAN'T UPDATE. SO
BRIAN IS OPERATING WITHIN
CONSTRAINTS THAT MAKE IT REALLY
HARD FOR HIM TO GIVE YOU.
ACCURATE INFORMATION. NORMALLY
WHAT YOU WHEN THIS SEARCH. MAKE
A MAJOR EFFORT TO ATTRACT ALL OF
THE AREA BOB. SOME YOU CAN'T
ATTACK WE DON'T KNOW WHEN
INFLATION IS GOING TO BE NEXT
YEAR HOW LONG THAT IS GOING TO.
CONTINUE BUT WE CAN CERTAINLY
ATTACK THE NEED FOR UP TO DATE
THE MOST RECENT UP TO DATE
INFORMATION THE MOST RECENT.
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HAS
HAPPENED TO DATE AND- THEN
CERTAINLY PRESS OWN THINGS LIKE
ALL TRYING TO GET ESTIMATES THE
BEST AVAILABLE ESTIMATES OF
STUFF THAT HASN'T DONE YET BASED
ON FOREIGN EXPERIENCE SO.
OVERALL I THINK THE ADVICE THE
LEGISLATURE IS THAT TAKE THESE
NUMBERS WERE CAUTIOUSLY. BECAUSE
THEY ARE SUBJECT TO A WIDE RANGE
OF OUTCOMES END OF THE TRIED TO
DO EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO ACQUIRE
THE BEST POSSIBLE UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THE NUMBERS MEAN AND
WHAT THE EXPERIENCES TOLD US. I
THANK YOU MISTER JOHNSON I THINK
IN THIS HEARING I'VE LOST TRACK
OF THE AMOUNT OF TIMES THE WORDS
RISK AND UNCERTAINTY HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED. COM AND I THINK IT
GIVES ME GREAT PAUSE- MY LAST
QUESTION I'M SENSITIVE TO THE
TIMES I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE- THE ABILITY
ASK QUESTIONS WELL ADD TO THE L.
A. L. ON YOUR LAST ON THE LAST
PAGE OF REPORT- YOU'VE
INDICATED- AND YOU WROTE THIS.
OUT. THAT- THE OF THE SHE COULD
I A BUNCH TRAILING LIMITING OR
PREVENTING- HSR A FROM
COMMITTING THE STATE SUCH AS THE
TERMS OF GRANT AGREEMENTS
ECCENTRIC CETERA- TO UNDERTAKEN
WORK BEYOND WHAT THE LEGISLATORS
COMFORTABLE COMMITTING TO
FUNDING AS SPECIFIED IN STATUTE
THIS COULD BE IMPORTANT GIVEN
THAT THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY HAS ENTERED INTO
PASSED GRANT AGREEMENTS THAT
HAVE CONSTRAINED. LEGISLATIVE
CHOICES YOU'VE INDICATED ONE
EXAMPLE BUT COULD YOU GIVE US
ADDITIONAL EXAMPLES IN WHICH THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY HAS
CONSTRAINED OUR- OUR ABILITY TO
MAKE DECISIONS. WELL I WOULD
ARGUE THAT THAT THAT SORT OF THE
ORIGINAL GRANT AGREEMENT THAT WE
SIGNED INITIALLY- REALLY SORT OF
SET IN MOTION A LOT OF THIS
PROJECT IN A LOT OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE PROJECT IS
BASED- I THINK EVEN THE
AUTHORITY- HAS MENTIONED A
NUMBER OF TIMES THAT. YOU KNOW
WE RUSHED WE ENTERED INTO THIS
AGREEMENT WITH THE FEDS WERE
GONNA DO THE CENTRAL VALLEY
RIGHT WE HAD TO START RIGHT AWAY
YEAH THESE THESE THAT THESE VERY
SHORT- DEADLINE. I TO SPEND ERA
FUNDS FOR EXAMPLE AND WE THAT
WE- ENTERED INTO THAT. TO
CONTRACT BEFORE WE REALLY DONE
THE PRELIMINARY WORK BEFORE WE
DIVE RIGHT AWAY BEFORE WE DONE
THE DESIGN- AND THE STATE ENDED
UP- HAS HAS BEEN PAYING FOR IT-
REALLY EVER SENSE AND THOSE ARE
STILL THE ISSUES THAT. I THINK
MISTER KELLY WAS REFERRING TO
SOME OF WHICH ARE SO HE'S HE'S
STILL WITH SOLVING YOU KNOW
CLAIMS AND OTHER ISSUES THAT
RELATE TO THAT RIGHT. SO YOU
KNOW THAT'S PART OF IT'S GREAT
TO GET FEDERAL MONEY I THINK WE
KNOW WHAT WE AT THE STATE ALWAYS
LIKE TO GET- GET ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THAT WE DO NEED TO BE
REALLY CAREFUL AND CAUTIOUS.
ABOUT MAKING SURE THAT WHEN WE-
DO THOSE AGREEMENTS WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHERE DO SO
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T HAVE
REQUIREMENTS THAT COSTING US
MORE YOU KNOW. I'M AND CREATING
MORE CHALLENGES FOR THE STATE SO
I THINK THAT'S BEEN JUST REALLY
HISTORY OF THE PROJECT FROM FROM
REALLY YOU KNOW IT'S BEGINNING
THAT WE HAVE BEEN CONSTRAINED BY
OUR FEDERAL GRANT AGREEMENTS-
AND THAT SORT OF- YOU KNOW. MADE
MADE MADE THE PROJECT MAKES THEM
STOP OPTIMAL CHOICES RUSHED
THINGS THAT SHOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
RUSHED PERHAPS- AND MADE IT MORE
CHALLENGING AND THEN AND
CERTAINLY THIS MOST RECENT-
GRANT AGREEMENT THAT THAT
REALLY- IDENTIFIES ALIVE. THE
ELECTRIFICATION REALLY
THROUGHOUT SO THAT'S IT THAT
THERE'S I THINK I THINK. AGREE
ABOUT THAT ON IT PROBABLY MORE
THAN. ONE CASE. I THANK YOU-
THAT IS VERY ALLOW. I'LL JUST
CAN BY. THAT I THAT THERE'S
BETTER ABOUT OF TAX- WE NEED TO
RE OF THE PROJECT- WITH OUR WIDE
. AND WE CAN IGNORE ANYMORE- THE
MAY ISSUES THAT ABOUT BEEN OUT
EVERY SINGLE BUSINESS PLAN THAT
HAS BEEN PRESENTED TO US- SINCE
I'VE BEEN LEGISLATURE AND SINCE
I'VE SERVED IN A TRANSMISSION
COMMITTEE AND THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AND WITH THAT- I
WOULD CERTAINLY ASK- MY
COLLEAGUES TO DO MORE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS- ON THIS PROJECT ON A
CONSISTENT BASIS I KNOW THAT
CHAIR AND- THE ON THE AND THE
JOB TRANSPORTATION IN THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE- IN THE BUDGET
YEAR HAVE COMMITTED. ARE
COMMITTED TO OVERSIGHT AND SO
THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING THAT I
WOULD ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
DO THANKS VERY MUCH MR. I YOU'RE
WELCOME MR FONG WE HAVE A MISTER
PATTERSON FOLLOWED BY MS RIVAS
MS FRIEDMAN AND I THINK- MISTER
SMITH THIS. AND BENNETT. MISTER
THANK YOU. UP I A CAR I HAVE.
PERSONAL REVIEW- THIS DRAFT PLAN
AND I HAVE ALSO PARTICIPATED FOR
A NUMBER OF YEARS AND- LISTENING
TO THE QUESTIONS THE COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES IN MY VIEW THIS
DRAFT PLAN IS UTTERLY
INADEQUATE. AND IN FACT I THINK
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO DEFEND
IT AS A BUSINESS PLAN. I HAVE
ANYTHING MORE TO SAY I DON'T
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS TO
ASK BUT I DID WANT TO. MAKE THAT
STATEMENT FOR THE RECORD RIGHT I
THANK YOU- AND IS RIVAS BEFORE
YOU BEGIN WITH YOUR REMARKS OR
QUESTIONS- WHAT WE PAUSE FOR A
SECOND AND ALLOW YOU TO ADD ON
TO THE VOTE ONLY- A CALENDAR THE
VOTE THAT WE TOOK EARLIER. I
HAVE HAD. ABOUT ONLY RIVAS AT. I
THOUGHT IT WAS ONLY A- ALL
RIGHT- WE. MISERY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- I THINK A LOT OF
MY CAR AND HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ADDRESSED BY OUR TRANSPORTATION
CHAIR AND OUR BUDGET CHAIR OF I
FEEL LIKE WE GO THROUGH THIS
EVERY YEAR RIGHT I'VE BEEN ON
THIS SUB COMMITTEE MOST OF THE
TIME THAT I'VE SERVED IN THE
ASSEMBLY OUR END OF I FEEL THAT
IT'S ALWAYS DIFFICULT TO GET.
THE ANSWERS THAT WE WANT. OR
THAT WE NEED TO MAKE THE FUNDING
DECISIONS FROM THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY- AND ONE OF THE
COMMENTS THAT. ARE I BELIEVE
MISTER THOMPSON MADE- WAS HOW DO
WE STRUCTURE OURSELVES IN THE
LEGISLATURE. OF TO HAVE MORE
OVERSIGHT R. THE LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT OF THIS PROJECT THE-
ONE OF THE LARGEST PROJECTS
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS EVER IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU
KNOW ARE WE CURRENTLY
STRUCTURED. OF AT TO PROVIDE
THAT OVERSIGHT TO THE AUTHORITY
FIVE AND YOU I'VE BEEN THINKING
LIKE EVEN BETWEEN HOUSES YOU
KNOW IS THIS THE TIME. THAT WE
CONSIDER PERHAPS A JOINT
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ON THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL FREIGHT BECAUSE- THIS
PROJECT. ITSELF DOES IT
POTENTIALLY DESERVES A COMMITTEE
THAT COULD BE MADE UP OF- THE
CURRENT CHAIRS- THAT. CURRENTLY
HAVE. THE JURISDICTION IN THEIR
COMMITTEES. YOU KNOW I THINK THE
PEER REVIEW SUGGESTED THAT THE
MANAGEMENT ISSUES. OF OUR
PERHAPS THE FAULT OF THE
LEGISLATURE BUT- WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING. TO YOU KNOW GET
INFORMATION THAT WE NEED AN-
EACH DRAFT PLAN AND WE GET VERY
LITTLE OF. ANSWERS TO OUR
QUESTIONS OFTEN WHEN WE APPROACH
EITHER THE AUTHORITY OR THROUGH
THE DRAFT PLAN STILL DOESN'T
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS WHAT WERE
EXPECTED TO VOTE AND RELEASE
FUNDING TO THIS PROJECT SO I
HOPE THAT WE CAN THINK MORE
ABOUT OUR OWN STRUCTURE HERE.
AND WHETHER. THERE IS ANOTHER
WAY FOR US TO PROVIDE THAT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT. THANKS.
OKAY THANK YOU- MS FRIEDMAN- ARE
YOUR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
RELATIVELY SHORT BECAUSE I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE EVERYBODY GETS
AN OPPORTUNITY WHO HAVEN'T
SPOKEN ALREADY FOR SHORT THANK
YOU SO I WAS A LITTLE BIT
UNCLEAR WITH THE BUSINESS PLAN
IT IS ROLLING STOCK PURCHASES IN
THE BUSINESS PLAN AND IF SO
WOULDN'T IT MAKE MORE SENSE. TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU CAN FINISH
YOUR TRACK AND EVERYTHING THAT
YOU NEED TO DO TO HAVE A
COMPLETE SYSTEM BEFORE YOU
COMMIT TO PURCHASING ROLLING
STOCK. YEAH WE ARE NOT
COMMITTING TO PURCHASE AND
ROLLING STOCK BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT KIND OF ROLLING STOCK
TO PURCHASE. BECAUSE THERE'S NO
DESCRIPTION THERE'S NO DECISION
MADE YET ELECTRIFICATION NOT. WE
DID PUT IN THE PLAN AND WHAT WE
PREFER TO DO. BUT WE'RE NOT
GONNA WE'RE NOT GONNA GET INTO
THE PROCUREMENT OF ROLLING STOCK
WE DON'T HAVE ALSO DECISION.
WELL WECERTAINLY STAND BY. TWO
DISCS HAVE THESE DISCUSSIONS
WITH YOU AS WE DID LAST YEAR AND
THE ADMINISTRATION WOULD LOVE TO
SIT DOWN AND- TRY TO WORK OUT
THESE DETAILS. AT THAT WE HAVE
MISTER SMITH NEXT OF ALL BY
MISTER BENNETT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR INSTEAD OF A VERY ACTIVE
MEETING HERE. BUT THE PROBLEM IS
WE GOT ON A BUDGET PLAN. THAT WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT'S IN THE
BUDGET. BECAUSE WE HAVE A OF
BUSINESS PLAN THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO. APPROVE FUNDING FOR. WE
WON'T HAVE THE BUDGET FOR
ANOTHER YEAR. SO MY QUESTION IS
IN REGARDS TO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE SETS BEFORE US. WHAT IS
GONNA HAPPEN TO THE REST OF THE
PROJECT IF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
DOES NOT GET IT FUNDING. MAYBE
THE L. A. O. OR WHO CAN ANSWER
THAT QUESTION. AND THEN I WOULD
ASK YOU IS THE CHAIR OF SUB
THREE. FOR INFRASTRUCTURE AND
BUDGET CHAIR KING AND VICE CHAIR
FONG IF WE CAN TOTALLY SEPARATE
THIS OUT IN THE BUDGET STRICTLY
FOR HIGH SPEED RAIL WE ALL HAVE
MAJOR CONCERNS WITH IT. I DON'T
THINK IT SHOULD BE A PACKAGE
WITH OTHER ITEMS THAT WE HAVE
MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE
NEED TO DO IN CALIFORNIA AND
HAVE A STAND. BUDGET ITEM. AND
WE WILL KNOW FOR THE VOTE OF THE
LEGISLATORS FOR THE- PEOPLE IN
THEIR DISTRICTS KNOW EXACTLY HOW
THEY STAND WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL
. AND NOT KEEPING THE BALL DOWN
THE ROAD. FOR THIS PROJECT
BECAUSE IT STARTED OUT WITH THE
VOTERS APPROVED IT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT IT'S GOING TO
COST THIRTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS
AND I WAS GOING TO GET ON IN LOS
ANGELES AND BE IN FRISCO. IN AN
HOUR TO. THERE WERE NO WHERE
NEAR THAT. OVER A 130% OVER
BUDGET ALREADY THERE WERE NO
WHERE NEAR WHERE IT'S GOING TO
BE. WE HAVE A PROJECT IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. IT MIGHT BE A
BICYCLE PATH TO WE STARTED WITH
TWO TRACKS NOW WE'RE DOWN TO ONE
TRACK WE HAVE NO TRACK AND NO
TRAINS. WE NEED TO REALLY LOOK
AT THIS PROJECT AND I THINK IT
NEEDS TO BE A STANDALONE BUDGET
ITEM. SO THE EIGHTY MEMBERS OF
THE ASSEMBLY. CAN VOICE OUR
CONCERN FOR CONSTITUENTS THEY
REPRESENT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND FINALLY SAVE
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WHEN HIGH
SPEED RAIL CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
. YOU'RE WELCOME- GOT A GOOD
THING- CHAIR TANGO IS NOT HERE.
TO HEAR YOU REFER TO IS CITY BY
SHORTHAND THAT'S NOT PREFERRED.
MISTER SMITH BENNETT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I'D LIKE TO JUST TRY
TO POINT OUT SOME RISK THAT I
THINK HAVE NOT BEEN IDENTIFIED
OR APPROPRIATELY- CLARIFIED
WE'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
STATED THAT THE GREATEST RISK IS
THE LACK OF- CONSISTENT FUNDING
FOR THE PROJECT BUT I WOULD
OFFER TO YOU EQUALLY AS GREAT IS
A COMPLETE UNCERTAINTY ABOUT.
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN WITH COST
AND THEY THEY ARE TWO SIDES OF
THE SAME COIN BUT WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THE FUNDING SOURCES ARE WE
ALSO DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COST
ARE NOW IF YOU IF YOU JUST WENT
TO THE PUBLIC AND SAID. YOU KNOW
WE'RE GOOD RARE TACKLE THE
BIGGEST PROJECT WE'VE EVER DONE
AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
FUNDING IS GOING TO BE AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THE COST ARE I
THINK MOST PEOPLE WOULD SAY
THAT'S NOT VERY GOOD PLANNING IN
TERMS OF MOVING FORWARD. BUT
THIS PROJECT WAS INITIATED BY
INITIATIVE FRIED BITE BITE BITE
OF OVER THE PUBLIC SO DIDN'T GO
THROUGH THE NORMAL PLANNING
PROCESS BUT I WOULD OFFER A
THIRD RISK THAT I THINK IS GOING
TO CONTINUE TO COME UP BECAUSE
WE'RE SO DESPERATE FOR FUNDING.
AND THAT IS THAT A DESPERATE
SEARCH FOR SHORT TERM FUNDING IS
CAUSING US TO MAKE DECISIONS
STEP PUT THE WHOLE PROJECT AT
RISK. AND YOU JUST HEARD STAFF
SAY WE ONE OF THAT FEDERAL MONEY
WE HAD TO GET CONTRACTS SIGNED
RIGHT AWAY SO WE SIGNED
CONTRACTS BEFORE WE EVEN HAD
DESIGNS. AND NOW WE'VE GONE BACK
AND WE FIND OUT AND WE'RE WE'RE
WE'RE MOVING TO THE POINT WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO THE PUBLIC AND
THE POLITICAL SUPPORT NEEDED FOR
THIS PROJECT IS GOING TO JUST
TAILSPIN DOWN BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THAT THEY CAN'T GET THEIR
HANDS ON THIS SO I WOULD OFFER A
THIRD RISK. IS THAT WE CAN. A
THE TO. OF GRAB. SHORT FUNDS.
THAT REQUIRE US TO DO THINGS
THAT IN THE LONG RUN ARE NOT
GOOD FOR THE PROJECT RIGHT- AND
SO. THAT INITIATIVE IS THE
EXACT. OPPOSITE WAY OF HOW YOU
WOULD LAUNCH THE BIGGEST PROJECT
AT AND IT'S NOBODY'S FAULT WE'RE
NOW STUCK WITH WHERE WE ARE. SO
THE QUESTION IS. HOW DO WE STOP. M. PAUSING FOR THE BENEFIT OF
MY CHAIR I REALLY WANT TO CATCH
IS PART HOW HOW DO WE STOP. AND
REASSESS ALL OF THOSE RISK AND
TRY TO ELIMINATE AS MANY OF US
POSSIBLE GIVEN WHERE WE ARE WITH
THIS PARTICULAR PROJECT SO I
THINK EVERYBODY'S BEEN
APPROPRIATE I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS MADE BY- THAT ARE
CHAIRED BY TRANSPORTATION CHAIR
MR TANG AND IT AND EVEN OUR
COLLEAGUES ON THE FOR THE OTHER
SIDE FROM FROM- ABOUT THE
FRUSTRATION THERE'S LOTS OF
FRUSTRATION OUT THERE BUT IT'S
BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T. LAUNCHED
THIS PROJECT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING APPROPRIATELY AND I'VE
THINK RATHER THAN US AS MISS
REAVIS SAID EVERY YEAR WE'RE
BACK HERE. IF I THINK THIS IS
THE YEAR WE SHOULD STOP AND SAY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO COME BACK
HERE NEXT YEAR JUST LIKE THIS
WE'RE GONNA WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
EVALUATE THE BEST WEEKEND
THERE'S BEEN SOME SUGGESTIONS I
REALLY APPRECIATE HIM. AND
WANTED TO JUST OFFER THAT
THOUGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MUCH AND- OF IT WILL
HAPPEN MR YEAH. THANK YOU- I
GONNA GO BACK TO MISS SMITH- THE
HE CORRECTLY REMINDED ME THAT WE
DIDN'T REALLY GIVE STAFF A
CHANCE TO ANSWER HIS QUESTIONS-
I NOT STAFF BUT- ARE A SPEAKERS
. IT REPEAT THE QUESTION IF YOU
- IF YOU ARE A SUMMER REALLY
QUICKLY WHAT YOUR QUESTION IS
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IF. WITH
ALL THE OTHER PROJECTS IT'S IN
THIS REQUEST IF THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL DOES NOT GET. OF FUNDED AND
IS TO THE ALEJO'S OFFICE
PROBABLY WILL BE THE BEST ONE.
SO I'LL TAKE A WE HAVE ASKED
pADMINISTRATION AND THE RESPONSE
THAT WE'VE GOTTEN IS THAT THIS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AS A
PACKAGE WITH A FOUR POINT NINE
BILLION OF A GENERAL FUND
TRANSPORTATION DOLLARS TO THE
BASICALLY IT SHOULD BE ALL
CONSIDER TOGETHER THAT'S HOW THE
ADMINISTRATION IS. PUTTING THAT
FORWARD SO THAT THE RESPONSE
WE'VE GOTTEN FROM THEM I
DEFERRED AT THEM BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE ONES WHO ARE REALLY- YOU
KNOW WHO ARE REALLY PUTTING THAT
FORWARD SO THEY MAY HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL INSIGHTS AS TO IT
SORT OF WHAT THEY MEAN BY
BECAUSE THEY WERE ALL PACKAGE.
BUT THAT'S THAT'S WHEN WE HAVE
ASKED THAT QUESTION ABOUT
WHETHER THERE IS YOU KNOW HOW
THEY ARE LINKED TO YOUR- THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN TOLD IS
THAT THEY SHOULD BE CONSIDERED
AS A PACKAGE SO- PERHAPS
FINANCE- MIGHT HAVE SOME
COMMENTS ON THIS- MISTER
CHAIRMAN. YES AND WE HAVE A- MR
MORE- WAITING ON ISSUE TO- FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
MISTER MOORE IS IT POSSIBLE THAT
YOU CAN- ENLIGHTEN US ON THAT
QUESTION. BUT WHAT. THE STEVE
WELLS IN THE OF BY- ARE I CAN
STEP PLEASE. I APOLOGIZE THANK
YOU VERY YOU KNOW THE- OFF UP
THIS AS A AS A PACK- MOSTLY
BECAUSE THE- TRANSIT AND
INTERCITY RAIL. FUNDING THAT
WERE THAT IS PART OF THIS
COHESIVE PACKAGE- THE IDEA IS
THAT WE'RE BUILDING A SYSTEM.
USABLE AND WE'RE BUILDING UP A
SYSTEM STATEWIDE SO AS PART OF
THE SYSTEM WE HAVE THE WE HAVE
THE FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
COMPLETE THE CENTRAL VALLEY WITH
THE ONE A MONEY WE ALSO ARE
MAKING FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
ADVANCE COMPLEMENTARY PROJECTS-
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- JUST
STARTED TO CREATE A SYSTEM THAT
IS THAT IS A COMPREHENSIVE HE
SAID AS WE PLAN TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE PROJECT- I MEAN. IF YOU
KNOW THE IDEA THAT A PART OF THE
IDEA BEHIND THIS IS THAT WE YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- TO GUARANTEE THAT.
WERE WERE MEETING THE NEEDS OF
THE OF THE DIFFERENT
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE DIFFERENT
MEMBERS. AND YOU KNOW SORT OF
EVERYONE EVERYONE WORKING TOWARD
A COMMON GOAL ON THE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE VOTE BUT
pTHAT'S WHY WE PUT IT TOGETHER.
AS A PACKAGE RATHER THAN AS A
SEPARATE- A SEPARATE GROUP OF
FUNDING OR- COULD IT BE
CONSIDERED. WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
IN YOUR OFFICE. TO SEPARATE
THESE ITEMS OUT SO WE CAN GET A
DEFINITIVE IT DIDN'T FIT EVAN OF
ANSWER ON HIGH SPEED RAIL WE
STILL NEED ALL THESE OTHER
PROJECTS. BUT PUTTING THEM ALL
TOGETHER. COULD POSSIBLY KILL
ALL PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA WITH
HIS FUNDING. IF HIGH SPEED RAIL
IS NOT APPROVED. I'M I'M SORRY
THAT YOU HAVE A QUICK APRIL
COULD YOU COULD YOU THE GOVERNOR
THE GOVERNOR WALKER THE
GOVERNOR'S PRIORITY IS TO.
DEVELOP A PLAN THAT INCLUDES
HIGH SPEED RAIL SO WE'VE OFFERED
UP THIS PACKAGE THAT WERE- HAPPY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO
WORK WITH ALL THE MEMBERS TO
DEVELOP SOMETHING BUT WE WANT
YOU KNOW THAT IT'S THE
ADMINISTRATION'S HIGH PRIORITY
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE- THE HIGH
SPEED RAIL CONTINUES. AND THAT
WE COMPLETE THE SOMETHING. BUT
THAT'S THAT'S WHY WE PUT IT IN
THERE. AS A PACKAGE THAT WE CAN
WORK TOGETHER TO MOVE FORWARD.
REALLY HASH IT OUT FOR A LITTLE
BIT BUT I GUESS MY ANSWER TO
YOUR YOUR ANSWER IS A KNOW. THAT
YOU'RE NOT WILLING TO SEPARATE
IT OUT WE CAN DO JUST HIGH SPEED
RAIL. AND WE CAN'T DO ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS. THE
ANSWER IS THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PRIORITY IS TO USE THIS ENTIRE
PLOT OF FUNDING. TO COME UP WITH
A PLAN THAT INCLUDES HIGH SPEED
RAIL. THANK YOU THE CLIP THE
FUNDING OF THE HIGH SPEED RAIL.
MISTER BENNETT IT'S JUST VERY
QUICKLY YOU JUST STATED THAT HE
DID TO. YOU BELIEVE THAT THERE'S
ENOUGH MONEY IT WITH THE ONE A
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO COMPLETE THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT IS AT.
THE OUR SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION IS CONFIDENT
THAT- THERE WON'T BE MORE MONEY
NEEDED TO COMPLETE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT BECAUSE THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT WHAT I'M HEARING
WITH ALL OF THE UNCERTAINTIES
OUT THERE. WE BELIEVE THAT AND
AS IT AS IT HAS BEEN- PRESENTED
FROM HIGH SPEED RAIL AS A
WORKING COMPLETION OF THE OF THE
ONE HUNDRED AND NINETEEN MILE
SEGMENT ALONG WITH- ALONG WITH
THE PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT OF
THE- ADDITIONAL BOOK IT OR NOT
BOOKING SEGMENT THE ADDITIONAL-
BAKERSFIELD AND MERCED
EXTENSIONS WITH THE AVAILABLE
FUNDING. THAT WE PROTECT HAVE
AVAILABLE. THREE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTY ONE TRACK OR TWO TRACKS.
THIRTY ONE TRACK WITHOUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO EXPAND
THAT THE TEACHER THANK YOU.
SERVO BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO ISSUE
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE-
PACKAGING HAVE- ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ABOUT THAT. I'M I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
OVERALL-PACKAGE THAT'S BEEN
PRESENTED TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
MY VIEW IS AND ALWAYS HAS BEEN
KIND OF AN INVITATION IN THE
GROCERY EIGHT. AND UP TO THIS
POINT THE NEGOTIATIONS HAVE NOT
GONE WELL- BUT BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS HAPPEN AND THERE'S A LOT
OF LAUGHTER IN THE ROOM BECAUSE
I GUESS THAT'S PUTTING IT
MILDLY- BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING
FROM TODAY'S HEARING IS THAT I'M
HEARING A LOT OF AREAS OF
AGREEMENT ON GOALS ON WHAT WE
SHOULD BE TRYING TO IT. CHIEF
WITH THE HIGH SPEED RAIL-
PROJECT- I SEE NO REASON WHY WE
SHOULD NOT PUT OUR SHOULDERS
INTO THE NEGOTIATIONS AND- TRY
TO ACHIEVE AN AGREEMENT THAT
NEEDS AS BEST AS POSSIBLE ALL
THE GOALS THAT WE COLLECTIVELY
HAVE AS THE LEGISLATURE MANY OF
THE GOALS THAT WE HAVE- AS A
LEGISLATURE. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION CALLS IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT THERE'S A- ALL- LIKE I
SAID A LOT OF AREAS OF AGREEMENT
WE COULD BUILD ON THOSE- THE
FUNDING SOURCE ISSUE IS A THORNY
ONE AND ONE THAT- WILL CONTINUE
TO BEDEVIL THIS PROJECT BECAUSE
IT IS- A LARGE INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS. OF I'M TAKEN BACK TO-
OF THE BIG DIG PROJECT- IN
BOSTON WHICH IS MANY MANY
DECADES OR MANY DECADES OLD- AT
THIS POINT. BUT IT WAS ALSO A
VERY CONTROVERSIAL VERY BIG-
VERY DIFFICULT AND COMPLEX AND
UNDER FUNDED PROJECT TO CONTINUE
TO HAVE. PRICE ESCALATIONS I
DOUBT THAT THERE IS ANYONE. IN
THE STATE OF MASSACHUSETTS ARE
CERTAINLY IN THE CITY OF BOSTON
WHO TODAY WOULD SAY- IT WASN'T
WORTH IT- BECAUSE IT PROVIDED
CRITICAL. CRITICALLY NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THAT CITY AND REGION- ALSO I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE- CONTINUE TO TRY AND- A
REACHING AGREEMENT- WITH- OF THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE. AND WITHOUT-
WILL MOVE ON TO ISSUE NUMBER TWO
WILL BE HOLDING OPEN IF YOU WANT
A AND ISSUE TO TODAY BUT- ISSUE
TWO IS OUR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE
PRESENTATION- AND TO KICK IT OFF
WE HAVE- CARLOS QUANT THE DEPUTY
SECRETARY. FOR BUDGET AND
ADMINISTRATION WITH CALLOUSED
YET. YEAH. TEN MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CARLOS ONCE AND DEPUTY SECRETARY
BUDGET AND THE MINISTRATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY TODAY ONLY
PRESENTING OUR BUDGET PROPOSALS
INCLUDING INCLUDED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WITH MAJOR NAY
I HAVE UNDER SECRETARY WAS A
KIND OF SENIOR ADVISOR JOBS
YOU'RE NOT SEEING AND DEPUTY
SECRETARY FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
POLICY DARWIN MESABI HELP ANSWER
QUESTIONS I'LL START OF
EVERYBODY AN OVERVIEW OF THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSAL SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
IN NEW TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MAINTENANCE
OF THE EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE
WE ARE PROPOSING OVER NINE
BILLION DOLLARS IN STATE
INVESTMENT STATE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM TO PATEL HELLO AN
EQUITABLE RECOVERY AND POSITION
THE STATE TO PURSUE SIGNIFICANT
FEDERAL FUNDING THESE
INVESTMENTS WILL CREATE QUALITY
JOBS ACCELERATE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS SUPPORT CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS AND
PROVIDE BETTER CONNECTIVITY.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES POINT ONE
BILLION IN THE IN THE- SYSTEM. I
WILL PROVIDE A BRIEF. THE
COMPONENT. THE FIRST INVESTMENTS
THREE POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
FUND. FOR HIGH PRIORITY TRANSIT
AND RAIL INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE. DISMANTLED LOCAL
TRANSIT AND INTERCITY RAIL
CAPITAL PROGRAM AND WILL PROVIDE
RAIL AND TRANSIT CONNECTIVITY
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL OR
REGIONAL SERVICES. PROVIDE
MOBILITY OPTIONS AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. THE
NEXT INVESTMENT I SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION GENERAL FUND
TO ADVANCE ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS THAT EXPAND WALKING AND
BIKING NETWORKS. INCREASED THE
STADIUM MOBILITY OF PEDESTRIANS
AND BICYCLISTS ADDRESS EQUITY
THROUGH PROJECTS TO RECONNECT
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HARMED TRANSPORTATION SECTIONS
OF THE PAST AND PRIORITIZE
MOVEMENT OF CARS OVER PEOPLE.
THE NEXT INVESTMENT IS FIVE
SUPPORT CRITICAL SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS ARE GREAT
CROSSINGS. THIS IS A SITUATION
WHERE REAL ROADS CROSSING THE
HIGHWAY OR STREET AND SECOND
LEVEL. THERE ARE MANY
OPPORTUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO ADDRESS THE MOST
DANGEROUS OF THESE CROSSINGS.
THIS CAN BE DONE BY SEPARATING
THE ROAD AND RAIL REVENUE TWO
SEPARATE LEVELS OR BY OTHERWISE
INCLUDING THE GRADE CROSSINGS TO
ADD MORE PROTECTION. THIS
INVESTMENT WILL HELP TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE MORE CRITICAL GRADE
CROSSINGS ACROSS THE STATE. THE
NEXT INVESTMENTS FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PROJECTS. SUPPORT
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. AND REDUCE
RISKS TO INFRASTRUCTURE FROM
EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS. THE
FINAL COMPONENT THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE IS A FOUR POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
PROPOSITION ONE A BOND FUNDS TO
COMPLETE THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
CONSTRUCTION IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. ADVANCE WORK FOR SERVICE
BETWEEN MERCED AND BAKERSFIELD
AND ADVANCE PLANNING A PROJECT
DESIGNED THE ENTIRE PROJECT.
THIS PROPOSAL EMBRACES AND BUILD
UPON THE VISION OF THE CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH ALIGNED OUR
TRANSPORTATION SPENDING WITH
CLIMATE PUBLIC HEALTH. SAFETY
AND EQUITY GOALS. THAT CONCLUDES
MY BRIEF SUMMARY THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL MY COLLEAGUES AND CAL
STATUS REPRESENTATIVES IN HIGH
SPEED RAIL TRANSIT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ARE AVAILABLE TO HELP
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL
ASK FOR A REPORT FROM THE- L. A-
NOW. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRANK
JIMENEZ WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- IN OUR
ANALYSIS OF THE GOVERNOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PACKAGE- WE HAVE FOR
RECOMMENDATIONS. I'M THE FIRST
BEING IN ORDER TO MAXIMIZE
AVAILABLE FUNDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION WE RECOMMEND THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED PACKAGE. IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE ANTICIPATED
FEDERAL FUNDING FROM MY AJ.
ENSURE THAT STATE FUNDS ARE USED
TO TEACH ECKLEY- THIS COULD
INCLUDE SUPPORTING LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES WHERE FEDERAL FUNDS.
ARE NOT A SIGNIFICANT ARE ABSENT
AS WELL AS HELPING THE STATE BE
COMPETITIVE AND RECEIVING
DISCRETIONARY PROGRAM. NOW WE
ALSO RECOMMENDED LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERED YOUR GRAPHIC EQUITY
AND TRANSIT RAIL FUNDING. TO THE
EXTENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
PRIORITIZES THAT SOME LEVEL OF
BASED FUNDING SHOULD BE PROVIDED
TO ALL REGIONS OF THE STATE. I'M
CURRENTLY PROPOSED- THE TRANSIT
EVERY OPENING WOULD GO THROUGH
THE TRC P. PROGRAM. WHICH IS A
COMPETITIVE PROGRAM- WE FIND AT
A COMPETITIVE PROCESS COULD
ENSURE THAT THE HIGHEST QUALITY
PROJECTS ARE FUNDED BUT IT CAN
ALSO RESULT IN FUNDING
ALLOCATIONS THAT ARE NOT.
DISTRIBUTED EQUITABLY EQUITABLY
ACROSS ALL REGIONS OF THE STATE-
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER
PROVIDING SOME FUNDING FOR
TRANSIT RAIL PROJECTS TO
EXISTING- FORMULA BASED
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS ARE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL DEDICATED
FUNDS FOR DIFFERENT REGIONS-
SIMILAR TO THE FUNDS DEDICATED
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
REGION- AND A RECOMMENDATION
AREN'T WE'RE NOT INDICATING THAT
THIS SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AS-
COMPLETELY- COMPETITIVE PURSES
FORMULA DRIVEN. JUST ENSURING
THAT SOME BASE LEVEL OF FUNDING
IS DISTRIBUTED. EQUITABLY ACROSS
ALL REGIONS- WE ALSO RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REQUIRE
VALUATIONS OF THE NEW PER
PROPOSED PROGRAMS TO ENSURE THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PROVIDES.
INFORMATION REGARDING
PROGRAMMATIC OUTCOMES TO INFORM
FUTURE POLICY AN FUNDING
DECISIONS- THIS IS- PARTICULAR
TO THEM I WASTE THE BOULEVARD
PILOT PROGRAM. AND THE SEVERAL
CRIME ADAPTATION PROGRAMS.
CURRENTLY THE PROPOSED TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO IMPLEMENT THESE
PROGRAMS HAS LIMITED.
REQUIREMENTS FOR PROGRAM
EVALUATIONS- WE FIND THAT HAVE
NEEDS OF. WHAT BETTER INFORMED
LEAD UNDER THAT AND CHALLENGES
OF THE PROGRAM'S AN INTERN
GUIDE. WHETHER AND AT WHAT LEVEL
TO CONTINUE FUNDING FOR THESE
PROGRAMS IF THE LEGISLATURE WISH
TO DO SO IN THE FUTURE- AND IT
WOULD ALSO HELP THE LEGISLATURE
DETERMINE IF ANY MODIFICATIONS
WERE NEEDED FOR THESE PROGRAMS-
AND THEN FINALLY RECOMMENDED THE
LEGISLATURE BE MINDFUL OF THE
STATE APPROPRIATION. LIMITS AND
ASSESSING THE PACKAGE- AS ANY
RIO REALLOCATION OF THIS FUNDING
WILL NEED TO BE FOR SOME REALLY-
SAT RELATED PURPOSES- THAT ENDS
OUR COMMENTS AND HAVE TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS. THERE THANK YOU-
NEXT WE HAVE FOR MISTER MOORE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HI JAMES MORE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I DON'T
HAVE ANYTHING TO ADD AT THIS
POINT- OTHER THAN HAVING TO TAKE
ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
- I THANK YOU THIS- MARKED.
QUESTION IS PROBABLY BEST
ADDRESSED TO MR QUANT- I'VE BEEN
HEARING. GOD FROM MY
CONSTITUENTS ORGANIZATIONS- IN
AND AROUND MY DISTRICT THAT THE
L. A. REGION. HAS NOT BEEN
GETTING ITS FAIR SHARE OF
FUNDING AND- I'M WONDERING IF
YOU COULD COMMENT ON THAT. AND
IF YOU AGREE HOW DO WE- GET TO A
MORE EQUITABLE FUNDING SOLUTION
FOR. UP FOR THE FOR THE REGION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A
PROPORTIONAL DEFERRED CHIU
UNDERSECRETARY WAS GONNA. THANK
YOU BYE MISTER CHAIR- HAPPY TO
ADDRESS YOUR QUESTION ON IT THE
THREE POINT TWO FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TOTAL- TRANSIT
FUNDING I TRANSIT RAIL FUNDING
PROPOSED IN THIS PACKAGE- WE
WOULD BE LOOKING TO DEVELOP
GUIDELINES AND- PROVIDE A CALL
FOR PROJECTS. I TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS A GEOGRAPHIC EQUITY- IN
THE PRIORITY TRANSIT AND RAIL
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ALL RIGHT- THANK YOU- IT
PROBABLY WOULD BE- HELPFUL THAT
WAS- WRITTEN INTO THE ACTUAL
BUDGET- DOCUMENTS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD- BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
WILLINGNESS TO- MAKE CERTAIN
THAT THEIR- IS EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF THE FUNDING. I
THINK OF MR MULLIN HAS SUCKED.
MISTER I THINK IT WAS SHARED
YEAH JUST A OF QUESTIONS FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION- AS YOU'RE AWARE
THAT CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION%
PROJECT REF REFERENCE A COUPLE
TIMES ALREADY THIS MORNING- IS
IN MY DISTRICT IS NEARING
COMPLETION NEEDS ADDITIONAL
STATE OF FEDERAL FUNDING. SEEMS
TO BE A PRETTY EXTRAORDINARY
FEDERAL FUNDING OPPORTUNITY BUT-
WITH THE WITH THE FUNDING
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR THE T. I. R. C. P. BE
ELIGIBLE TO COMPLETE THAT
CALTRAIN PROJECT AND OTHERS
AROUND THE STATE THAT MAY BE IN
SIMILAR. SITUATIONS IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS THAT AND THEN- MIGHT YOU
BE OPEN TO UP BUDGET LANGUAGE
THAT WOULD ENSURE THE
ELIGIBILITY OF THESE PROJECTS.
LAKE WHAT IS PROPOSED IN THE OUT
RECENT BAY AREA LETTER THERE'S
REACH A LETTER SIGNED BY-
NUMEROUS- TRANSPORTATION
PARTNERS IN THE REGION SO IF YOU
COULD JUST SPEAK TO THAT JUST
THE LEVEL OF FUNDING. AND THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR A PROJECT LIKE
THE CALTRAIN ELECTRIFICATION
PROJECT. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ALYSSA CONNER FROM TULSA
AGAIN I. YES WE'VE BEEN TALKING
A LOT WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT THE NEEDS- FOR THESE
TRANSIT AND RAIL PROJECTS- WE
BASE OUR PROPOSAL ON THE TRC
KEY. PROGRAM BIG BECAUSE THESE
ARE GENERAL FUND ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION REQUEST WILL BE
LOOKING TO MODIFY OUR TYPICAL
GUIDELINES- TO MAKE THEM A
LITTLE BIT MORE FLEXIBLE- TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE NEEDS THAT-
YOU'VE MENTIONED. I FROM OUR
TRANSIT AND RAIL SYSTEMS- SO
THAT'S SOMETHING TO BE HAPPY TO
WORK. TOGETHER ON AND TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING ALL
OF THOSE NEEDS. OKAY AT THE END
OF THE F. BUDGET BLUE CALL FOR A
TEN BILLION FOR TRANSIT RAIL AND
I KNOW WHAT. OUR TRANSPORTATION
CHAIR CAN CAN SPEAK TO THAT BUT
I HAD A QUICK QUESTION ON GRADE
SEPARATION FUNDING. OF THE
ADMINISTRATION IS PROPOSING FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION ONE TIME FUNDING
STATEWIDE. WHICH FRANKLY IS
MERELY A DANCE AND WHAT IS IT
TEN BILLION DOLLAR. FIGURE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE STATE WIDE NEEDS
SO- CAN YOU JUST SPEAK TO JUST
THAT LEVEL OF FUNDING ON GREAT
STEPS AND WHAT KIND OF A-
PRIORITY THE ADMINISTRATION IS
GIVING TO THAT ISSUE. YES THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER I AND IT DID
SO CROSSINGS ARE EASY ERY- AND
EXPENSIVE. AND COMPLEX- CENTER
PROJECT ON BUT ALSO VERY
NECESSARY. FOR TO IMPROVE SAFETY
OF THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR PROPOSAL WOULD TARGET- I
DID SOME OF THE- MOST. DANGEROUS
INTERSECTIONS- AND TRY TO BRING
AND SOME KEY PRIORITY PROJECTS-
DATED THEIR ENSURE CONNECTIVITY
AND SAFETY- AND BRING THOSE TO
THE FOREFRONT. OF THE PACKAGE SO
IT'S- TRYING TO BALANCE ALL OF
THE NEEDS AND WITH YOU KNOW SOME
CONSTRAINED RESOURCES- AND THAT
SAID THE BASIS OF THE. FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL
. OKAY FIGURE OUT BACK TO THE G.
JUST A PUTTING A NOTE OF HOW-
LIKE. IS FOR THE ACTIVE- IN THE
BAY AREA REGION- IT TRULY IS AN
ECONOMIC ENGINE FOR ACTIVITY
WHICH IS FUEL HELPING FUEL THE
STATE BUDGET SURPLUS WE HAVE SO
WITH THAT NOBLE PERFECT. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER MULLIN-
BEFORE YOU TURN YOUR MY COUGH WE
NEGLECTED TO CALL YOUR NAME-
WHEN WE DID TO ADD ONS FOR THE-
ABOUT ONLY CALENDAR SO. LISTEN
CAREFULLY OUR NAMES COMING UP
FALLEN. THANK YOU. A MINUTE MS
AND FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE
WAITING TO GET PUBLIC WILL BE
GETTING TO THAT VERY SHORTLY- WE
WILL BE LIMITED TO ONE MINUTE
TO- PURSE BAKER SO PLEASE
PREPARE COMMENTS ACCORDINGLY MS
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU I WILL TRY TO
BE BRIEF FIRST ALL ECHO IT
MISTER MULLIN SAID ABOUT THE
IMPORTANCE OF ELECTRIFICATION
AND FOR CALTRAIN- REALLY CRUCIAL
PROJECT AND I WANT TO FIRST OF
ALL COMMEND GOVERNOR NEWSOM AND
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR ARE VERY
PROGRESSIVE AND VERY. A
VISIONARY APPROACH TOWARDS A
TRANSIT AND INVESTMENT IN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION I WE HAVEN'T SEEN
THAT KIND OF VISION BEFORE OF I
THINK FROM THE GOVERNOR AND IT'S
REALLY GREAT TO SEE AN CERTAINLY
COMPLIMENTARY OF ALL OF OUR
GOALS WITH CLIMATE AND EQUITY
AND MOBILITY AND EVERYTHING ELSE
WE'RE TRYING TO DO I WILL
CONTINUE TO PLUG FOR EVEN MORE
MONEY TO GO INTO TRANSIT- YOUR
PARTICULARLY IN OUR POPULATION
CENTERS THERE'S A GREAT HUNGER
OUT THERE TO IMPROVE EXISTING
TRANSIT AND TO EXPAND ON IT. AND
GIVEN THE FEDERAL APPETITE FOR
THOSE INVESTMENTS I THINK THAT'S
ALSO A GREAT PLACE FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PARTNER WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ON THOSE
GOALS AND IT CLICKED CHECKS
EVERY BUTTON THE JOB BUTTON THE
EMPLOYMENT BUTTONED- AND IS A TO
BE CHECK BOX THE CLIMATE
MOBILITY EQUITY IT'S ALL OF
THOSE THINGS WRAPPED UP INTO ONE
BUT I ACTUALLY MY QUESTIONS ARE
ACTUALLY ABOUT THE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PART OF THIS
WHICH IS ALSO EXTREMELY
EXCITING- WE KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD
THIS REALLY UNFORTUNATE UBTECH
IN FATALITIES. FOR PEDESTRIANS
AND CYCLISTS LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS AND IT JUST CONTINUES
TO TRACK ABOARD IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S A MAJOR CONCERN I TO ME
TO OUR CONSTITUENTS WE SEE IT
BEING TALKED ABOUT FINALLY
NATIONALLY THIS IS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY IT'S NOT UNIQUE TO
CALIFORNIA. AND ALONG WITH THAT
INVESTMENT IN ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION WE ALSO- CLEARLY
DID NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
INVESTMENTS ALSO INCREASED
SAFETY FOR THOSE USERS FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE WALKING AND
PEOPLE THAT ARE CYCLING AND I
ALSO AND I'M CONCERNED THAT SOME
OF OUR INVESTMENTS DON'T. REALLY
DO THAT THAT ADDING- ADDING THE
- WITHOUT PRIOR. THIS FOR THOSE
USER- LEADS TO A DANGEROUS
SITUATION AND DISCOURAGES PEOPLE
FROM FULLY UTILIZING THOSE
SYSTEMS AND I HEAR THAT A LOT
FROM. PEOPLE LIKE ME A MIDDLE.
THIS ALMOST MIDDLE AGED WOMEN
WHO WANT TO BE ABLE TO- TO BIKE
AROUND BUT OUR MAYBE NERVOUS TO
DO SO BECAUSE THEY WANT TO FULLY
PROTECTED BIKE LANE THEY WANT TO
KNOW THAT THEY'RE SAFE AND I. I
THINK THAT CONNECTING THE
SAFETY- WITH ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AYE I GUESS MY
QUESTION IS HOW. IN FOR HOW
INFORMATION ABOUT THE BIKE
SAFETY INVESTIGATIONS THAT
CALTRANS HAS BEEN DOING GET
COMMUNICATED HOW THOSE GET
ABOUT WHAT PROJECTS GET FUNDED
AND HOW. THEY ARE FUNDED. AND I
WANT TO KNOW WHAT KIND OF
CHANGES YOU THINK WE NEED TO
MAKE TO OUR FINDINGS- PROGRAMS
AND WHAT WE CAN DO IN THIS
PACKAGE TO ENSURE THAT NOT ONLY
ARE WE INVESTING IN. AFTER
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT THAT WE'RE CENTERING A
SAFETY AS WELL. THANK YOU. IMAGE
FOR HER ALSO ANNOUNCED IT PART
OF THAT IS ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR BIKE NETWORKS AND
PEDESTRIAN AFTER COMPREHENSIVE
THAT THEY'RE NOT LITTLE PIECES
HERE AND THERE AND THAT THEY
FOCUS ON ON REDUCING VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED THAT THE
RECREATIONAL CYCLING IS
IMPORTANT BUT IF WE REALLY WANT
TO GET PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR CARS
WE ALSO HAVE TO MAKE INVESTMENTS
IN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION THAT'S
REALLY AIMED AT COMMUTERS AND
PEOPLE MOVING AROUND THEIR
COMMUNITY TO GET TO THE
ESSENTIALS OF LIFE SO WITH THAT
I'LL STOP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR THOSE CALM- WITH QUESTION
AFTER. THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
THAT QUESTIONS AT ARMS ARE BIG
AND- DEPUTY- MARNA BALLS HERE
TELL AND I WOULD ANSWER- THIS
QUESTIONS ARE TIME OF OUR
TRANSPORTATION ABOUT. THAT WE'VE
BEEN I THE PACKAGE- WE AGREE WE
TAKE. A SIMILAR OF MY SURE THAT
WE'RE BOTH BUILDING OUT THE
TRANSFER. ADDRESS NETWORK ALSO
SURE HUGE AND WHICH IS WHY. THE
PACKAGE BUT INCLUDE. THE
DEPARTMENT DOLLARS. BACK TO
TRANSPORTATION FOR. WHICH IS
REALLY- REALLY. BY AND- REDUCE
VEHICLE MILES FOR- LOOK AT IT-
TELLING KEY NETWORK GAPS IN
AFTER BIRTH. NETWORK AMONGST
GOAL AND THEN THE- HOW IT
IMPROVE PROGRAM- ALSO KNOWN AS
THE AGE THAT PROGRAM THERE'S- A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS IN- FOR
A BICYCLE PEDESTRIAN SAFETY
ASIDE- WHICH- WOULDN'T EXACTLY
GO. TO RESEARCH PROJECTS THAT
THAT THEY WERE MENTIONED- AND
LISTEN TO THAT- THANKS- BASED ON
KIND OF HISTORICAL SEARCH DATA
THAT WE HAVE SO WE THINK THE
PACKAGE- ADDRESSES AS ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS AND- AND
THIS HAS TAKEN- THOSE NEEDS INTO
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISTER
SMITH CLICK ON IT TO DO REAL
QUICK WHAT IS A LIST SPECIFIC
PROJECT LISTED FOR THE ONE AND A
HALF BILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CALIPHS OTHER
CALIFORNIA. INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
THE TRANSIT. IS THERE A SPECIFIC
LIST AND CAN WE GET A COPY OF
THAT. HI A LITTLE OF THE
CONFERENCE HEALTH- AND THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION- THERE IS NOT
A SPECIFIC LIST IN THE PROPOSAL
AT THIS TIME A WE PROPOSED TO
DEVELOP GUIDELINES- FOR AWARDS
OF PROJECTS WE WOULD DO A CALL
FOR PROJECTS- AND- EVALUATE
THOSE ACCORDING TO YOU- EIGHT A
SET OF CRITERIA AND THEN THAT
ARE TYPICALLY UNDER THAT TRANSIT
AND INTERCITY RAIL. CAPITAL
PROGRAM- IN THOSE PROJECTS WOULD
BE AWARDED. BASED ON THAT
PROCESS. IT JUST TWO QUICK COM.
I KNOW WE'RE ALL TALKING ABOUT A
LOT ABOUT ELECTRICITY LECTER SHE
ELECTRIFICATION OF THE STATE I
THINK WE NEED TO USE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES ON THINKING OF
HYDROGEN WHICH IS A CLEAN
ALTERNATIVE TO POSSIBLY. IF WE
GET SOME FUNDING- FOR THOSE TO
GIVE EVERYBODY A DIFFERENT.
PERSPECTIVE ON IT. BUT I'M AGREE
WITH MY COLLEAGUE- FRIEDMAN.
BICYCLE SAFETY I WAS PART OF
VICTOR VALLEY BICYCLE TOUR. TO
CARE FOR FIVE YEARS. ALL THE
FUNDS THAT WE RAISE DID PUBLIC
SAFETY THE THREE FOOT SIGN LAWS.
A LINE DOWN THE ROAD DOES NOT
PROTECT YOU LIKE THE- VILLAGE
SAFE IN A CROSSWALK JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S A LINE THERE WE NEED
MORE FUNDING FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
BECAUSE WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE
OUT OF THE CARS ON THE ROAD. WE
CAN MAKE SURE THEY'RE SAFE.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME CHAIR.
YOU'RE WELCOME WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO MISTER BENNETT. VERY QUICK
IF I COULD RAISE MY VOICE IN
SUPPORT OF BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND SENATE
MEMBERS MISS COMMENTS- ABOUT
SAFETY AND IF I COULD TURN THIS
INTO JUST. ABOVE THE COMMON AND
A QUICK QUESTION AND THAT IS CAN
WE PUT INTO OUR GRANTS-
APPLICATIONS- EXTRA POINTS FOR
THE SAFETY SIDE OF IT BECAUSE A
SMALL INVESTMENT IN IN IT AND A
MODIFICATION THAT IMPROVE
IMPROVE THE SAFETY CAN
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE HOW MUCH
PEOPLE ARE WILLING TO USE THAT I
GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE I MEAN IN
SACRAMENTO IN SOME PLACES HERE.
WE HAVE THE BY CLEAN INSIDE OF
THE PARK CARS IT WHICH CREATES
SO MUCH MORE SAFETY AND THE
SOLUTION IS GREATER FEELING OF
THAT SO- IS IT POSSIBLE TO
INCLUDE SAFETY AS A WITH GOD
CREATE MORE POINTS AND MORE
FOCUS ON THAT AND OUR GRANT
PROGRAM. VERY QUICKLY. THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION- THE THAT CAN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM-
CURRENTLY DOES. A GOOD SAFETY OF
THE CRITERIA WE CAN CERTAINLY-
OR WORK WITH THE TALIBAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION TO SEE
HOW PROGRESSIVE CONSIDERED
WITHIN WITHIN THE PROGRAM- AND
IT IS CERTAINLY THE TOP PRIORITY
AND THE- IN THE HIGHWAY SAFETY
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM- WHICH WE'VE
ALSO ASKED FOR BEST INTEREST IN
THE- MONEY FOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GREAT AND- I WOULD- ADD MY
VOICE TO- A SUPPORT FOR- THAT-
KIND OF APPROACH. THAT TAKES US
TO PUBLIC COMMENT- WE ARE TAKING
PUBLIC COMMENT ON ISSUES- ONE
AND TWO ONLY AND- YOU'LL PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE- WE'LL BEGIN WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT- HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. PLEASE VISIT. THANK YOU
FOR YOU HAVE TRANSPORTATION
CALIFORNIA BEFORE YOU HAVE
LAYERS OF. IN THIS PARTICULAR-
THE LETTERS THE STATE BUDGET
REQUIRE OF NINE ONE DOLLARS.
FOR- FOUR K. PROGRAMS THAT WE
SHOULD- I AM STAND HERE AND GO
THROUGH ALL THE THAT THEY NEED
TO BEEN. FOR THE CODED IMPACT ON
THE STATE HIGHWAY GAS TAX HAS
BEEN OVER BILLION SIX DOLLARS
ADMITTED IT PILES UP FROM THERE
HI THIS IS A ONCE IN A LIFETIME
OPPORTUNITY AND WE WOULD CLOSE
BY STRESSING THAT WE WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH YOU IF WE CAN OR
JUST- ENCOURAGE YOU TO.
COLLABORATE TOGETHER WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION TO COME UP WITH A
PACKAGE- THAT YOU CAN ALL
SUPPORT ENDORSE APPRECIATE THAT
COMMENT OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT AND I HOPE I STAY WITHIN
ONE MINUTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. HI OPERATOR- GET
YOURSELF READY- WE'RE GONNA
START A MOMENT I'M GONNA READ
THE PHONE NUMBER OFF AGAIN- FOR
PUBLIC GOT A COMMENT. YOU CAN
CALL IN 287-769-2895 SEVEN. AND
USE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE ONE TWO SEVEN OPERATOR
YOU THERE. I'M DEFINITELY HERE-
WE HAVE. ABOUT ELEVEN BILLION UP
. TO REPLICATE ITSELF START WITH
MIND. SEVEN NINE FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FIFTY OKAY
WE'LL MOVE ON THE LINE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS MICHAEL
PIMENTEL EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA TRANSIT
ASSOCIATION I FIRST WANT TO
THANK THE MUSEUM ADMINISTRATION
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR CONTINUED.
SUPPORT FOR TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WE APPRECIATE THE FUNDING
THAT IS CURRENTLY ON THE TABLE
FOR TRAINS AND RAIL BUT WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THE PROPOSED
FUNDING LEVEL SHOULD BE THE FOR
STATE INVESTMENT NOT THAT
DEALING. I INTO THAT AND ARE
BUDGET LETTER CALLS FOR
ADDITIONAL AND MORE FLEXIBLE
FUNDING FOR TRAINING A REAL
CAPITAL PROJECTS AN INCREASE
FUNDING FOR ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
INCREASE FUNDING COULD FOR
EXAMPLE ALLOW NEW CAPITAL FUNDS
TO BE OUTSTANDING BUT NEEDS FOR
PROJECTS THAT PREVIOUSLY
RECEIVED STATE FUNDING AT THE
MORE TO WHAT YOU HEARD ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MALL AND REQUESTS. OUR
BUDGET LETTER ALSO CALLS FOR THE
PROPOSED CLIMATE ADAPTATION
FUNDING TO BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
TRAIN THE NEURAL AGENCIES
RECOGNIZING THAT TRANSIT
PROJECTS ARE NOT IMMUNE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE IN VERY
SIGNIFICANTLY WE ARE REQUESTING
FUNDING FOR TRANSIT OPERATION TO
KEEP TRANSIT RUNNING ONE FEDERAL
EMERGENCY FUNDING THIS WE
DEPLETED. WE SUBMITTED A LETTER
IT GOES INTO MUCH MORE DETAIL ON
THESE ITEMS THE MANY MORE I
THANK. YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. WONDERLAND SO. GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MATT ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
CALTRAIN AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW
CALTRAIN WILL SOON BEGIN
OPERATING THE STATE'S FIRST
ELECTRIFIED EVERY COMMUTER RAIL
LINE. SPENDING FIFTY ONE MILES
WE CAN'T JUST GO WITH SAN JOSE
CALTRAIN SUPPORT SIGNIFICANTLY
INVESTING IN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THE STATE'S
PROJECTED BUDGET SURPLUS
CONSISTENT WITH THE FEBRUARY
SIXTEENTH LETTER SUBMITTED BY
THE BAY AREA TRANSPORTATION
AGENCIES. CALTRAIN ALSO ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE FUNDING TO
FACILITATE THE COMPLETION OF THE
ELECTRIFICATION PROJECT WE
APPRECIATE MISTER MILLER'S
COMMENTS EARLIER IN COMMITTEE
BUT AS WELL AS YOUR FRIEDMAN AND
THEN FINALLY CALTRAIN DOES IN
FACT SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA HIGH
SPEED RAIL PROJECT AND THE USE
OF THOSE BOND FUNDS TO FINISH
THE PROJECT IN ADVANCE OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. ACTUALLY
CONNECTING TO A LARGER STAY REAL
NETWORK INCLUDING OUR SYSTEM. IN
THE BAY AREA THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MOVE
ON THE LINE. SORRY WE MOVE ON TO
LINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
I'M SORRY NINE FIFTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BOB GOOD MORNING TO
SEE WHAT CAN BE AFTER THE
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA TRANSIT
DISTRICT THE ONLY KIND OF
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION AND
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE HIGHWAY
AND TRANSPORTATION DISTRICT.
YEAH ONE OF THESE WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THAT OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE REQUEST WAS MADE BY THE
VERY TRANSPORTATION ENTITIES. TO
ALL RIGHT LEAST TEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
FOR TRANSPORTATION TRANSIT
PROJECTS. IN PARTICULAR BY GOING
FOR PUBLIC TRANSIT OPERATOR
STATEWIDE HOW THE FUND SHOULD BE
GOING OUT BY A COMBINATION OF
SPEAKER THE SYSTEM'S FORMULA.
AND- MONEY THAT DEDICATED TO THE
TWENTY NURSING ROCK OUT OF THE
PROGRAM. YOU'RE THE NEED FOR
OPERATING FANTASY DEER YEAH SHE
TRANSIT AND OTHER OPERATORS ARE
FACING UP THIS CLIFF. WE HAVE
SEVERAL FUNDED ARE. USED UP IF
YOU ARE RIDERSHIPA LACK AND
COSTLY REASONS. HM TRANSIT THE
HUNDRED ONE NINE DOLLARS- IN THE
NEXT FEW YEARS ADDITIONAL
OPERATING FUNDS TO HELP US
WANTED THIS REBOUND AS WE
TRANSITION BACK TO WHATEVER THE
NEW NORMAL IS- IN ADDITION WERE
ALSO FACING YOUR CAPITAL COSTS
WITHOUT ONLY FOR YOUR- YOU TO.
MISSION VEHICLES BUT ALSO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED IN OUR
CLASS SO THESE CHI- MAINTAIN AND
THE COMMON THAT REJECT
TECHNOLOGY. AS WELL AS UP YOUR
FACILITY RADIO QUORUM. STRIKE
APART THAT MEASURE FOUR POINT
AND ONE THING THAT BEEN A
MENTION WHAT MARKETING YOUR DID
YOUR TIME EXPIRED IF YOU COULD
READ UP VERY QUICKLY PLEASE
RIGHT. IN THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. INCRIMINATE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MONEY TO CONVERT JERRY
BROWN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION TO CONDUCT AN ISSUE
TO OUR THINKING IS WRONG WITH
THE COURT THE INLAND EMPIRE
CAUCUSES REQUEST FOR TWO POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN BUDGET
FUNDING TO DELIVER
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS THAT
PROVIDE IMMEDIATE RELIEF CAR
REGION'S RESIDENTS. AT THE END
OF THE STATE- GROWING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ARE BY
CONTINUED POPULATION GROWTH AND
WORSENING SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS.
IN RECENT LIKE EMPIRE CONTINUE
TO EXPERIENCE POPPING THAT LAW
ANGELES NAH COUNTY REVERSE
INTEGRITY COUNT WHERE 40% OF THE
NAY GOOD TRAVEL COULD BE A FROM
DECADES OF UNDER AND ARE ACUTE
SO WHEN WE LOOK THAT YOU SUPPORT
THE AND WHEN EMPIRE. SUCH A
REQUEST IN A PARADOX THE BETTER
RECALL AND THAT WE SOME A LETTER
ALONG WITH A COPY OF THAT LETTER
- LET'S OF ASSISTANCE PROJECT
EXPECT. THANK YOU. THANKS THREE
BECAUSE- CASH GOOD MORNING MR
AND ANOTHER PERSON OKAY FRERICHS
ON BEHALF OF COULD I'M WE
SUPPORT ADMINISTRATION OVERALL
THEIR TRADE FOR PRIOR SO AND ONE
TO CALL OUT SUPPORT FOR THE
FIGHTER MILLION DOLLAR PROPOSED
FOR TRANCE PER. AS WELL AS A
MILLER DOLLARS THE CLIMATE
PROGRAMS. EIGHT I THINK FOR ANY
CONSERVANCY ONE AND THAT SO
MULTI BENEFIT RIGHT SUCH AS
WILDLIFE CORRIDOR. OR PROJECTS
THAT IT ISSUES SUCH AS THE OVER
COST FLOODING THANKS MUCH HAVE A
GOOD DAY THANK YOU. FIND FIFTY
SO PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS- IN THE SURGICAL CHECK
ON THE OF SANTA CLARA VALLEY
CHANCE AUTHORITY SPEAKING ON THE
ISSUE PURSUING KNOWLEDGE AND
THAT MENSURATION THE
TRANSPORTATION INCLUDED COULD
BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL ALSO JOIN
OUR PEER AGENCIES AROUND THE
STATE IN CALLING FOR INCREASING
THE AMOUNT OF GENERAL FUND
SURPLUS REDDING IS DEDICATED TO
SUPPORT TRANSPORTATION
PRIORITIES. THE PHYSICALLY WOULD
URGE A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR TRANSIT INVESTMENTS
THROUGH THE TRC PEOPLE FOR THOSE
PROJECTS THAT REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
STATE FUNDING TO SECURE MAINTAIN
SIGNIFICANT FEDERAL INVESTMENT
AND WHAT CALL FOR ONE TIME
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE G. R. T. P.
PROGRAM STRUCTURE TO ALLOW FOR
SACRAMENTO AWARD SUPPORT TO
PROJECT THE SUPPORT WOULD ENSURE
THAT PROJECTS SUCH AS V. T. MARC
THE LOOK ON THE BALLOT. THE
STUDENTS PROJECT IN THE CAR
TRANSFER CHIP COOKIE PROUD COME
THE FUNDING PLAN IN SECURING THE
CRITICAL IN THINK FEDERAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE FOR EIGHT
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR THIS
IS KEITH DONE ON BEHALF OF THIS
CALIFORNIA SPEED LOOK AT THE
COUNT ARM. YOU'RE SPEAKING TO OF
I DON'T WANT BECAUSE AND OUR
TRANSFERRED TO SYSTEM DOES NOT
STOP WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL
SYNDROME. AND ALL THE OTHER READ
NEED THAT WOULD CAN INTO THE
ADDITIONAL ABOUT. IN THE REGION
THAT YOU'VE BEEN HEARING OR TO
MAINTAIN OUR FIRST AND NATION
AND PER. ONE OF GOING TO BE NEW
AS OUR STATE CAN TO GROW HIKES
RAILS PART OF THAT WE HAVE LEFT
HERE SPACE TO TURN IN STATE MORE
CROWD HIGHWAY. WITH YOUR YOU'RE
A THE BEST WAY TO HAVE A CLIMB
ACTION FROM STATE IS THE
BUILDING ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED
RAIL STARTING IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU TO
MAKE SURE THAT HAPPENS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I'M OF
ON THE LINE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JERRY MEMBERS JOSH SHAW
ON BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
LONDON BREED WHO COMMANDS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED NEW
INVESTMENTS IN TRANSPORTATION
PARTICULARLY THE PUBLIC TRANSIT
SPENDING WE ALSO THINK IT'S TIME
TO APPROPRIATE THE REMAINING
PROP ON A BOND FUNDS TO THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY WHICH HAS BEEN A TRUE
PARTNER TO US IN DEVELOPING THE
CALTRAIN REAL CORDER IN THE
SALES FORCE TRANSIT CENTER.
ADDITIONALLY WE NOTE THAT OUR
REGIONAL TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
AGENCY AND OTHER BAY AREA
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES HAVE
IDENTIFIED AND COMMUNICATED TO
ALL OF YOU BILLIONS MORE AN
ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION TRANSIT
CAPITAL PROJECT IN TRANSIT
OPERATIONS NEED AND WE SUPPORT
THEIR REQUEST OF YOU ALONG THOSE
LINES AS WELL. THANKS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU. ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS ON
THE US ARMY DOES ON BEHALF OF
THE TRANSBAY JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY CALLING IN THE FIRST
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY'S DRAFT TWENTY TWENTY
TWO BUSINESS PLAN YOU MAY KNOW
THE TJ OWNS AND OPERATES A
SALESFORCE TRANSIT CENTER SLATED
TO BE THE NORTHERN TERMINUS FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL CAMP CISCO. IN
WHICH SERVES OF A TRANSIT HUB
SERVING MULTIPLE OPERATORS
REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE BENEFITS
AS RELATES TO SOME MORE
IMMEDIATE ACTIONS WE ENCOURAGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO STRONGLY
CONSIDER THE FULL ALLOCATION OF
REMAINING PROP ONE A. FUNDS FOR
HIGH SPEED RAIL AS WELL AS THE
FUNDING AMOUNTS FOR THE ENTIRE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE AS
PROPOSED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
JANUARY BUDGET PROPOSAL. THANK
YOU. AND ONCE AGAIN AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE. AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE.
I'M ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MATT KREMIN TERRIBLY
HAPPY CALIFORNIA ABOUT A
CONFERENCE OF OPERATING
ENGINEERS HAPPY TO BE HERE TODAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF ISSUE ONE
ON YOUR AGENDA RELATED TO THE
HIGH SPEED RAIL AUTHORITY STRAP
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUSINESS PLAN
THE OPERATING ENGINEERS
RECOGNIZE THE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE BY THE
AUTHORITY ON THIS PROJECT OVER
THE PAST THREE YEARS. INCLUDING
MAKING MAJOR HEADWAY IN A CENTER
DESIGN WORK TRIPLING THE NUMBER
OF STRUCTURES AND CONSTRUCTION
AND NEARLY DOUBLING THE MILD OF
GUIDE WORK OPEN FOR WORK GIVEN
ITS PROGRESS AND WHAT IT MEANS
FOR OUR MEMBERS AND APPRENTICES
WERE CONTRIBUTING TO THIS
PROJECT WE'D LIKE TO THANK THE
BOARD FOR THEIR HARD WORK AND
WOULD APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT OF
THE BUSINESS PLAN. I IF I MAY
ONE ISSUE TOO I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTED MR WHAT'S
AND TRANSPORTATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MOVED TO ONE FORTY. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CASH GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE NEARLY HALF
MILLION MEMBERS OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF THE DRAFT
TWENTY TWENTY TWO BUSINESS PLAN
FOR THE HIGH SPEED RAIL IN THE
CONTINUED FUNDING OF THE PROJECT
THE THOUSANDS OF MIDDLE CLASS
JOBS CREATED AND THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AS STATED BY THE
CHAIR'S COMMENTS REGARDING
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. LIKE THE
BOSTON PROJECT AND LET'S NOT
FORGET THE CRITICISM OF BART AND
THE FANTASY TRAIN TO NOWHERE NOW
WHICH CARRIES FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND TRIPS ON
WEEKDAYS AND HUNDRED TWENTY SIX
MILLION TRIPS ANNUALLY. THIS
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT ONCE
COMPLETED IS OUR LEGACY
INFRASTRUCTUREPROJECT THAT WILL
BE FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN TO ENJOY FOR
DECADES TO COME THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ONE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU SIR MEMBERS
MADE SO LOVE ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA WATER
EMERGENCY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND POLL SUPPORT OF A
MAXIMUM OUT OF FUNDING FOR
TRANSIT AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE ONE OF THE HIGHLIGHTS TWO
IMPORTANT PIECES NUMBER ONE AND
WE'RE- AS THE LARGEST- WATER
FERRY TRANSIT OPERATOR IN THE
STATE WERE NOW UNDER REGULATION
BY CARBON TRANSITION AND YEAR
OLD MISSION FERRIES AND PURCHASE
SHORE SIDE CHARGING
INFRASTRUCTURE. SO FUNDING FOR
THAT TRANSITION IS CRITICAL ALSO
ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE SIDE- WE
ARE REQUESTING THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE MISSION
BAY FERRY LANDING. IN FRONT OF
THE- OF THE WAR YEARS AGO BUT
SHE CENTER WHICH WILL ALLOW US
TO LINK UP WITH- COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE BAY AREA AND BE
SURE SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
HEARING THE OF PORTS- ITEM ON
ANOTHER DATE IF YOU HAVE
COMMENTS ON- ISSUES ONE AND TWO-
THAT'S. ALL WE'RE HEARING PUBLIC
COMMENT ON PLEASE. ARE YOU THERE. WE ARE NOT APPRECIATE THAT MR
CHARGES THAT THAT THAT'S ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA WILL BRIDGE IT ALL SO THAT
THAT LAND AS PART OF EXTEND ARE
TRY SERVICE IN THIS EVER BAY. I
GET IT OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH- I
APOLOGIZE FOR CUTTING YOU OFF
AND. AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONGREGATE BUDGET THANK YOU.
NEXT PLEASE. THE MODEL ONE SIXTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NEW AND
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SPEAKERS
INCREASE TRIED ENOUGH BEHALF OF
MAIL THE CARDIO IN THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE CALLING WITH BRIEF
COMMENT ON ITEM TO- THE
TRANSPORTATION PACKAGE. WITH
RESPECT TO THE RAIL PROGRAM- THE
MAYOR AND THE CITY WE'RE PLEASED
TO SEE THE GOVERNOR'S INCLUSION
OF THE TWO BILLION IN THE
JANUARY BUDGET WE WOULD HAVE
RESPECT REQUEST THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDERING I'M READING THAT
AMOUNTS. TO ENSURE THAT A NUMBER
OF TRANSFORMATIONAL PROJECTS
RIGHT WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF OUR
STATE SURPLUS AND IN PARTICULAR
FEDERAL FUNDING- SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY APART THANK YOU-
THAT WOULD EXTEND BART SIX MILES
FROM. TRANSIT CENTER INTO
DOWNTOWN SAN JOSE AND ANY SANTA
CLARA- TREAT YOU ASK ME TO CARRY
IF YOU POINT OUT PASSENGER EACH
DAY TEST GOT TO BEAR- YESTERDAY
AND SENATE ASSEMBLY CENTER
CORTESE. BUT A NUMBER OF
COMMENTS THAT BRING CHEER TO
BECAUSE YOUR CONCERN WITH OUR-
REQUEST IN TERMS OF INTEREST-
THE JOE DOWN OF. DOLLARS AND
MEET MAKING- NEEDED TO THE TREES
OF. AS THE PRIOR SPEAKER
BACKBENCHER TO SO WITH THAT-
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR- OF
THE CARPENTERS FOR THE- THANK
YOU. BY NOW SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUB COMMITTEE. I'M GAME BUT
FORMER FIFTEEN YEAR CHIEF SENATE
SEVEN MONICA AND CURRENT ELEVEN
YEAR MAYOR BEING AWAY JOIN YOU
BY IN SOME OF THE TWO TO
INTEREST BACK. THE SITTING WHICH
IS WHY OF THE HIGHER GROWING
HOUSE AND EMPLOYMENT CENTERS IN
THE UNITED. ABSENT TRANCE IN A
MAY BRIDGE ACTIVITY CENTER AND
OF VEHICULAR TRIPS SHOULD WITH
NEW JOBS RETAIL ENERGY. AND
RESIDENTS ARE PER. IS EXPECTED
DURING. THE NEW L. A. METRO K.
LINE WILL PROVE TRANSIT TO THE
CITY BEING WOULD TRADE CONNECT
ALSO KNOWN AS I. P. C. WILL
COMPLETE THE CALL. FOR LAST MILE
GAP BETWEEN THE COUNTY METRORAIL
SYSTEM AND THE CITY'S NEW ACTIVE
CENTERS THE ITC'S OF L. ELECTRIC
POWER AUTOMATED TRANS SYSTEM
WITH THREE NEW TRANSIT STATIONS
THE IDC WILL PLAY A CRITICAL
ROLE DURING MAJOR ENTERTAINMENT
EVENTS ESPECIALLY DURING THE
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT SUMMER
OLYMPIC GAMES THE CITY OF THE
FORMER MILLION DOLLAR GAP TO
FULLY FUND THE I. T. ON THE
BUDGET SURPLUS. THE STATE HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE HISTORIC
INVESTMENTS IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THANK THE IBM PROJECT IN THE
CITY OF ENGLISH. I KNOW YOU'RE
SO READ MILLION WERE THE HOLD
PEOPLE TO. WORK ON TIME. THE IN
SHOVEL FOR THE- SO I YIELD REST
OF MY. THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD GOOD HEAR FROM YOU CHIEF.
THANK YOU YOUR DATE OF ARE. AND
ONE THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. A
GOOD MORNING. EVERYONE REMEMBERS
CHAU CREW ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
COUNCIL FLAVORS AND I'LL BE
HAPPY ALL OF THE SEVENTY
THOUSAND HARD WORKING MEN WHEN
IN CALIFORNIA I WANT TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT UP TO TWENTY
TWO. TWENTY TWENTY TWO HIGH
SPEED RAIL PLAN AS WELL AS THE
GOVERNOR'S TRAFFIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PROGRAM- WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE WORK YET. THAT
HAS DONE TO IMPROVE PROJECT
DELIVERY. OF THE LARGEST
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGNOSTICATION. CALIFORNIA THE
CHANCE TO LEAD THE WORLD ONCE
AGAIN WE HAVE ASIAN
INFRASTRUCTURE CONNECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES CREATING GOOD JOBS
ADDRESSING CLIMATE CHANGE AND
ENSURING EQUITY. HIGH SPEED RAIL
BRINGS EXACTLY THAT BUT NOT THIS
IS A CENTRAL VALLEY BUT AT SOME
POINT ACROSS THE STATE. DESPITE
THE PANDEMIC HYPHY WILL
CONTINUES AT INCREDIBLE PACE THE
PROJECT HAS CREATED BIGELOW
FIFTY TWO HUNDRED GOOD PAYING
JOBS WITH AN AVERAGE OF ELEVEN
HUNDRED WORKERS A DAY AT DOZENS
OF CONSTRUCTIONS BY TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. CONSTRUCTION
JOBS HAVE DOUBLED SINCE WENTY
EIGHTEEN IT IS VITAL THE
REMAINING BOND APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE THERE'S NO COST ONE
DAY THE APPROVED BY LEGISLATURE
AND CONTINUE THE SUCCESS AND THE
CONSTRUCTION OF PROJECTS
CURRENTLY UNDERWAY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION. OF
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU. NINE
SEVEN TWO PLEASE GO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN WAS MANUALLY ON BEHALF
OF THE FOUR OF ONE B. IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF ISSUE NUMBER THREE
THE SUPPLY CHAIN RESILIENCY AND
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS WE THANK
GOVERNOR WE'RE AN- WE'RE HEARING
GOT A COMMENT ON THE ISSUES ONE
AND TWO TODAY. WE'RE WITH PUSHED
OFF ALL THE OTHER ISSUES TO A
FUTURE MEETING- PROBABLY A
MARKET SHARE OF. GREAT THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SORRY ABOUT
THAT. BUT A LINE TWENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
DANNY CONDOM PRESIDENT CEO OF
THE U. S. HIGH SPEED RAIL
SOCIAIS HAITIAN AND CONVENER OF
COALITION WHICH IS CHAIRED BY A
BIPARTISAN GROUP OF THREE FORMER
SECRETARIES OF TRANSPORTATION
INCLUDING RAY LAHOOD. NORMAN AT
ANY ANTHONY FOX ON BEHALF OF THE
COALITION AND THE ASSOCIATION
ITS MEMBERS WE SUPPORT THE RAPID
COMPLETION OF THE CALIFORNIA
HIGH SPEED RAIL PROJECT. ENERGY
TO MOVE THE PROJECT FORWARD BY
RELEASING THE STATE FUNDS IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET SETTING THE
STATE UP TO RECEIVE SUBSTANTIAL
FEDERAL FUNDING TO ADVANCE THIS
IMPORTANT PROJECT AND THIS
INCLUDES A FULL SYSTEM WOULD
DOUBLE TRACK FULLY ELECTRIFIED
THE SAME IN EVERY HIGH SPEED
RAIL SYSTEM AROUND THE WORLD.
THE CALIFORNIA HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT WILL MOVE AMERICA INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY AND YOU
ARE LEADING THE WAY YOU ALL
DESERVE A LOT OF CREDIT AS A
STATE FOR TAKING THIS BIG AND
DIFFICULT LEAP IT'S NEVER EASY
BEING THE FIRST AT SOMETHING BIG
AND IMPORTANT LIKE THIS. BUT
WILL PAY OFF MANY TIMES OVER AND
ALL YOU HAVE TO DO IS LOOK AT
THE TWENTY PLUS NATIONS AROUND
THE WORLD THAT HAVE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AND OF ALL BENEFIT IN ALL
THE WAYS WE TALK ABOUT JOBS NEW
FAST MOBILITY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ACCESS EQUITY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INCREASED TOURISM.
TRANSLATED ELEMENT AND MORE WE
URGE YOU TO CARRY THE PROJECT
FORWARD AND LEAD TO DELIVER ALL
THESE BENEFITS TO CALIFORNIANS.
AND THE REST OF AMERICA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY. ONE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GAFFER YOU MISTER SHARED
MEMBERS ALEX WALKER WHICH CAME
TO THE BAY AREA RAPID TRANSIT
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS DEPARTMENT-
BAR WE WANT TO REITERATE- FOR
ITEM ONE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
FOUR POINT TWO BILLION FROM PROP
ONE EIGHT OCCIDENTAL BALLET HIGH
SPEED RAIL NOT THE ONE TO-
REITERATE OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
LETTER DATED FEBRUARY SIXTEENTH
THE KMART BAY AREA. TRANSIT
SYSTEMS- FOR TEN BILLION
DOLLARS- FROM GENERAL FUND IN
FOR FIVE BILLION FOR PUBLIC
TRANSIT TWO BILLION FOR ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION A BILLION FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCE- WE BELIEVE
THAT BOB. THAT CONNECTING THESE
PROJECTS- ARE ESSENTIAL TO OUR
RECOVERY FROM BAY AREA IN THE
BAY AREA AS WE RECOVER MORE
SLOWLY IN SOME WAYS FIVE ARE
ARE- ARE RIDERSHIP WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THIS REGIONAL EQUITY AS WE
ARE RECEIVING THE FUNDS WE
SUPPORT THIRTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
FORMULA GROWTH AND COMPETITIVE
MIX- FOR THOSE FUNDS WE HAD THAT
LAID OUT IN- THAT LETTER AND
NEIL GORE COULD FOR TO ENGAGING
WITH YOU ON OTHER ISSUES SUCH AS
THE OPERATING FUNDING WALL
GETTING WITHIN THE- THE-
APPROPRIATIONS- HOME WITH
ANOTHER ISSUES ON OUR- OUR
DOCTORS WERE. WE THANK YOU. FOR
YOUR WORK. THANK YOU. ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MICHAEL TURNER ON BEHALF
OF THE L. A. COUNTY METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY AND OUR
BOARD WOULD LIKE TO URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER CONTINUE TO CONSIDER
THE GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY PACKAGE
WHICH IS A PROPOSAL THAT HAS
BEEN SIGNED BY ALL THIRTEEN OF
OUR BOARD MEMBERS REPRESENTING
THE TEN MILLION PEOPLE THAT LIVE
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY THAT
PROPOSALS ALSO BEEN ENDORSED BY
A NUMBER OF THE COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS REPRESENTING THE
EIGHTY EIGHT CITIES. IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AS WELL WE WOULD
LIKE TO FOCUS YOUR ATTENTION ON
INCREASING THE FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC TRANSIT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PROJECTS THAT ARE BOTH
SHOVEL READY AND SHOVEL WORTHY
THAT COULD USE THAT MONEY VERY
QUICKLY THOSE ARE THE WEST SANTA
ANA TRANSIT BRANCH PROJECT THE
FOOTHILL EXTENSION THE GOAL LINE
AND THE INGLEWOOD TRAN THE
CONNECTOR IS MENTIONED BY MAYOR
BUT- WE'D ALSO LIKE YOU TO
CONSIDER ORIENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT PROJECTS.
BACK TO THE OLYMPICS THE WORLD
IS COMING TO LA FOR A NUMBER OF
EVENTS NOT TO MENTION NOT JUST
THE OLYMPICS AND PARALYMPICS AND
WE THINK THAT MONEY SHOULD BE
FOCUSED ON SUPPORTING THOSE
GAMES AND ABOUT THE NUMBER
SHOULD BE SIGNIFICANTLY HIGHER.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW MANY
MILLION CANADIANS ARE IN I WORK
FOR BC I ONE OF THE ONE OF THE
SIX HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
SMALL BUSINESSES- OPERATED WITH
WITH A HIGH SPEED RAIL AS A DVD
- WORKING ON FIFTY TWO THIRTY I
CAN PUSH ATTEST IN PRAGUE. BY
THE FACT AND WHAT TO SUPPORT
THAT FOR THE ACCEPTANCE OF THE
TWENTY BUSINESS- AND A SOCIAL
RESIDENT ARE BORN AND RAISED I
ALSO THAT TO. SAY THAT THE
FEDERAL DESERVES LOOK AHEAD TO
AND WITHOUT THE SUPPORT OF THE
FUNDS BE ALLOCATED TO THE
FEDERAL I HAD THE BILL OFF THANK
YOU. YOU VERY MUCH. THIRTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH I HAVE
MORNING AFTER REMEMBER OF THE
FACT THANK YOU THE MEMBER AT THE
NUMBER THE STATE NEXT RECOGNIZED
VEHICLE OF THE HAS THE FUNNY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECTING CIRCLE
LIKE OURS MY NAME IS GETTING ON
THE FIELD ON THE PATH CARE. I
REQUEST THE CABINET ACCOUNT I'M
OF THE CITY OUT I MEAN THE PART
BOB I DO WANT TO OUT OF QUITE
YOU CAN AT AND THAT BETTER-
COMMITTEE AT- I LOOKED. WE ARE
NOT THE TOP TO SUPPORT THE
GROWING UP IN TEN FUNDING FOR
THE NEXT. BY TRUMP ABILITY
MENTION PRIOR I BEEN PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNE CORRECTIVE TO USE
STATE DOLLARS NEVER KIND OF
FUNDING CLOSE A WITH A ANAGRAM
WHICH WILL SUPPORT A LOT OF WORK
AND INCLUDING HOW A PART. NOT
THE LEAST URGE HAVE COME TO
CONSIDER. HEALTH CARE MORE
FEDERAL FUNDING I WANTED I THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THE TIME THANK YOU. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COMMENTS. THANK YOU
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I AM DAVID YOU CAN
GO ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
LITTLE TOOK A BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION I WOULD LIKE TO YOU
TO CONSIDER TRANSPORTATION
FUNDING UNDER ITEM TWO. WORK LOS
ANGELES METROS WEST SANTA ANA
BRANCH PROJECT THAT WILL BRING
MUCH NEEDED RAIL TRANSIT FROM
DOWNTOWN LOS ANGELES UNDERSERVED
AREAS IN THE SOUTHEAST OF LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. LITTLE TOKYO
GIVING ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
YEAR OLD ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITY ONE OF THREE REMAINING
JAPAN OF THE UNITED STATES WITH
GREAT CULTURAL EVENTS AND
HISTORICAL SIGNIFICANCE. 42% OF
OUR HOUSING IS AFFORDABLE WE
ALONG WITH THE MEMBER CITIES
ILLEGAL WEAPONS TRANSIT AND THE
GATEWAY CITY COUNCIL OF
GOVERNMENTS ALL NEED ACCESS TO
TRANSIT THE COMPLETION OF THE
PROJECT WILL PROVIDE ACCESS TO
THE STATION AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
GOOD PAYING JOBS HEALTH CARE
EDUCATION CULTURAL DESTINATIONS.
I DOUBT THAT YOU'RE COMMITTEE
SUPPORTED APPROVED FUNDING FOR
THE MOST POPULOUS METRO WEST END
BRANCH. WILL PROJECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
I'M JONATHAN CASSIDY KING ON
BEHALF OF SPUR AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA SPUR SUPPORTS
THE ELECTRIFIED HIGH SPEED RAIL
PLAN AND THE RELEASE OF PROP ONE
EIGHTY FUNDS AND WE ENCOURAGE
THE AUTHORITY AND LEGISLATURE TO
DOUBLE DOWN ON SUPPORTING STRONG
GROWTH. NEAR HIGH SPEED RAIL
STATION. AN ITEM TWO WE
ENCOURAGE GREATER FLEXIBILITY TO
TRANSIT OPERATORS TO USE GENERAL
FUND DOLLARS TO SUPPORT TRANSIT
SERVICE AND FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR REGION'S.
CONTENT THIS TRANSIT
TRANSFORMATION ACTION PLAN. AND
FINALLY WE AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COMMENTS ABOUT THE NEED
TO DELIVER CAPITAL PROJECT MORE
QUICKLY AND COST EFFECTIVELY.
BIRTH ADVOCATING FOR A SPECIFIC
BUT THE PREPARATION TO HELP
STUDY WHY PROJECTS TEND TO COST
SO MUCH AND THE PILOT IMPROVE
PROJECT DELIVERY TECHNIQUES IN
THE BAY AREA. WE HOPE YOU'LL
SUPPORT THIS EFFORT TO INFORM
BETTER TRANSIT PROJECT DELIVERY.
THE NEW INTRODUCTION FUNDING
WILL BE TRANSFORMATIVE ONLY IF
WE CAN MEET PROJECT TIMELINES
BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ACTION DECLINED THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH HI THIS IS DAVID
CAMERON IDEAS SHIFTED TO THE
DIRECTOR OF THE TEAMSTERS
CONFERENCE OUTSIDE THE PURPLE OF
SERVING OTHER BY. TEAM THAT
APART OF TRADE AND I'M IN
WASHINGTON DC NOW MEETING WITH
THE F. R. A. N. TO DO J. AND I
DO TO THIS VERY CLOSELY I'VE
HEARD YOUR CONCERNS I UNDERSTAND
THEM I THINK THAT- ASSEMBLY
WOMAN FRIEDMAN MAKES A VERY GOOD
POINT THAT IT NEEDS TO CONNECT
WITH. A MAJOR ECONOMIC ENGINE
LIKE LOS ANGELES SAN JOSE OR SAN
FRANCISCO BUT I WANT YOU TO
KNOW. THAT THE FEDS ARE WATCHING
VERY CLOSELY BECAUSE THEY NEED
TO KNOW THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ALSO BEHIND THE
SYSTEM AS A TRANSITION MEMBER I
RECOMMENDED THAT- THE STE THE.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BE READY TO.
OUR AGO- NO FOLLOW UP SEVEN
DOLLARS BUT TO GET THE FED
BEHIND IT. THE STATE HAS TO BE
BEHIND IT. I UNDERSTAND THERE'S
A LOT OF PROBLEMS THIS IS
ARGUABLY THE SINGLE LARGEST
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT IN THE
HISTORY OF THE NATION. AND WITH
THAT IS GOING TO COME CHALLENGES
COST OVERRUNS DELAYS AND
PROBLEMS. IT IS PART OF THE
TERRITORY WITH ANY LARGE PROJECT
I URGE YOU. TO STAY BEHIND IT
BECAUSE THE WAY TO GET THERE IS
TO STAY WITH IT AND NOT STOP NOW
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FIFTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN VERY WHEN I THINK ABOUT
THAT CHRISTIANITY ON BEHALF OF
CATCH WE ACTUALLY MEDICAL A
COALITION LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE ALONG WITH SEVERAL
OTHER SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO
BEGIN AGENCY. BUT WE WANTED TO
EMPATHIZE THE OF COUPLE ITEMS-
IT'S WE WERE WE WERE. REQUEST
PRIOR OF BY TRANSIT OPERATIONS
AND MEET I THANK PROGRAM. TO THE
CAP AND OPERATION DIEM AT
BILLION EACH ADDITIONAL WE WOULD
REQUEST CRITICAL FUNDING SUPPORT
INVESTMENT AND ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION AND KIND THAT
WERE. PROGRAMS SUCH AS AN
AUGMENTATION TO THE EIGHTEEN
PROGRAMMING THE I'M NOT A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR IN ENSURE THAT IS
PLENTY BEYOND A BACKLOG IN YOU.
AND THANK YOU. SURE WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN CUTE TIME OFF THANK
YOU VERY JIM THANK YOU FOR A WHO
PER IN THE MEETING TODAY
COLLUDING THOSE WHO JUST GAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BE BACK
WITH ANOTHER HEARING NEXT WEEK I
THINK BOB SO WE'LL LOOK FORWARD
TO THAT AND WE WILL STANDS NOW
ADJOURNED.